RESPONSE TO THE COLE BUT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT NON
ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR OVERSIGHT
HEARING IN THE CAPITAL. ON THE
SENATE FLOOR BUT SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY
WITH THE USE OF VIDEO LEADING
SERVICE ARE PARALLEL TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
OILS OFFICE WILL ALSO BE
PARTICIPATING. THROUGH THE
VIDEO CONFERENCE SERVICES. FOR
MEMBERS WILL BE ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY AND FOR PALACE
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES OUR
COMPUTERS. OUR IT PERSONNEL
WILL MUTE AND UNMUTE THE VIDEO
SERVICE WHEN YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
THIS WILL GREATLY AIDED
ELIMINATING ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I
ASK THAT EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A
COMMENT OR QUESTION YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE THE
PROGRAM WANT TO RECOGNIZE TO
SPEAK PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
BEFORE YOU SPEAK. ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USED IN A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR INDIVIDUALS. WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TO PARTICIPATE TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. FOR YOUR REFERENCE
BECAUSE WE WILL NOT BE TAKING
VOTES TODAY ALL PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE AT THE END OF TODAY'S
HEARING. WILL BE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT TO A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY
OPEN YOUR LINE OF THAT THAT YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE BUT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MIGHT
MUSE THE FIVE OR WATCHING THE
HEARING OFTEN PRIOR GIVING TO
THE MALL. PHONE THAT WE CAN YOU
AT LEAST. YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY.
AND ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEDIAN SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT THEIR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LATIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE USE OF NEW ONLINE TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES. WE ARE YOUR
PATIENCE AND INDULGENCE. WITH
THAT TODAY'S HEARING IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO GET AN OVERVIEW
IN HERE INITIAL COMMENTS
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION. AS WE ALL KNOW THE
REVISED BUDGET THAT WE WILL BE
REVIEWING OVER THE NEXT VERY
FEW WEEKS IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT THAN THE BUDGET THAT
THE GOVERNOR PRESENTED TO US IN
JANUARY. DUE TO THE GLOBAL
RECESSION THAT IS A DIRECT
RESULT. OF THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
PANDEMICS. WE FIND OURSELVES
FACING A SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
SHORTFALL AT THE TIME THAT
THERE IS AN INCREASED NEED TO
DEPLOY RESOURCES AND TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. AS
SUCH. WE WILL USE THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE LAST RECESSION
AND AVOID MAKING BUDGET
DECISIONS THAT EXACERBATE THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE ARE ALL FACING.
BOB IT'S HELPFUL THAT THE
THAT TAKES THE BALANCED
APPROACH IN A MANNER THAT
FOCUSES ON PROTECTING OUR
CURRENT LEVEL OF PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. AARON DO ACTIONS THAT
WE ALL HAVE TAKEN OVER THE LAST
DECADE WE ARE IN A MUCH BETTER
POSITION THAT WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN IN THE PAST. A BUDGET
SHORTFALL SUCH AS THIS. HOWEVER
IN ORDER TO STAY ON THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF THE GLOBAL PUBLIC
HEALTH PANDEMICS. WE MUST HAVE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL SUPPORT FOR
BOTH OUR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AS WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE PUSH FOR ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL SUPPORT IN THE COMING
WEEKS WE WILL BE WORKING UNDER
A CONDENSED TIMELINE. BEGINNING
WEDNESDAY AND THROUGH THE
HOLIDAY WEEKEND. EACH BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL HOLD ONE
HEARING TO REVIEW THE MAJOR
PROPOSALS IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
AREA. SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL
MEET ON WEDNESDAY SUBCOMMITTEE
FOUR WILL MEET ON THURSDAY
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE WILL MEET ON
SATURDAY SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILL
MEET SUNDAY AND SOMEONE WILL
MEET ON MONDAY. IN ANY
UNFORESEEN CIRCUMSTANCES WE
WILL THEN HAVE ANOTHER FULL
BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING ON
THURSDAY MAY TWENTY EIGHTH TO
MAKE THE FOR THE TAKE FINAL
ACTION ON THE SENATE VERSION OF
THE BUDGET. THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF TIME TO COMPLETE THE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IN ORDER
TO MEET OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
DEADLINE OF JUNE FIFTEENTH. I
MUST ACKNOWLEDGE ALL OF THE
HARD WORK OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IN PREPARING THE MAY
REVISION. AND THE LA- AND ARE
SENATE BUDGET TEAM IN ALL THE
WORK THEY WILL DO TO GET US
DOCUMENTS WE NEED TO MAKE THE
BEST DECISION ON BEHALF. OF
CALIFORNIA. UNDER THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES IN IS MORE CRITICAL
THAN EVER THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION WORK
TOGETHER TO ENSURE WE ENACT THE
BUDGET. THAT ADDRESSES THE
SHORTFALL BOTH RESPONSIBLY AND
THOUGHTFULLY. WITHOUT
COMPROMISING THE NEEDS OF EVERY
MAN WOMAN AND CHILD WHO'S MADE
pVICE CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OFFER SOME OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU SIR BUT WITH THE VICE
CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO WELCOME
THE NEW MEMBERS OF YOUR CAUCUS
WHO'S JOINED THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TODAY. MADAM CHAIR I
JUST WITH THE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
HARD WORK AHEAD. BUT YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN HERE BEFORE WE WERE
FORTY FIVE BILLION ONE TIME.
I'M QUITE SURE THAT WE CAN DO
IT TOGETHER. AND I'M GLAD TO BE
HERE WITH MY COLLEAGUES CENTER
MORE LACK. IN NEW BUT NOTICED
SENATOR MELENDEZ AND THAT'S
KIND OF A- ADOPTING THAT YOUR
FIRST DUTIES ARE GOING TO BE
HERE ON THIS. HUGE DEFICIT BUT
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE AMERICA WAY
THROUGH IT MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR USUAL
COURTESY SHOULD. SHAKE THAT SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH THAT
COLLEAGUES ARE WILL BEGIN
TODAY'S HEARING WILL. ASK ARE
ACTING SECRETARY TODAY TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
MITCHELL HERE NIELSEN THERE
CABALLERO PRESENT. DOLLY THERE
TO RATHER. HER DAUGHTER PRESENT
LABOR HERE MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ
HERE MONNING HERE. MORE LOCKED
RESIDENTS MORALE. PAN THEIR RAW
HERE SKINNER YEAH MY COUNTY.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
THOSE MEMBERS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FROM
THEIR DISTRICT OFFICES WILL BE
PARTICIPATING IN COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS AND DEBATE TODAY AND
THAT IS SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND SENATOR
BAIL. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
WILL BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY FOR OVERSIGHT
HEARING- FOR THE BUDGET WE'LL
HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE REGARDING THE MAYBE
VISION- I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
REMOTELY MR THIS WHEN I THINK
BACK TO THE GOOD AFTERNOON SIR.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO BE HERE. I'LL KEEP MY
OPENING COMMENTS THREE TO
RESERVE THE BALANCE OF THE
TIMES FOR A MEMBER QUESTIONS.
THE NAY REVISION THAT THE
GOVERNOR RELEASED A LAST
THURSDAY MAY FOURTEENTH IT'S A
BALANCED BUDGET INCLUDES ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN. BILLION
DOLLARS. EXPERTS IN THAT. THE
JUDICIAL USE RESERVE. AND IT
INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS EXPENDITURES. WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS A DIFFICULT
SITUATION AS DISCUSSED IN THE
WEEK BEFORE THE REASON A
REVISION. THE STATE'S CASE IS A
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET PROBLEM WHEN YOU INCLUDE
THE CURRENT YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY THAT
WERE IN USE AND THE BUDGET YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY DASH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WHEN WE LOOK AT A
REVENUES ALONE ALL THREE MAJOR
SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR THE
GENERAL FUND PERSONAL INCOME
TAX SALES AND USE TAX AND
CORPORATE TAX ARE DOWN MORE
THAN 20% TO WHERE WE PROJECTED
THAT THEY WOULD BE IN JANUARY
FOR THE COMING YEAR. OUR CASE
LOAD EXPENSES I'M SORRY YOUR
CASE LEADING ROLE MAKING MEDI
CAL WORKS ARE PROJECTED TO BE
OUT. ON AND THEN WE ALSO KNOW
THAT WE ARE DIRECTLY. ASKING
MONEY TO. THE NINETEEN AND YOUR-
YOUR- ATTACK PUBLIC TELLS SO
WHEN COMES TO SOLVE THIS SIXTY
FOUR GOING DOLLARS BECAUSE WE
ARE TO CON PROPOSED A BALANCED.
THE GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISION
INDEXES. FIRST AMONG THESE IS
GOING BACK TO THE EXTENSIONS
THAT WERE COMPOSED IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET AND THE GOVERNOR
AND THE ADMINISTRATION I HAD
WORKED WITH MANY OF YOU ON
THESE PROGRAMS YOU KNOW
INCREASES FOR YOU SEE AND HEAR
YOU THANKS CAL. AROUND ONE ACTS.
OTHERS THAT WERE EXCITED ABOUT
TO CITED. GIVEN BUDGET THESE
ALSO IN A SHIFT. FUNDS FOR CAN
WERE. FOR SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
HEY CALPERS OBLIGATE OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS. THE SECOND
CATEGORY OF SOLUTIONS RELATES
TO THE USE OF RESEARCH THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND HIGHER
ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE'S HAVE WORKS
GENERALLY OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS TO BUILD A- IT WAS A SIX
HOUR NOTICE RAINY DAY FUNDS.
AND WITH LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP.
AND SO THAT WE COME INTO THIS
YEAR WITH SIXTEEN GOING TWO
BILLION IN A RAINY DAY FUND
ANOTHER NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE STATE. RESTORE
OUSTED YOUR MENTIONED WE ARE A
TRAINED THIS RECESSION IN A
MATTER FISCAL POSITION WE GET A
LAST. SO BUDGET REFLECTS THE
JUDICIOUS USE OF. ARE BOTH IN
THE COMING YEAR BUT ALSO IN THE
YEARS AFTER THAT BECAUSE YOU
KNOW IT'S HIGHLY LIKELY THAT
RECOVERY. THE WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HOW TO
BEGIN AS SOON AS POSSIBLE WILL
LIKELY STRETCH ON BEYOND YEAR.
ANOTHER CATEGORY OUTCOMES WITH
FARMING FROM SPECIAL FINDS MY
CHANGES RELATED TO TRANSFER AND
DEFERRALS OF SOME SPENDING.
BROWN'S BUDGET IN THE COMING
YEAR. WE ALSO INCLUDING
TEMPORARY INCREASING REVENUES
AWAITS THE USE THAT OPERATING
LOSSES CREDITS ON AS WELL AS
BUSINESS. OF CREDITS AND
PUTTING A CAP ON THOSE. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE HELP THE STATE.
NEXT SPRING YOURS. I THINK HERE
MENTIONED FEDERAL FUNDING IS
CRITICAL BOTH IN TERMS OF
BALANCING THIS BUDGET. AS WELL
AS A LONGER TERM FISCAL
POSITION OF THE STATE SO BUDGET
INCLUDES ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
IT ASKED NOT INCREASE FROM
CONGRESS. AS WELL AS AUSTIN'S
PROVIDED THROUGH THE CORONA
VIRUS RELEASED TIMES ON THIS IS
THE FIFTEEN POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. BUT STATE LOCAL. WHICH
ABOUT NINE AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS TO THE STATE. AND WE
PROPOSE AN ALLOCATION FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN THE. NAME OF
MISSION. FINAL AND GIVEN THE
SIZE OF THE BUDGET PROBLEM WE
FACE THIS DOES INCLUDE A
SIGNATURE NUMBER BASED. THESE
ARE CUT TO BE. WHAT WAS IN THE
BUDGET. LAST YEAR AND THIS
INCLUDES IGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS
IN SPENDING ON. K. TWELVE
EDUCATION HIGHER EDUCATION
HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES PORTS. IF
YOU AREAS OKAY NOT RECEIVE SOME
TYPE OF REDUCTION IN THE
NEIGHBORING NATION. BUILDING
THESE FUNDS WITH THE TRIGGER SO
THAT IF THE CONGRESS COMES
THROUGH AND THE PRESIDENT SIGNS
ADDITIONAL RELEASED FOR THE
STATE OF THE LEAST FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS APPROXIMATELY.
THOSE CUTS WILL TRIGGER AUSTIN
THEY WILL BE RESTORED TO THEIR
PRIOR LEVEL MORE THAN MY TWO
YEAR AND I'M HAPPY TO TALK
ABOUT CONTROL SECTION LANGUAGE
THAT WE ARE CLOSED ON OR ANY
OTHER CONSIDERATIONS I STEP
AWAY. THIS IT'S ALL BEING SAID
WE PROPOSED TO FOR THE YEAR
ACCORDING TO A MULTI YEAR FOR
WHICH LOOKS THREE YEARS AFTER
THAT WE ARE STRUCTURAL RIGHT
NOW IN THOSE YEARS GROW OVER
TIME SO WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE%
CONTINUED BUDGET ISSUES TO
ADDRESS AND WE ARE HOPING THAT
THE ADDITIONAL USE OUR
CORRELATES PROVIDED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S NOT ONLY
HELPED TRIGGER ALL KINDS BUT
ALSO HELD THE ADMINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATURE NAVIGATE
THROUGH THESE NEXT COUPLE YEARS
HE CALMLY. I WILL MENTION MONEY
KNOW THAT CALM SAYS SOMETHING
ABOUT YOUR PROBLEMS. THERE IS
ON WHAT WE CAN REDUCE OR WHAT
WE CAN TRANSFER OR WHAT WE CAN
BORROW AS THE CASE MAY BE. BUT
I DO ALSO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
OKAY SOMEWHAT THIS. PRIORITIZE
AND IN PARTICULAR I WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE ELEMENTS PUBLIC
CHANNELS AND SAFETY WHEN IT
COMES NOT ONLY TO. THE RESPONSE
TO COME IN NINETEEN THE-
EMERGENCY THAT IS RIGHT IN
FRONT OF US IN TERMS OF.
CONTAINING THIS KIND AN X. BUT
ALSO FUNDING. FOR OTHER
EMERGENCY CAPABILITIES
INCLUDING INCREASED RESOURCES
CAL FIRE YES. EVEN AS WE CAN
CHANGE THIS KIND AN ACHE WE
KNOW THAT WILL BE ENTERING
ANOTHER WILDFIRE SEASON. THERE
ARE OTHER NATIONAL OR OTHER
DISASTERS ACTION IS LIKE THE
STATE AND SO THIS IS A CORE
RESPONSIBILITY STATE
GOVERNMENT. AND WE DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
MAKE INVESTMENTS. THAT WE
MAKING THOSE. CAN FINALLY WENT
TO WHAT WE CRIER. MENTION THE
IMPORTANCE DURING OUR ASSIST TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE OF THAT IS
NOT DISPROPORTIONATELY ON THE
MOST INCOME POPULATIONS STATE
WHICH- HEALTH IS ALREADY
GEARING AND ONE MAY. REASON WHY
IN THIS CASE ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED NOT MAKING ANY CHANGES
TO MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY KEEPING
CAL WORKS CRANKS AFTER CURRENT
LEVELS AND MAINTAINING THE
CURRENT- COMBINED GRANT LEVELS
FOR SSI. WE HOPE THAT
MAINTAINING THESE INVESTMENTS
INCLUDING AS WELL MAINTAINING
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
FOR THE STATE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR'S MORE
THAN DOUBLED LAST YEAR WILL
HELP PEOPLE. GET THROUGH THIS
TRYING TIME. WHEN THE BUDGET
ALSO INCLUDES SEVERAL MEASURES
WHEN IT RELATES TO ECONOMIC
RECOVERY INCLUDING ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE FOR SMALL BUSINESS
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR.
HAS SET UP A TASK FORCE THAT
SOMEONE JUST WAITERS ARE ON AS
WELL AS PEOPLE IN STAKEHOLDERS
ACROSS SECTORS OF THE STATE AND
WE HOPE THAT THE TASK FORCE THE
ADMINISTRATION WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU ACTUALLY. I NEED
NOT. WELL PUBLIC HEALTH. WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS A BIG WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED TO WORK WITH THE
LIKES. NOW TO GET YOU WHERE YOU
WERE AND WE APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO PARTICIPATE I'VE GOT
SEVERAL OF MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND ON
THE SO WE WERE BY REMOTE YEAH
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SERVICE WHEN OFTEN WILL MOVE
COLLEAGUES TO HEAR THE
PRESENTATION FROM THE LA- UPON
COMPLETION OF HIS PRESENTATION.
ALL OF IT UP FOR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. MR PANIC. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON-
MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING NEED TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING TODAY AND THANK YOU
TO. THE VICE CHAIR AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION
AND- I HAVE A HAND OUT HERE
THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO WALK
THROUGH. AND WHO WE ARE AND YOU
HAVE A COPY AND HOPEFULLY YOU
CAN VIEW IT. SO LET ME BEGIN
WITH. READ RECAPS RESTATING
SOMEWHAT THE- OVERVIEWS AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE PROVIDED I THINK IN
MANY WAYS WE HAVE- SOME
SIMILARITIES WITH HOW WE USE
THE PROPOSAL AND- YEAH WE
CATEGORIZE SOME THINGSA LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY AND ALSO WE
THINK THERE'S AN IMPORTANT
CHOICES FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE IN THE COMING WEEKS SO WE
JUST GO BACK TO- JANUARY
BRIEFLY IF YOU THINK ABOUT
WHERE WE WERE AT THAT TIME THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED BUDGET WITH
A- PROJECTED SURPLUS OF ALMOST
SIX BILLION DOLLARS. AND THE
OUTLOOK WAS MUCH BRIGHTER AT
THAT POINT. BUT THEN AS WE KNOW
WE WERE STRUCK BY THIS- GLOBAL
PANDEMIC THAT THROUGH THE STATE
AND THE NATION AND THE GLOBE
REALLY INTO A SEVERE. ECONOMIC
RECESSION THAT THAT NOT ONLY
WAS SEVERE BUT TOOK TOOK EFFECT
ON VERY QUICKLY. AND AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF THAT- THIS STATE
REVENUES. THE OUTLOOK FOR STATE
REVENUES DETERIORATED
SUBSTANTIALLY. AND RT AS AS- AS
WAS ALREADY MENTIONED THE
REVENUE PROJECTIONS FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR IN THE BUDGET YEAR
WERE REDUCED BY FORTY ONE
BILLION COMPARED TO THE JANUARY
ESTIMATE AND AT THE SAME TIME
THERE IS A CORD EXPENSE
PRESSURE ON EXPENDITURES.
UPWARD EXPENDITURE CRUSHER WAS
IN TWO MAIN AREAS BOTH ON THE
DIRECT COULD BE RELATED
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES BUT THEN
ALSO AS A RESULT OF THE
DECLINING ECONOMIC SITUATION.
IN THE NEED FOR MORE PEOPLE TO.
ENROLL IN OUR SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS THERE IS A HIGHER COST
THE CASELOADS IN OUR IN OUR
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS INADEQUATE.
UPWARD PRESSURE ON ACROSS ALL
OF THIS- IN TAKEN TOGETHER-
RESULTED AND DIG THE GOVERNOR'S
ESTIMATE OF A FIFTY FOUR POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
PROBLEM FOR THE FOR THE CURRENT
AND NEXT YEAR. AND WHAT I HAVE
ON THE SLIDE BEFORE YOU ON THE
FIRST LINE IS IN A SUMMARY OF
THE MAIN REVISION GENERAL FUND
XIN ANIME REVISION. WHAT YOU
SEE THERE IS AS WAS STATED
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN POINT
FOUR BILLION IN REVENUES AND
TRANSFERS IF YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT IT WAS IN JANUARY WAS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE POINTS.
SO THAT'S A NINE POINT 4%
DECLINE AND THIS FIGURE
INCLUDES. SIGNIFICANT TRANSFERS
IN AND SOME REVENUE
AUGMENTATION. THE EXTENDED. I
AM HERE SHOWS A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE POINT NINE BILLION
AND IN JANUARY THAT WAS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE POINT
WHAT SO THAT IS THE THAT IS A
pCHOICES THAT DOES THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES TO MAKE IN THIS YOUR
VISION. IN ADDITION IF YOU THAT
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT
BALANCE IT GOES FROM SIXTEEN
POINT TWO BILLION DOWN EIGHT
POINT FOUR BILLION. YEAH AND
YOU KNOW THEN IT THIS IS A
ANOTHER BIG CHANGE BECAUSE IN
JANUARY WAS PROJECTED THAT THE
STATE WOULD END TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH AN EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT BALANCE.
SIMILARLY THE SAFETY NET
RESERVE. GOES FROM NINE HUNDRED
MILLION DOWN TO FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION. SO THAT IS
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE AFTER THE
GOVERNOR AND DEVELOPED HIS
PROPOSED WAYS TO CLOSE TO FIFTY
FOUR POINT THREE BILLION DOLLAR
ARE PROJECTED BUDGET PROBLEM.
MOVING TO THE NEXT SLIDE. I
WOULD LIKE ON THIS SLIDE TO
WORK KIND OF FROM LEFT TO RIGHT
IF YOU LOOK ON THE LEFT SIDE
THERE THE RED BAR WELL YOU SEE
REALLY IS THE BUDGET PROBLEM
THE FIFTY FOUR POINT THREE
BILLION. AND THE WORK RIGHT
THESE ORANGE SMALLER BARS ARE
THE RELATIVE CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
EACH OF THESE PROPOSED AREAS OF
THAT WILL REDUCE THE BUDGET
PROBLEM. SO SOME OF THESE ARE
IN SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES IN OUR OFFICES VIEW
ALL. YOU HAVE. DESCRIBED IT SO
MANY JUST BRIEFLY TELL YOU HOW
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT THIS. ON
THE FIRST ONE THE BASELINE
ADJUSTMENTS YES. OF COURSE TEN
OF THE TOTAL COULD YOU
SOLUTIONS I DIDN'T. THINGS LIKE
THE INCREASED MATCH FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR THE
STATE'S MEDI CAL PROGRAM BUT IN
IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES AND-
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICE AREA. IT
ALSO REFLECTS AN ADJUSTMENT TO
THE BASELINE BY TAKING OUT WHAT
THE GOVERNOR HAD PROPOSED IN IN
JANUARY AND- WHEN YOU REMOVE
THOSE THAT'S WHAT MAKES AT
THESE BASELINE ADJUSTMENTS. IN
ADDITION WE HAVE AS WAS
MENTIONED TO. THE USE OF BUDGET
RESERVES IN THIS CASE THEY
REPRESENT ABOUT 15% OF THE
TOTAL SOLUTION PACKAGE AND
SEVEN POINT EIGHT BILLION ABOUT
IS FROM THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT AND THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION FROM
THE STATE YOU KNOW RESEARCH.
AND ENSURE THAT THERE IS SOME
NEW AUGMENTATION AND THAT
ACCOUNTS FOR AROUND 8% OF THE
SOLUTION AND IT IS NOT SO MUCH
A BROAD BASED TAX PRIEST BUT-
FOR US EXPLORATIONS REVENUES
THAT WOULD COME IN PARTICULARLY
IN THE CORPORATION. SO MEETING
AT SIX OUR EXEMPTION BUT SOME
BUSINESSES FOR AND THAT WOULD
RAISE ABOUTFOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL THEN I
THE NEXT ITEM IS THE LARGEST
REDUCTION SHOWN ON THIS WHICH
IS ADJUSTING THE K. FOURTEEN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING LEVEL DOWN TO THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEED ACCOUNT FOR
ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT. OF THE
TOP BUDGET LUCIEN'S ALTHOUGH IT
IS OFFSET TO SOME DEGREE BY
SOME OTHER A JOB INSTEAD A
MENTION IN A MOMENT. ARE WE
HAVE BEEN REDUCTIONS THAT
ACCOUNT 41819% OF THE SOLUTIONS.
AND THESE ARE. IN IN KIND OF
TWO BROAD CATEGORIES SOME ARE
SOMEWHAT FLATTERS FLORIDA CROSS
THE BORDER NATURE SIR. FOR
EXAMPLE 10% REDUCTIONS TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION- UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
AND- EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION BUT
THEN. AGAIN PERSON MORE
TARGETED REDUCTIONS ALSO. THANK
THINGS LIKE. YEAH AND SHE'LL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS FOR
EXAMPLE AND THESE THESE
SOLUTIONS IN TOTAL. PRESENTED
ABOUT 18% OF. ALL THE SOLUTIONS.
THEN IN THE NEXT CATEGORY WE
HAVE WHAT ARE CALLED A
CONSCIOUS AND THESE ARE. BUDGET
OF FISCAL TOOLS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS AT ITS DISPOSAL ON THESE
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE- SPECIAL
FUND LOANS TO THE GENERAL FUND
SO YOU'RE REALLY SHIFTING SOME
COSTS TO OTHER FUNDS OF THE
STATE GOVERNMENT BASED ON A
TEMPORARY BASIS. BUT THEY ALSO
INVOLVES. OUR STUDENTS TIME SO.
THAT WOULD BE THE EXAMPLE
MENTIONED ABOUT THE CHANGING
THEIR PLANS FOR THE NEXT FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT. RATHER
THAN MAKING A SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT WITH PAY DOWN THE LONG
TERM LIABILITY IT WOULD
ACCELERATE- TAKE TAKE THAT THE
SAME FINDS AND PUT IT TOWARD
THE CURRENT AND NEXT YEAR.
CONTRIBUTION GO THE LONG TERM
BENEFITS OF MAKING THOSE
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PAYMENTS
TO THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY. AND
THEN IN THE LAST CATEGORY OF
OUR FEDERAL FUNDS BOAST AN
APOLOGIZE THE CAUTIOUS OR ABOUT
11% OF THE SOLUTIONS AND THEN
THE CATEGORY ARE FEDERAL FUNDS
WHICH MAKE UP ABOUT 7% OF THE-
SOLUTION. THE INCLUDED. YOU
KNOW THINGS THE- AT THE FEDERAL
CARES ACT FUNDING WHICH
INCLUDED THE- OPEN RELIEF FUND
GAINED ABOUT THAT THAT THE
STATE WILL RECEIVE ABOUT NINE
POINT FIVE BILLION OF THAT YEAH
AND ALLOCATED TO. PROGRAMS LIKE
HELL WORKS AND HOMELESSNESS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THOSE ARE WILL TOTAL ABOUT
THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION FROM
IN THOSE AREAS. AND THIS. IS
SORT OF A- THE SAME
INFORMATION. PRESENTED AND
SOMEWHAT A TABLE FORMAT WITH
MORE DETAILS ON WILL PASS OVER
THAT ONE. AND ON THE SCHOOL
REDUCTIONS I MENTIONED THAT
THIS REPRESENTED THE LARGEST
ITEM ON OUR BORDER CHURCH BUT
THERE'S SOMETHING IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT IS NOT IS ALTHOUGH WE
ARE REDUCE ENGINE AT.
OPPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
LEVEL TO THE MINIMUM CARE AND
SHE- WE ARE OFFSETTING THAT AT
LEAST IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND
THE- BUDGET YEAR BY PROVIDING
THE SCHOOLS WITH. US FIVE POINT
EIGHT BILLION OF FEDERAL FUNDS
THESE FUNDS ARE WOOD IN THE
MAJORITY OF THESE FUNDS WOULD
GO TO- MITIGATE AGAINST OUR
LEARNING LAS THAT HAS LIKE WE
ARE HERDERS OCCURRING BECAUSE
OF. THE YOU KNOW SITUATION OUR
STUDENTS ARE IN THE CLASSROOM.
AND THEN ANOTHER FIVE POINT
THREE BILLION OF DEFERRALS SO
THESE TWO ITEMS TOGETHER HELP.
BRING BACK THE SUBSTANTIAL IF
NOT ALL OF THIS FUNDING TO THE
SCHOOLS IN THESE TWO YEARS. IN
ADDITION THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
SETTING UP A NEW LONG TERM
OBLIGATION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO THEIR SCHOOL RULES.
THAT WOULD. THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEED FUNDING LEVEL ON A
SOMEWHAT HOT AT A SOMEWHAT
HIGHER PLATEAU GOING FORWARD
ESSENTIALLY RAISING IT FROM
ABOUT 38% 240% OF GENERAL FUND
REVENUES. AND AT THE AT THE
MINIMUM. AND SO. THAT WOULD
DRIVE BEGIN TO BE PAID TO THE
SCHOOLS AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. NEXT I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
TOUCH ON THE CODED RELATED
FINDING. HERE THE MAIN MESSAGE
THAT I WOULD HAVE- FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS AREA IS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE THIS POINT
IS NOT HAVE A VERY DETAILED
WERE CLEAR PICTURE OF WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN IS. AT
THIS POINT THERE ARE STILL SOME
MECHANISMS IN PLACE THAT WOULD.
PROVIDE FOR FUNDING- DISCRETION
OVER HOW TO SPEND FUNDING TO
THE ADMINISTRATION AND WE THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT SOME
OF THESE IDEAS BECAUSE- SOME OF
THE SOME OF THE PROCESSES THAT
WERE PUT IN PLACE SUCH AS THE
SECTION THIRTY SIX- CONTROL
SECTION THIRTY SIX PROCESS WERE
PUT IN PLACE JUST PRIOR TO BUT
WHEN I JUST LAY YOU'RE GOING ON
TO ONE SOCIAL DISTANCE. REQUIRE
BUT NOW THAT IT'S NOT. QUITE
THE SAME WAY WE THINK THAT
MAYBE IT'S TIME TO REVISIT SOME
OF THOSE. AND WE HAVE SOME
SUGGESTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER ON THE SPOT. NOW
HOW DO WE LOOK AT THE PROPOSAL
OVERALL. WELL IN GENERAL WE
THINK THAT THE MIX OF SOLUTIONS
IS GENERALLY WELL BALANCED- IN
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
RECOMMENDED IN OUR SPRING
OUTLOOK FROM JUST A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WE THINK IS A VERY IMPORTANT
AND IN THE BEST OF THE WEB
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
SIR IN ORDER IS BOTH ON THE
FISCAL SIDE AND THE PUBLIC
DECIDE AND SO ON ALTHOUGH THE
GENERAL MIX OF SOLUTION SEEMS
REASONABLE THE LARGEST
DIFFERENT PREFERENCES FOR. HOW
THEY ARE WAITED RULE THIS IS
SIMPLE. COMPONENTS OF THE
PROPOSED SOLUTIONS ARE.
SECONDLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PROPOSED REVENUE SOLUTIONS. WE
THINK THAT THE IDEA OR- SO
SPENDING THAT OPERATION NOT
OPERATING LOSSES AND LIMITING
TAX CREDITS FOR THE CORPORATION
TAX OR A REASONABLE REASONABLE
PLACE TO START AND THEY ARE
LESS BURDENSOME THAN A BROAD
BASED TAX RATE INCREASE. LET'S
KEEP IN MIND THE DIRECT WITH
THEIR PRIMARILY REPRESENT
REVENUE ACCELERATION YOU'RE NOT
AN ONGOING SOURCE OF READING.
THEY'RE ALSO VERY DIFFICULT TO
PREDICT BECAUSE OF CORPORATION
TAXES JUST THE TORIES FOR BEING
DIFFICULT TO PREDICT FIRST
CALLS. AND WE THINK OF IT
THERE'S SOME RISK TO RELYING ON
THIS- AZAR'S SO COMPONENT TO
THE SOLUTIONS AND WE SEE THAT
THERE IS POSSIBLY. AN ARGUMENT
THAT SOME OF THE ESTIMATES IN
THE NAY REVISION ARE SOMEWHAT
HIGH THEY SAID THOSE ACCOUNT
FOR ABOUT FOUR POINT FOR DOING
THIS SINCE. IN THE LAST I HAD
ONE WOULD SOMETHING NINE WAS IS
THAT. OF THE- SPENDING REGARD
SO OF THEM ARE. BUT OTHERS ARE
A LITTLE BIT ONE JUROR IN THERE
STRUCTURE AND SO WE THINK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER IN SOME CASES MAKING
HORSE- STRICT. SURGICAL TYPES
OF REDUCTIONS. IN IN SOME AREAS.
LOOKING AHEAD TO THE MULTI YEAR
BUDGET CONDITION. THE GOVERNOR
DOES MAKE PROGRESS IN
ADDRESSING- THE YOUNG GOING
DEFICIT BUT AS I'M AS WAS
MENTIONED THAT. THE MULTI YEARS
STILL SHOWS IN YOUR BUDGET
PROBLEM FOR THE REMAINDER OF
THE FORECAST RISING WHICH GOES
YOUR TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR.
IT CREATES THIS NEW SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING OBLIGATION FOR THE
SCHOOLS. AND ONE THING ABOUT
THAT IS THAT IN GENERAL OVER
TIME THE ENROLLMENTS ARE
DECLINING STATEWIDE. AND EVEN
BEFORE ADDING THIS NEW
OBLIGATION TO THE SCHOOLS WHICH
WOULD TOTAL ABOUT THIRTEEN
BILLION ONCE IT'S FULLY
IMPLEMENTED. THE SCHOOL FUNDING
WAS GOING TO INCREASE UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REVENUE
FORECAST SUCH THEN EACH YEAR
OUR PEOPLE FUNDING WOULD
INCREASE BY ABOUT 5% WE JUST
THINK THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO THINK CAREFULLY ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE- AT A TIME WHEN OTHER
PARTS OF THE BUDGET WILL BE
NECESSARILY SQUEEZED IN ORDER
TO. BRING THE STATE'S FINANCES
BACK INTO ALIGNMENT IT WOULD
YOU KNOW BE SOMETHING THAT-
YOU'D WANT TO BE QUITE
CONSCIOUS ABOUT MAKING THIS
CHOICE. WE ALSO TAKE WE ALSO
HAVE SOME QUESTION WITH REGARD
TO THE PENSION PROPOSALS. WOULD
SHIFT COSTS TO THE FUTURE YEARS
AS I SAID THERE'S ALSO A
PROPOSAL TO SPEND THE- ZERO
POINT 5% AND STATUTORY FORMULA
TO INCREASE TO THE CAL STIRS.
FUNDING CONTRIBUTION FROM THE
STATE TO THE- ALISTAIR SYSTEM
AND WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THAT
SAID SOMEONE OF A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT. AND WELL WE THINK
THAT IT DOES MAKE SENSE AND IS
WARRANTED TO CONTINUE TO SEEK
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE. AS THE
CHAIR MENTIONED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SESSION. WE
WERE JUST POINT OUT THAT AID IF
IT DID COME THROUGH TWO WERE
SIMILAR TO THE- FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE THE CAME WITH THE
AMERICAN REINVESTMENT IN
RECOVERY ACT IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE. THAT AGES GENERALLY
ALMOST CERTAINLY GOING TO BE
VERY LIMITED SO IT WOULD BE IN
PLACE FOR ONE OR TWO YEARS
PROBABLY. AND IF YOU THINK
ABOUT THE SOLUTIONS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PUTTING FORWARD THAT
ARE SUBJECT TO THESE TRIGGERS
THERE ALMOST ALL ONGOING
PROGRAMS AND SO. ESSENTIALLY WE
WOULD GET THIS TEMPORARY
FUNDING AND THE ONGOING FINDING
WOULD BE TRIGGERED BACK ON. AND
THEN YOU THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
BE FACED WITH A STRUCTURAL
BUDGET ISSUE IN THE SUBSEQUENT
YEARS WHEN THE FEDERAL AID
WE'RE TO PHASE OUT SOONER JUST
ONE OTHER CONSIDERATION. LAST
MEAL JUST BY SAYING. THE
GOVERNOR MAINTAINS IN HIS NAY
REVISION AND SOME PROPOSALS
THERE'RE ALL TOGETHER NEW OR
REORGANIZATIONS OF CERTAIN
DEPARTMENTS LIKE THE DEPARTMENT
OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF BETTER JOBS
HIGHER WAGES AND WE THINK IF
YOU TO CONSIDER THAT THE RECENT
PAST THERE ARE TWO MONTHS OR SO
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE REALLY
HASN'T HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE FULL INSURANCE IN THE WAY
THAT IT WITH TRADITIONAL. YOU
HAVE CENTER THESE FOR CONCERT.
WE THINK YOU MAY WANT TO CAN
JUST. SOME OF THESE. ISSUES TO
LATER AT POLICY PROCESS OR
PERHAPS EVEN THE NEXT BUDGET
CYCLE AND THEN FINALLY IN SOME
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR
NEW SPENDING ON OPENING WAITED
ACTIVITIES. HE IS PROPOSING
THAT WE- IN THE COUNTRY CAPTION
PROCESS THEN IN THERE- SUFFERS
FROM SOME SHORTCOMINGS IN OUR
VIEW IN PARTICULAR THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DOESN'T HAVE AN
ESPECIALLY LONG TIME TO REVIEW.
THESE THESE PROPOSED SPENDING
ACTIVITIES AND ALSO YEAH IN
SOME CASES IT GIVES THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE FAIRLY BROAD
LATITUDE TO MAKE CHANGES IN HOW
THE FUNDS ARE SPENT WE REALLY
THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD BE SURE TO LOOK OUT FOR
ITS OWN- THE STORY AND YEAH
IT'S PRODIGIES IN THIS. SO WITH
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AS
WELL- WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE. MR PECK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUT COLLEAGUES- WE'RE
NOW GOING TO TRANSITION TO
MEMBER QUESTIONS AND I'M GOING
TO JUMP START AS- WELL BUT I AM
LOOKING FOR HANDS TO BE RAISED-
I SO FAR HAVE SENATORS ROCK AND
KNEELS. HAN MINING WHY CAL SKI
DURACELL WITH THE- UHHUH. HAVE
A YEAR THANK YOU. THE AND
SENATOR MORLOCK. THE.
SENATOR
STERN I SAW YOUR REYES TAN AND
SENT TO SKINNER I HAVE YOU AS
WELL SO THAT WHEN WE GET
STARTED COLLEAGUES- I
APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOU. MISTER
THIS WILL NOT THAN IN THE
PADDOCK- RAISING THE ISSUE OF
THE CONTROL SECTION- YOU ALL
ARE WELL AWARE THAT- THE
LEGISLATURE TOOK ACTION ON THE
DAY WE RECESS IN THE FORM OF SB
EIGHTY NINE. THAT EXTENDED BOB
BROUGHT A STORY TO THE
ADMINISTRATION TO SPEND A
BILLION DOLLARS. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WHILE WE
WERE RECESSES MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT. HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
MILLION OF THE ONE BILLION
REMAINS AVAILABLE FOR URGENT
SPENDING ME. BUT THE REAL
QUESTION FOR ME- COMES. IT IS
ON YOUR ONGOING REQUEST FOR THE
IMPROPER THIRTY FOUR IN
ADDITIONAL TWO POINT EIGHT
BILLION. AND IT'S GOT TO. WHY
IS IT MINISTRATION BELIEVE THEY
NEED TO HAVE THE THIRTY TO.
THIS SHOULD WITHOUT VISION OF
LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL
PARTICULARLY SINCE WE ARE NOW
BACK IN SESSION. THE SERVICE
WHEN OFTEN. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I THINK WHEN IT COMES
SAID TODAY TWO POINT NINE
BILLION CONTINGENCY RESERVE I
KNOW YOU MENTIONED THE FIRST
POINT I WANT TO MAKE A SOUND
YOU KNOW WE NOTICES ARMING
WRIST WAS ALL. WOULD YOU WANT
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF IN
TERMS TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS THE APPROPRIATE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE LEGISLATURE AND WE HAD IN
OUR CORPORATE GOAL ALL. NOT
EVER SINCE THAT WE ARE. WE DO
THINK THAT IT IS IN IN CASE
PLEASE WHETHER IT'S AN ABSURD.
IN NINETEEN AGAIN OR I NEED TO
STAY UP COSTS CAPACITY CAPACITY
THERE IS A SECOND OR SOME OTHER
TYPE OF RELATED EMERGENCY
RELATED TO THE NEXT WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE THAT THERE IS. NO
QUICKLY AS NOBODY REALLY. THIS
A ONE IN A SENSE. MARGINS AND
NOBODY REALLY KNOWS HOW IT'S
GOING TO HOURS ON EACH OF THE
OVERALL ESTIMATE IS TO POINT
NINE GOING. BUT WE ESTIMATING
CONSISTENT WITH OUR OTHER.
BECAUSE IN NINETEEN APPROPRIATE
I APPROPRIATE EIGHT. THAT WE
HAVE OUTSIDE OF THIS THE
MAJORITY OF BATTLE BE REIMBURSE.
SO TO SUM IT UP THE REASON HAVE
IT IN IS. WE SHOULD CHANGED BUT
WE DO UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE
OF CONSUL COLLABORATE. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORK WITH YOU
TO GET INTO. APRIL THAT LET ME
JUST US ALL THE IF THAT WE
AGREE TO END THE UP AND SECTION
THIRTY SIX WAS A REQUEST TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WHAT THEY SEVENTY TWO
HOURS AROUND. VERSES THE
TYPICAL SECTION TWENTY EIGHT
CONTROL SECTION THAT ALLOWS FOR
THIRTY DAY TURN AROUND AND SELL
IT FROM YOUR YOU'RE SUGGESTING
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION FEELS.
THAT EVEN WITH THE LEGISLATURE
BACK IN SESSION BUT YOU STILL
NEED BROADER AUTHORITY WITH
SEVENTY TWO HOUR NOTICE IN
TERMS OF. YOUR ABILITY TO STAND
ALL THREE TIMES NOW DO WE-
APPROVED MARCH SIXTEENTH. WOULD
YOU WANT TO RESERVE THAT HAS A
CONTAINS- JUST BECAUSE WE DON'T
NOW HOW THE EMERGENCY IS GOING
TO GO AND WE DO WANT TO BE
COMPARED YES. HERE IS HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION DETERMINED THAT
SHE WOULD NEED AN ADDITIONAL
TWO POINT NINE BILLION. YES SO
ON THIS- I HAVE Y COLLEAGUE TO
RESET CALVERT ON THE WIND SO
I'LL JUST SAY THAT WE HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENTLY REVISING OUR
EXPENDITURES WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE PROVIDED ACTS YOU AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND INITIAL
ASSN SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT WAS THE GROWTH. IN THE NAY
REVISION WE ARE PUTTING OT AND
NOW AND NOW ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS ON THE DAY WE
ALSO IN ADDITION TO THE
ESTIMATES THAT WE HAVE AT THIS
POINT IN TIME ONE BUILDING
INCIDENTS IN CASE CONDITIONS
CHANGE. OVERALL ACCENT
FURNITURE TERESA CALVERT
PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL. I IN
AND JUST TO PROVIDE A BIT MORE
FOR ME ON THE TYPE OF ACTIVE
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THAT
ESTIMATE SOMEWHERE TO HAVE LAID
OUT AB AGENTS IN OUR SUMMARY
PAGES IT A PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
CRITICAL MEDIC. DIGITAL
HOSPITAL SEARCH FOR AND THERE'S
ALSO THE FOR HOW WORKERS SPORTS
ACTIVE ON FOR THERE'S THE STATE
MORAL AS WELL AS STATE RESPONSE
OPERATIONS AND OTHER SUPPORT
SERVICES. OR IS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING. BUT AGAIN MUCH IS TO
BE DETERMINED AND- OR STILL
WORKING DIRECTLY ONES. I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
KNOW THAT IT'S THREE TIMES THE
AMOUNT THAT WE APPROVED IN
MARCH- AND YOU'RE NOT SPENT AT
THIS POINT THE FULL BILLION
ANOTHER QUESTION WITH REGARD TO
THE CONTROL SECTIONS- YOU ALSO
INCLUDE TO CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN POINT NINE ELEVEN POINT
NINE FIVE. RELATED TO FEDERAL
AID THAT WE RECEIVE INTO
COMBAT- CALLED NINETEEN HOW THE
USE OF THE FUNDS PURSUANT TO
THESE CONTROL SECTIONS BE
DETERMINED AND FROM YOUR FIRST
WHAT WILL THE LEGISLATURE
PLAYING IN MAKING THAT
DETERMINATION. YES WHEN IT
COMES TO THE EAST CONTROL
SECTIONS THESE RELATE TO THAT
FEDERAL AID AS YOU MENTIONED.
INCLUDING SOME OF THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT AND THE STATE-
UNDER THE MAYOR NATION IT'S IT
IS AN ACTIVE THAT IF THESE
PROVISIONS ARE NOT. LEGISLATURE
WOULD NEED TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AS WELL. THE
PROVISIONS OF THE CORONA
REQUIRES SOMEBODY FIND ARE
RELATIVELY STRICT. STRICTER
THAN MANY. OF US LOOK LIKE AND-
BOLD AND CONGRESS MIGHT MAKE
SOME CHANGES THERE. BUT THE
OVER FLAW HERE IS THAT WE TO
MAKE SURE THAT ANY SENDING
WHETHER IT HAPPENS AT THE STATE
LEVEL OR AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. IS
ALIGNED WITH THE GUIDANCE. OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO THAT
THEY ARE NOT PULLING BACK THE
MONEY AFTER THIS ACT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS EMERGENCY ANY
PARTICULAR. I TO PROVISIONS ARE
NUMBER ONE- ON THE MONEY TO BE
USED FOR SPECIFIED PURPOSES AND
NOT NECESSARILY SALES BUDGET
CAPS ON AND THEN. NUMBER TWO.
IN MY CASE. NUMBER THE END OF
THE COUCH YEAR RATHER THAN JUST
YEAR WE ALL OF US ABOUT THIS
AND LOCAL LEVELS ARE YOU TO.
I'M SO THAT'S THE OVERALL GONNA
TRY OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE. OKAY
WE ARE THINKING ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE COMMUNICATIONS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY
WORK THROUGH THE COMING MONTHS
IT AGAIN I THINK FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE IS NOT MERELY
COMMUNICATION IT'S FULL
ENGAGEMENT AND PARTICIPATION
YES WELL HERE FROM YOUR STAFF
MEMBER. SINCE OFTEN DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
POINTED OUT AND THERE HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT. OF
UNCERTAINTY AND- FLEXIBILITY
THAT HAS REALLY BEEN NEEDED AS
WE TRACK AND MANAGE THE FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE. AND WE
WANT TO BE SURE THAT THE STATE
FULLY SPENDS BE FEDERAL
RESOURCES CONSISTENT WITH THE
FLEXIBILITY PROVIDED. TWO
KILLER EARLY AS WE THINK ABOUT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND PUBLIC
SAFETY AREA. BUT WE WANT TO
REMAIN NIMBLE AS GUIDANCE HAS
EVOLVED OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS
AND WE EXPECT TO CONTINUE TO
MOVE ALL OVER THE COMING WEEKS
AND MONTHS. I BELIEVE THAT WE
FULLY APPRECIATE THE NEED FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION TO BE NIMBLE
AND BE A POWER TO RESPOND IN A
TIMELY MANNER FOR THE CRISIS
WHICH IS WHY THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED. I'LL GIVE YOU THAT
BROAD AUTHORITY MARCH SIXTEENTH
BUT I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT. THE ADMINISTRATION FIND A
WAY TO BALANCE YOUR ABILITY TO
RESPOND TIMELY WITH A GOOD
KNOWLEDGE IN THE ROLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE MUST PLAY TO
PARTNER WITH YOU. TO MAKE
DECISIONS THAT ARE IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS I
HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION AND COME UP
WITH. SOMETHING THAT MEETS THENEEDS. OF BOTH. BOB VERY
QUICKLY JUST LAST TWO QUESTIONS
FOR ME AND THEN I WILL PART TO
SENATOR ROBB. IT'S BEEN DONE IN
THE PAST TO HELP MITIGATE
BUDGET SHORTFALL DOES NOT KNOW
YOUR MAY REVISE INCLUDES
NUMEROUS SPECIAL LOAN SPECIAL
FUND LOANS WILL ANY OF THESE
LONG IMPACT THE ABILITY OF THE
SPECIAL FUNDS TO SUPPORT THEIR
CORE MISSION. MR THIS WILL
HAPPEN YES. YES SO. THE ANSWER
TO THAT IS THAT THE WAY WITHOUT
RESTRUCTURED- IN ONE THREE WE
MADE SURE THAT WE TOOK INTO
CONSIDERATION BEFORE. TAKING
ANY SPECIAL FUN RUN ON THE
PROGRAM THAT SIGNED IN MIND
ESSENTIAL FARMS ON THE NEED FOR
CASH. IN MAKING SURE THAT
ANYONE CAN DO NAY WITHOUT
CAUSING HARM TO THOSE PROGRAMS
HEY CERTAINLY THE PLAN A COMING
INTO THIS FOR STASHING HOLD
SPECIAL FUNDS LOANS FROM HIGHER
RECESSIONS IN YOUR MENTIONED
I'M SURE THAT. THIS TACTIC HAS
BEEN USED BEFORE WHAT THE PLAN
IS CERTAINLY TO PAY THOSE LOANS
BACK. WAYNE HI THERE THE
PROGRAM NEEDS TO MONEY BACK OR
WAY AND THE GENERAL SIGNS NO
LONGER MEET SOMEONE IN THIS
COURSE AND THESE MONIES TO
BELONG TO THE SPECIAL FUNDS FOR
THEIR PROGRAMS SO WE
DEFINITELY. HAD IN MIND IN
TERMS OF DECIDING WHAT LEVEL OF
LOANS. INTERNAL BORROWING
REVIEWS AND ALTERNATE OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE GREG FOR US THAT
WAS ON THE PHONE. WHO MIGHT BE
ABLE. TO PROVIDE AND SOME
ADDITIONAL. I NEED. YEAH THIS
IS GREG BREASTS WITH TO OF
FINANCE THE FOLLOWING THE FOR
ALL OF VALUE WAITED A AND ONLY-
AMOUNT THAT WERE IN EXCESS OF
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT NEEDED- FOR
THE SHORT TERM OR BORROWED FROM
AND SO THERE'S THERE WILL NOT
BE ANY HARM TO THE PROGRAM'S
WINDOWS TO NEED MONEY BACK AT
THE POINT WILL BE RETURNED TO
THEM. AND THAT'S NO DIFFERENT
THAN- THE- RE PAYMENT IF YOU
WILL PROCESS THAT WE'VE USED
OUT IN PAST YEARS WHEN WE
BOUGHT OUR BROKEN SPECIAL LOANS.
SAME CROSS THAT SAME TIME FRAME.
CORRECT IT'LL LOGIN TO PASS THE
EITHER WOULD HAVE A SPECIFIC
REPAYMENT DATE OR THEY'RE A
LITTLE MORE FLEXIBLE OR THEY
JUST SAID WHERE THE COMMENDED
APARTMENT NEED THE AT THE PINE
SO PENDING HOW THE CERTAIN
LOANS WERE WERE PHRASE I'M
CERTAINLY WE DO NOT ONE OF OUR
MANY TO PROGRAM YOUR PREVENT-
THEM FOR LATER MISSION SO.
PEOPLE CAN THAT TAB ON A THAT
ARE. TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PLAN
YOU'RE A GOOD SHE- THANK YOU
MISTER THIS ONE OFF WITH REGARD
TO THE TRIGGER CUTS THAT YOU'VE-
IN THE BUDGET AGAIN IF NO
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS- WOULD
BE WITH. THEIR MADE AVAILABLE-
IN YOUR MAY REVISE YOU'VE MADE
THEM EFFECTIVE JULY ONE WHY WAS
THE DECISION MADE TO START
REDUCTIONS ON THE FIRST DAY OF
THE NEW FISCAL YEAR AND- WHY
COULD WE INCLUDE A LATER
TRIGGER DATE TO ALLOW MORE
TIME. FOR FEDERAL ACTION. YES
WHEN IT COMES TO ATTACK
QUESTION AND SO ARE THINKING
ABOUT THIS WAS THAT- THE BUDGET
THAT WE ARE WORKING ON RIGHT
NOW WITH THE NEIGHBOR VISION
AND DENTAL LEGISLATURE'S
EVALUATING NOW HOUSE. DOES NEED
TO BE BALANCED AND SO. WHILE WE
ARE COPING AND CROSSING. FOR
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL ACTION. WE
WILL MAKE SURE. TO PROPOSE A
CONSOLATION LEGISLATION THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL NOT A
BALANCED BUDGET IS NOW IN INDIA
BANKS THAT FEDERAL ACTION DOES
NOT TAKE PLACE BEFORE JULY
FIRST SO YOU ARE CORRECT THAT
THOSE CUTS WOULD BE IN THE
PROJECT AT THAT TIME. HOWEVER
IT IS THE CASE ON AND MY
COLLEAGUE KRISTIN HOW NAY WHY
BREAK IT'S ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS. IF AT ANY TIME
DURING. THE YEAR. UP NEXT YEAR
TWENTY FOUR ONE. I DON'T KNOW.
HAS STATED TO ACT. AND THERE IS
A FOURTEEN DOLLAR. PLEASE IN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL. TO US COMES
THE STATE. UNDER THE CONTROL
SECTION THAT WE HAVE FOR CAR.
THAT WOULD BE RESTORE OR THOSE
TALKS YOUR CORRECT THE COST
GOING TO AFFECT UNTIL I. IT'S
TIME AFTER FOR THE FEDERAL. YOU
GET A ACT TOGETHER AND THEN THE
PROGRAM THAT ARE. THAT ON WILL
BE. TO THEIR. BUT CHALLENGE
WITH THAT IS BECAUSE HAD FOR IN
THE LAST KNOW THE ADDITIONAL RE.
THAT OVER TO STARTED THAT WE
ENDED IS YOU KNOW TOP AN. AND
CRAZY MAKING TO PUT IT MILDLY
SO AGAIN WHY NOT SIMPLY DELAY A
MONTH TO MONTH THREE MONTHS
BEYOND JULY ONE JUST TO GET
THAT EXTRA TIME WE KNOW THAT.
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
TOOK ACTION ON SATURDAY THAT
WOULD BENEFIT CALIFORNIA WE
NEED TO WAIT FOR THE SENATE.
AND SO AGAINST JULY ONE VERSUS.
ABSA SIXTY OR NINETY DAY DELAY.
YES WE UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS
POSSIBLE AND THEY'LL TAKE
FURTHER ACTION IN THE SUMMER
AND WE'RE CERTAINLY HOPEFUL
ABOUT MAX ON BUT WE DO THINK
YOU KNOW THE FIRST SEVERAL
FACES ARE CORONAVIRUS RELEASED
THE PASSED OVER AT THE RESORT.
AND MARCH. ALSO ON AND AT THIS
POINT IT'S REALLY HARD TO
EVALUATE WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
NEXT AND WHILE WE CERTAINLY
HOPE. IT'S ALWAYS LOS THAT IT
IS A OF WORKERS. WE DO AND SURE
TO EXPECTATIONS IN THIS PROJECT
IN PARTICULAR. AS I ALSO
MENTIONED WE ARE FACING A
STRUCTURAL ONGOING BUDGET
PROBLEMS SO EVEN IF. THESE CUTS
ARE RESTORED AND WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE TO DO SOME WORK TO DO
IN THE YEARS TO COME. THAT WE
ARE. FOR A BALANCED BUDGET
WITHOUT THAT HEALTH BUT WE WILL
TAKE YOUR FEEDBACK BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE
GOVERNOR. SHE KATE AND AS YOU
DO THAT WITH I CALL ON SO ROBB
I WOULD JUST GO BACK TO THE
SECTION AND HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
TAKE UP MY COMMENTS- BACK AS
WELL WE ARE BACK IN SESSION WE-
FULLY INTEND TO FOLLOW THE
STATE CONSTITUTION TO HAVE A
BALANCED BUDGET VOTED ON AND IN
ROUTE TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK BY
JUNE FIFTEENTH THAT'S LESS THAN
THIRTY DAYS OUR ABILITY TO
MANAGE THIS PROCESS IN THAT
THIRTY DAY PERIOD CERTAINLY
WILL BACK TO OUR BUILDING TO
RESPOND. QUICKLY YOU NEED A
PARTNER. IN A- FULL AGAIN
PLEASE NOTE OUR- CONCERN AROUND
EXPANDING. YOUR SKULL WITH
ADDITIONAL CONTROL LANGUAGE
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE'RE RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE BUDGET
SEASON AND CYCLE. AND SO WITH
THAT- WILL BEGIN WITH SENATOR
ROBB YOUR QUESTION SIR. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I DO HAVE TWO
OR THREE QUESTIONS I WILL
RESTRICT THEM TO. THE SUBJECT
OF- EDUCATION I WILL TRY TO
KEEP THEM AT A HIGH LEVEL AND
SAVE THE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
FOR. THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING THAT WE WILL HAVE A
WEEK FROM TODAY. SO WITH
RESPECT TO MY FIRST QUESTION
ONE OF THE MAY REVISION
OBVIOUSLY PROVIDES A
SUBSTANTIAL DECREASE. IN PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING FOR K.
THROUGH FOURTEEN THE REVISION
ITSELF ALSO. CONTAINS A VARIETY
OF PROPOSALS TO INCREASE NON
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS. IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET YEAR AND IN THE
OUT YEARS- FINANCE WITH THESE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS OVERALL HOW TO
RESOURCES ALLOCATED. TO THE K.
THROUGH FOURTEEN EDUCATION
SYSTEM COMPARE WITH THE LEVEL
THAT WAS PROVIDED FOR IN
JANUARY. YES THANK YOU SENATOR
ROSS ON THE QUESTION OF K.
TWELVE EDUCATION AND
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
RESOURCES. THE FIRST IS THAT-
WHEN WE WERE LOOKING AT THE
BUDGET GAP WE WERE LOOKING AT
THEIR LEVEL OF RESOURCES UNDER
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
COMPARED TO WHAT WE ESTIMATED
IN JANUARY OF THIS. OF COURSE
IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR WE SEEM
TO BE AT A HIGH WATER MARK YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU RECESSES ALWAYS
YOUNG RISING BUT IT WAS AN-
INSIDE TRACK TIMES. FOR THE
COMING YEAR WE WERE PROJECTING
FOR BILLION DOLLARS- AND THEN
IN HERE THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW
WE ARE PROJECTING. OVER EIGHTY
ONE. IT'S A BECAUSE NINETY
EIGHT REVENUES FOR. BY REVENUES.
JUST ESTIMATORS ON THE PROMISES
NINETY LEVEL ACTS DROPS BACK IN
THE CURRENT YEAR I'M IN
ADDITION TO THE- I BELIEVE IN
THE- HOUSE CHECK MY- YES IS NOT
SEVEN SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
IT'S NOT WHAT WE ARE EX. YOUR
DESTINATION RIGHT NOW AND THEN
AS YU NOTED SENATOR ROTH THE
BUDGET YEAR TO NINETY EIGHT
LEVEL DROPS TO ABOUT SEVENTY
DOLLARS SO MASSIVE PROXIMATE.
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR GAPS. AS
YOU NOTED A RESTORED THE UP
COMING YEAR ON THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF STEPS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING TO
FILL THAT OUT AND BUY EXTRA
RESOURCE. THIS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT AND FROM OF SIZE IS
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL. SO ON THE
NIGHT POINTS BILLION. THAT WAS
OUR- FOR SOMEONE FLEXIBLE SAY
UNDER THE CROWN OR RIDER
CORONAVIRUS SO WE SIGNED. UP
THAT NINE POINT FIVE FOR
BILLION DOLLARS SIXTEEN OUR
QUICK ALLOCATED TO SCHOOLS I TO
ADDRESS MORNING WE'LL AND
EQUITY ISSUES LAST FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS RIGHT THERE ON THE
OUTSIDE OF THAT WORK FLEXIBLE
CORONA VIRUS RELEASED. OX
CONGRESS ALSO PROVIDED AN
ADDITIONAL APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THEN ONE OTHER
CHOICE THAT WE KNOW IS THAT YOU
MAY REMEMBER FROM THE BUDGET
ACT LAST YEAR. THE STATE HAD
PUT IN AN. ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
ON THE SCHOOL THIS FOR A
CALPERS AND SHALL SERVE.
PENSION CONTRIBUTION TO BUY
THAT RATE OVER THE TERM. THE
GIVEN THE CRISIS THAT WE ARE
ALL IN RIGHT NOW AND THE SCHOOL
CRISIS AT SCHOOLS IN PARTICULAR
FACING WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA USE
THAT TWO POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE FURTHER
IMMEDIATE RELEASE. OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS SO THAT'S A
LITTLE OVER A BILLION DOLLARS
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. AS WELL AS
THE YEAR AFTER THAT. ALL THAT
THERE. CASE YOU PRETTY. BACK TO
THE REVISED PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT LEVEL. FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR NOW ON THIS THIS IS NOT. A
SPACE AFTER LEVEL EIGHTY ONE
BILLION OR EIGHTY FOUR BILLION
WE WERE HOPING FOR THE COMING
YEAR- COURSE WE KNOW THAT. YOU
KNOW EVERY PART OF THE BUDGET
IS TAKING A COT AND SCHOOLS. WE
DO HOPE TAX THE SITUATIONAL
RESOURCES WILL HELP SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS MAKE IT
FOR NEXT YEAR. AND WE ALSO OVER
THE LONG. I. FUND REVENUES A
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT. THAT'S
CORRECT GETTING IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET YEAR. YES
THIS IS NOT WILL NOT
SUPPLEMENTARY PAYMENT WILL
BEGIN IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO YEAR RIGHT. SO WITH THE
ADDITION OF THAT SUB MODEL-
PAYMENT WHAT'S YOUR PROJECTION
IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL FUNDING
FOR K. THROUGH FOURTEEN. YEAH
SO WHEN IT COMES TO THE OVERALL
FUNDING IS THAT ONE ONE HALF
PERCENT WILL BE IN THE BUDGET
YEAR SORT OF ALL INCLUDE THOSE
OTHER COMPONENTS THAT WE WERE
DISCUSSING. BUT NOT NOT THAT
ONE POINT 5% THAT THE WAY THAT
THE NAY REVISION INVASION THAT
15% TAX IT SHOULD BE. ON OVER
TIME SO IT'LL HE'S ONE POINT
FIVE PER. A YEAR THE YEAR ANY
15% AFTER THAT AND- AFTER THE-
ON AND WE'RE- ESTIMATING RIGHT
NOW THAT OVER THE- YEAR. WHICH
IS THREE YEAR. AFTER THE BUDGET
YEAR THIS WILL RESULT IN AND-
TEN GOING DOLLARS IN FUNDING
FOR. OVER TIME AND I CAN OTHER.
CLOSING ACT TO INCREASE THEIR
INTENTION OPPOSITION EIGHT ONE
GENERAL FROM CURRENT OR 30% TO
FORTY PER AND YOU KNOW WE
UNDERSTAND THAT NO WAY OUT HAS
SOME CONCERNS THAT DEFINITELY
WANT TO WORK WITH AND THE CLASS
YOU THAT CAN WORK WITH ALL OF
YOU I'M WE DO BELIEVE GIVEN
PRESSURES SCHOOLS UNDER IN
PARTICULAR. THAT IS SOMETHING I
STASHED AND THE CROP IS NINETY
BASS IMPORTANT PRIORITIES. NOW
WITH THE TO THIS WOMAN PAYMENT
SINCE IT IS A AGAINST THE CHEN
FUND. IF THIS SECOND RECOVERY
THAT HOPE WE HAVE. IS SLOW OR
SLOW DO YOU ENTER ANY
DIFFICULTY WITH THE STATE BEING
TO SET IT IT'S A- UNDER THE
SMALL YEAR PAYMENT OF A TO PAY
TO. YEAH WELL I'LL SAY FOR THAT
IS AND YOU KNOW ITS HARD TO
SECOND SHOULD REVENUE PER
PROJECTIONS J. SPECIFICALLY IF
THEY WERE YOU DECLINE DAY WE
HAVE TO WHAT THE WHOLE BUNCH SO
EVERYTHING WOULD BE IN THE
COUNTRY OF LIFE. NOT BEING SAID
YOU KNOW THIS IS IN OBLIGATION
THAT THAT ON THE STATE IS
WORKING TO AFTER THEY WERE AND
AMAZING HOW. AND THEIR IS KIND
OF NOT REALLY SHALL IN THAT
REVENUE. WHICH SHOULD OFFSET
SOMEWHAT THE PRESSURE ON THE
REST OF THE GENERAL. OKAY ONE
FINAL QUESTION. WE HAVE SEEN
DEFERRALS TO EDUCATION IN THE
PAST AND- OTHER DEFERRALS AS I
UNDERSTAND IT. I THOUGHT IT WAS
FIVE POINT NINE BILLION I
THOUGHT I HEARD JUST A LITTLE
BIT AGO IT'S FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION WHATEVER IT IS IT'S
OVER FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. FOR
K. THROUGH FOURTEEN EDUCATION
HAS THERE BEEN ANY ANALYSIS OR
REVIEW TO DETERMINE HOW ARE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO MANAGE THIS LEVEL.
OF DEFERRAL. ROSS THE STATE.
YES ON THIS QUESTION I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE ACCESS
TO HOMES I THINK DEPENDING ON
THE DISTRICT OF THE OR THE LA
X. IT'LL DEPEND ON HOW IT COULD
BE A NAY- EITHER CASH THEY HAVE
ON HAND OR VERY SHORT TERM
BORROWING A LITTLE OVER TO
JUST. TO DISCUSS. HI THIS IS
JESSICA HOLMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION SIMPLY MISTER ROTH YES
WE DID WE HAVE BEEN- SPEAKING-WITH STAKEHOLDERS- AS WELL AS
OUR COLLEAGUES OVER AT- PICK
MATT. A FISCAL CRISIS
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE TEAM- AND
WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT-
RESERVE LEVELS. AND WE BELIEVE
IT AS AS- I MENTIONED- YOU KNOW
IT IT IT'S GONNA LOOK A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT DEPENDING ON THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COMES
DISTRICTS AND BUILT UP
SIGNIFICANT RESERVES- OVER THE
LAST TEN OR SO YEARS. SOME AS
LARGE BUT OVERALL AS A STATE
RUN A FAIRLY STRONG POSITION. A
RESERVE WISE- IN TERMS OF ED
FOLKS ABILITY TO ABSORB THESE
IF FOR THE TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE ARE SOME DISTRICTS ARE
CHARTER SCHOOLS. HAVE TROUBLE
ABSORBING ON THE DEFERRALS AS
WE HAVE- A PROPOSED TO THEN. WE
DO INCLUDE LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS
DISTRICTS FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE COUNTY OFFICES THAT- TO
DEMONSTRATE THE SCHOOL HARDSHIP
TO BE EXACT FROM THE DEFERRALS
IN THIS IS A SIMILAR. MECHANISM
THAT WE USED IN THE LAST
RECESSION TO ENSURE THAT THE
DEFERRALS ARE CAUSING ANYONE
TO- ALL INTO YOU KNOW FISCAL
DISTRESS. OKAY WELL FOR YOU I
HAVE SOME VERY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ON SPECIFIC ISSUES
AND AGAIN I'LL I WILL DO FOR
THOSE- TO THE BUDGET.
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE HEARING WHICH
WILL BE A WEEK FROM TODAY
INCLUDING SOME VERY VERY
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE-
CONCENTRATION. GRANT BASED
ALLOCATION FORMULA FOR THE
FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS AS
OUTLINED IN THE MAY REVISION
BUT WITH THAT MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. A TWO THIRDS
REGINALD. MADAM PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
AND INDIVIDUALS AT FINANCE THAT
ALEJO. THIS IS ANOTHER HUGE
CHALLENGE FOR US AND AS I NOTED
BEFORE WE'VE BEEN DOWN THIS
TRAIL BEFORE. BUT THE QUESTION
IS HAVE WE LEARNED. BY OF GREAT
CONCERN TO ME IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROJECTED DEFICIT AND- THE LA
ALL. THERE'S A SUBSTANTIAL GAP.
AND THE QUESTION THAT I'D LIKE
TO POSE TO FINANCE. MR VISION
NOT AND DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE. AN ABILITY.
TO RECONCILE THOSE TWO KEY
FIGURES THIS IS WHERE THE
BUDGET STARCH WHAT RESOURCES
WHAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO US IS
THAT POSSIBLE I GOT ABOUT THREE
MORE QUESTIONS AFTER THAT BUT
THIS IS RELATED TO THAT
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN FINANCE AND
THE LA PROJECTIONS. YES I'LL
SPEAK AT VERY BRIEFLY YOU KNOW
WE CERTAINLY DO YOU- YOU KNOW
OUR BEST IN TERMS OF ESTIMATES
AND WE ARE IN CONTACT WITH THE
LA HOW AND IN TERMS OF STICKING
WITH THE REVENUES LOOK LIKE
CLOSE THIS YEAR. AND YEARS TO
COME AND WE RECOGNIZE ALREADY
THAT THERE IS A STRUCTURAL
BUDGET DEFICIT. NEED TO EXPRESS
OUR BUT WE ARE IN TEXAS NOW.
LOOKING TO. OUR ESTIMATES. BUT
I THANK YOU IT'S A TOUGH ONE
BUT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IT. THE ACT ALSO.
PICK UP ON A DEEPLY HELD
CONCERN OF MINE THAT GOES WAY
BACK THROUGH MANY GOVERNORSHIPS.
NOT JUST THIS PARTICULAR ONE
BUT OUR CHAIRPERSON. WAS
REFERRING TO THE DELEGATION OF
AUTHORITY FOR DECISION MAKING
TO THE ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
BY THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH. AND
MOST RECENTLY AND SB EIGHTY
NINE A LOT MORE OF THAT
OCCURRED. SOME OF IT HAS BECOME
NOW JUST FACT OF LIFE. DO YOU
SEE OR IS IT THE MINISTRATION
POSITION THAT THIS DELEGATION
WILL NOW BE TURNER OR WILL BE
TERMINATED AT SOME POINT HERE
IN THE FUTURE AS THIS
PARTICULAR. EMERGENCY EXHAUST
NOT THE ONE FROM THE FIRES BUT
THIS PARTICULAR ONE IS IT
ANTICIPATED THAT THIS
ADDITIONAL BROAD AUTHORITY TO
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH THAT WILL
BE THEN CURTAILED. YES SENATOR
NIELSEN AYE WHEN IT COMES
SPECIFICALLY Q. AND A TWO POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLAR CONTINGENCY
SIGNED. NAFTA CHAIR MENTIONED.
THAT CONVENIENCE USES
SPECIFICALLY FOR KOBE NINETEEN
RESPONSE AND WE KNOW THAT COULD
BE NINETEEN IS A MINUTE AWAY
ABROAD CATEGORY TOUCHING ON
PUBLIC HEALTH ON A RELATED
SAFETY MEASURES AND HOW THEY
RELATE TO OTHERS. AS YOURS.
CERTAINLY RELATED DIRECTLY TO
THE STAND SO WE DON'T KNOW WHEN
IT WILL BE AN AXIOM WILL CALM
MIND MY ACTUAL SATELLITE
RETURNS AT SOME SENSE OF NORMAL
OR IN YOUR NORMAL. BUT ONCE
THAT HAPPENS TO. BE SUNDAY
MARKETS ARE SPECIFICALLY FOR
COMING NINETEEN WILL NOT BE
NEEDED ANYMORE. YOU GOT THEIR
SEPARATION AFTER MERGING SEE
THAT ABLES THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
DRAW ON LEGALLY AVAILABLE SIGNS
FOR EMERGENCY EXPENDITURES WILL
BE CONTINUED OUT ONCE. HE IS NO
LONGER CRISIS SO WHILE WE DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE TEMPORARY
MEANS THE CRISIS IS SUCH AN
UNUSUAL SITUATION. CERTAINLY
ALL THE GOVERNOR'S AFGHANS AND
THE EXTRAORDINARY THE SIDE THAT
HE'S. BEEN USING THAT WE- TO.
NEWS OF NORM ONCE SIX YEARS
OVER. WELL I THEN SEE A TO WORK
WITH THE AND TELL A AND CALL TO
AND- LEGAL LANGUAGE. IN THIS
BUDGET TO COME. THAT SOUL A
SEARCH THAT AT CERTAIN TRIGGER
POINTS THAN THAT LORI WILL
REVERT TO THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH AT THAT SUPPORT
RECONCILED. SENATOR NIELSEN
BOOK ONE TWO NINE TONIGHT
MISTER HIS HAND RAY PREDATORS
OF LITTLE RISK TO THAT. YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU SENATOR NIELSEN FOR THE
QUESTIONS. I THOUGHT I COULD
ADDRESS BOTH IN THE THAT YOU'VE
HAD SO FAR I WANTED TO JUST
BEGIN WITH THE DIFFERENCE IN
OUR LIVES IN OUR ESTIMATED
BUDGET PROBLEMS OUR DEFICITS
BECAUSE YOU RAISE THAT AND I DO
THINK I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION WE- MADE IT. THAT THE
STATE COULD BE FACING A BUDGET
PROBLEM OF EIGHTEEN BILLION TO
THIRTY TO THIRTY ONE BILLION.
WE CONSIDERED THAT EIGHTEEN
BILLION TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH A
SOMEWHAT MORE OPTIMISTIC
ECONOMIC SCENARIO. AND THE
THIRTY ONE BILLION TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH A SOMEWHAT MORE
STICKS AN AREA. THE IMPORTANT
THING IS I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE UNDERNEATH THE THOSE
SURFACE LEVEL NUMBERS ARE
REVENUE ESTIMATES ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY REFLECTING A
SIMILAR VIEW OF THE WORLD. IN
THE IT'LL SHAKE SCENARIO OR THE
PESSIMISTIC SCENARIO WE SEE A
THIRTY NINE BILLION DOLLAR
REVENUE DECLINE COMPARED WITH%
JANUARY AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS A FORTY ONE BILLION
DOLLAR DECLINE. SO THAT PART OF
THE EQUATION IS FAIRLY SIMILAR
I THINK WHERE WE DIFFER IS IN
OUR METHODOLOGY FOR MEASURING
THE BASELINE OF EXPENDITURES.
THE GOVERNOR WHEN THE
GOVERNOR'S NAME A NUMBER
ASSOCIATED WITH THE NEIGHBOR
VISION CAME OUT THANK WHAT IT
DOES IS INCLUDES THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THE JANUARY
PROPOSALS. AND IT ALSO TREATS
THINGS LIKE- INCREASED FEDERAL
MATCHING FUNDS IN A DIFFERENT
WAY WHERE AS WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE LA- WE RECOGNIZED THE
INFLUX OF SEVERAL MATCHING
SIGNS AS HELPING CHIU. THE
DEFICIT OR THE BUDGET PROBLEM
THE GOVERNOR DOES YOU BUT
RATHER WORK INCLUDES TEN ON THE
SOLUTION SIDES OF THEIR
INCREASED FEDERAL DOLLARS WOULD
HELP US SOLVE THE BUDGET
PROBLEM. WHERE IS SORT OF USE
THAN NOT FRENCH ISSUE THE
BUDGET- SO SOME OF IT IS REALLY
A MATTER OF. DOES SHE IN THE
PARKING. BUT WE ARE HAVE DE
CASE LOTUS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS SUBSTANTIALLY
HIGHER CAL WORKS CASELOAD
ESTIMATES THAN WE DO. AND THEY
ALSO HAVE WELL THEY HAVE
SIMILAR MEDI CAL CASELOAD
ESTIMATES THEY HAVE A HIGHER
PER CASE LOAD IN HOSPITAL FOR
HER AT CASE- ACOSTA THEN WE'D
USE UP. THE KEY DIFFERENCES IN
CASE LAW. ARE OUT ON CAL WORKS
SIDE JUST A HIGHER NUMBER ON
THE MEDICAL SIDE HIGHER COSTS
FOR CASE. WOULD IS TO. THE
FUNDING FOR THE FOR COVERT
RESPONSE. THINK THAT THE CHAIR
AND USE SENATOR NIELSEN OR
RAISING A VERY IMPORTANT POINT
WE THINK THAT THERE IS ROOM FOR
SOME DISCUSSION HERE AND WITH
REGARD TO THE TWO POINT NINE
BILLION PROPOSED CONTENT-
COATED NINETEEN CONTINGENCY
FUND. THAT IS BEING PROPOSED
UNDER THE CONTROL SECTION
THIRTY SIX PROCESS AND YOU KNOW
WAIT IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO THE-
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
APPROVED PREVIOUSLY. BUT YOU
KNOW EVEN WITH THAT WE THINK
THAT YOU COULD CONSIDER MAKING
SOME AMENDMENTS YOU COULD
REQUIRE THAT THE- NOTIFICATION
ALSO INVOLVED LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL NOT JUST. A SIMPLE
REPLICATION. COULD INCLUDE A
REQUIREMENT THAT IT'S A LITTLE
BIT MORE SPECIFIC IN WHAT TYPES
OF CONSERVE ELIGIBLE TO BE
SPENT NOT JUST A BROAD CATCH
ALL OF IT. EVERYTHING RELATED
TO COPE. I'M YOU COULD ALSO
REQUIRE AN INCREASED LEVEL AND
MORE SPECIFIC OR DETAILED
INFORMATION DISCLOSURE. THERE
IN SOME CASES SO FAR WE HAVEN'T
HAD AS MUCH OF THAT IS WE THINK
WOULD BE. AND SO THESE ARE SOME
OF THE ITEMS THAT WE THINK YOU
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER AND WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
AND I THINK YOU KNOW THROUGH
THIS. SORT OF THOSE. THIS IS.
IT SECOND RESPECT WELL THAT IS
IMPORTANT AND IT'S- BEEN GOING
ON A VERY LONG TIME. AND PART
OF THIS IS GOING TO BE VIEWED
BY THIS NEXT QUESTION HELLO
FROM A FRIEND THAT TO YOU THEN
AT THIS POINT. YOUR PROJECT IN
IS IF WE PROCEED WITH THIS
BUDGET OUTLINED. WITH BEFORE US
HERE. IF WE EXTEND UP TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE I BELIEVE IT IS WE
WOULD END UP STILL WITH SOME
SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
RED. IT AND THAT WOULD ARGUE TO
THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT THAT WE
BUILT IN OVER DECADES. IS THAT
STILL HOW YOU SEE IT. ON THAT
FOR ME STATE INTERNAL CENTERED
ALIKE BUT I'M SORRY. I WASN'T
SPEAKING INTO THE MIKE. THE YOU
PROJECT NOW IN YOUR DEPARTMENT
A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE OF ABOUT SIXTEEN
BILLION IF JUST THIS OUTLINE IS
WHAT WE USE TO GOVERNOR'S AS-
WHAT IN THE BUDGET. THAT WOULD
SEEM TO ME IT ARGUES TO THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT THAT WE WILL
HAVE NOT CORRECTED EITHER IN
OUR PAST TROUBLES OR IN THE
CURRENT ONE. SO I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT
IN THIS BUDGET THAT STRUCTURAL
PROBLEM GET A SIXTEEN BILLION
IN THE RED. A JUST A FEW YEARS
OUT THERE TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
RIGHT I THINK- YES WE AGREE
THAT THERE IS. THERE'S STILL A
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM UNDER THE
NAY REVISION IN THE MULTI YEAR-
FISCAL OUTLOOK AND CIRCLE
WITHIN A REVISION. AND IT DOES-
CULMINATE IN ABOUT A SIXTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR PROBLEM AT THE
END OF TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND- YOU KNOW SO I DO THINK
THAT THIS THIS BUDGET IS-
RESPONDING IN SOME WAYS TO THE
URGENCY OF THE CRISIS THAT HAS
FALLEN THE STATE. AND IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT NOT ALL OF
THEM THE PROBLEM IS SOLVED-
IMMEDIATE WE- BUT THAT IS WHY
WE RAISE THE POINT THAT PRETTY
MUCH ALL OF THE ONGOING
SOLUTIONS IN THE PROPOSAL. OUR
FIND THE- EXPENDITURE SIDE AND
THEY'RE ALL PRETTY MUCH ALL
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TRIGGERS SO
THEY WOULD BE REMOVED YOU KNOW
THAT I'M- TIONS THAT WE'RE IN
THE BUDGET WILL BE. TRIGGERED
OFF IF WE CAN INCREASE FEDERAL
AID BUT OF COURSE IF WE DID GET
THE FEDERAL AID IT WOULD ONLY
LIKELY BE A TEMPORARY SOLUTION
AND SO YOU WOULD HAVE THAT
PHASING. OUT BUT ALL HAVE SOME
OF THE YOU KNOW THE ADDITIONAL.
UNDER THAT NOLES SUSPENSION AND
THE LIMITS ON THE TAX CREDIT
PROPOSALS. IN THOSE WOULD PHASE
OUT AT THE END OF TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND SO WHEN YOU
HAVE SEVERAL OF THESE VARIABLES
COMING TOGETHER AT THE SAME
TIME. I THINK YOU KNOW IT
CONTRIBUTES TO THAT SIXTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR SO THAT
THAT IS GOING TO STILL BE. AN
ISSUE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONTEND. THAT IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS PROBABLY. THANK
YOU IF I MAY THEM BACK TO MR.
MISSION NOT PLEASE. CUT
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE. THIS IS
KIND OF AN EXAMPLE OF HOW THESE
LONG TERM PLANS CAN GO AWRY.
I'M CONCERNED ALWAYS ABOUT THE
PLIGHT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AND
I BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE IN
SERIOUS TROUBLE AND ONE OF THE
PROPOSALS HERE IS TO. GIVE THE
REST OF THE JUVENILE AUTHORITY
AND HOUSING AND REHABILITATIVE
EFFORTS OVER TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WHICH IS FOR TO
SAVE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND-
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS I GUESS.
BUT LET WITH THE STATE IS GONNA
RECOMPENSE THOSE COUNTIES BY
ONLY NINE POINT SIX NOW OUR
LAST REALIGNMENT DID DOUBLE LOT
OF RESPONSIBILITIES ON OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TYPICALLY OUR
LOCAL JAILS. HOW CAN WE KEEP
GOING DOWN THIS PATH OF
SHIFTING MORE AND MORE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO SOLVE OUR
PROBLEMS. AND THEN JUST SAYING
TO THEM WILL FIGURE IT OUT.
THAT'S QUITE A DISCREPANCY FROM
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TO NINE POINT
SIX DID I READ THOSE WRONG. SO
I WILL MAKE ONE GENERAL POINT
AND THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE HERE AN ADWORDS
SUCH A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT SPECIFIC
PRO PROPOSAL NUMBERS ASSOCIATED
WITH SEX THE OVERALL IS THAT
WE- DEFINITELY ACKNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTAND RECOGNIZED AT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE UNDER THE SAME
TAXES PRESSURES AT THE STATE.
BUDGET CASES EVEN MORE AND IT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS I AM WHEN IT
CAME TO THE CRIME HIGHER SO WE
FIND THAT NINE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS THEY CAME TO
THE STATE- WE DECIDED THAT EVEN
THOUGH THE STATE HAD
FLEXIBILITY TO USE THAT FOR A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT STATE
PURPOSES. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
IN OUR PROPOSAL IN PATIENTS
THAT MEANINGFUL PART OF THAT
WHEN TO LOCAL. INCLUDED ABOUT
ONE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
A COUNTIES AND ENERGY MONEY FOR
HOMELESS AND PUBLIC SAFETY
FUNDING. THROUGH THAT PART OF
SIMPLY COULD YOU. AND THE
PROPOSAL ON OUR THOUGHT IS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY SAVINGS GENERATED
CAN HELP OFFSET SOME OF THE
COSTA LET ME TURN IT OVER TO
ERIN EDWARDS ELABORATE. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT.
FINANCE SO THE FIRST THING I
WOULD I WOULD NOTE- RELATED
YOUR QUESTION CENTER NIELSEN IS
THAT WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IN THE
BUDGET YOU'RE IN TERMS OF OUR
FUNDING IS JUST THE BEGINNING
OF OUR TRANSITION OUR PLAN A
TRANSITION DJJ LOCALS- THE PLAN
IS TO DO THIS THROUGH ATTRITION
AND SO IT'S NOT AN IMMEDIATE
CHEFS- RESPONSIBILITY OR IN THE
ARE CURRENTLY HAVE UNLIMITED
WEALTH SO IT IS. WILL TAKE
PLACE OVER. YOURS SO AT THE
FUNDING IN THE FIRST YEAR IS
JUST THE BEGINNING OF THIS
TRANSITION I DOES NOT REFLECT
THE FULL AMOUNT OF FUNDING- THE
FULL NOT A FUNNY WILL GROW OVER
TIME AND THAT WILL DEPEND ON
THE NUMBER OF. YOU SHOULD HAVE
OTHERWISE BEEN SOUNDS TO OUR
STATE FACILITIES ARE WE ARE
PROPOSING THE FINAL WAS AT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. PER YEAR. HI
AND WE THINK THAT'S A FAIR
RATE- BASED ON ON THE SERVICES
THAT WILL THERE BE RISKS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING TO
THIS YEAR'S- AND- THAT'S WHY DO
YOU SEE THE NUMBER IN THE FIRST
YEAR. QUITE MATCHING TO WHAT
WE'RE SPENDING ON- OUR ON OUR
DO NOT SO. THANK YOU AND LASTLY
KIND OF AN OBSERVATION MADAM
CHAIR. REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE DO
IN OUR BUDGET IF THE ECONOMY
DOESN'T REVIVE. SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AT LEAST ONE I KNOW
OF WHAT EXISTS AND IS EXISTENCE.
FEDEX VERY TINY PLACE. BUT WILL
GO OUT OF EXISTENCE WITHOUT THE
ECONOMIC RESURGENCE THAT WE ARE
ALL HOPING FOR. AND I ENCOURAGE
JUST AS WE PROCEED TO BE
CONSIDERING. THAT VERY
IMPORTANT FACTOR. YOUR BUSINESS
IS CLOSING MANY OF NOT COMING
BACK. AND THEN LASTLY DEPENDING
ON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I
THINK IS NOT THE BEST A VETS IN
THE DAYS THESE TIME SEX JR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR SENATOR
PAN OF HISTORY MADAM CHAIR AND-
IN APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION
SIDE I THINK CERTAINLY I. FOR
ONLY A SUPPORTIVE WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT THE CONTROL ISSUES WHEN
THINGS I WANT TO TOUCH ON IS
THE ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
CO BID BUT ALSO HOW DON'T
SEGREGATE I THINK THE FUNDING
WHETHER SEVERAL OTHER THINGS TO
DEAL WITH EMERGENCY. FROM
THANKS LEAD THE OTHER
ACTIVITIES IN THE BUDGET WHICH
ACTUALLY. UNDERLIE OUR RESPONSE
TO CODES I DO HAVE THREE
QUESTIONS RELATION TO THAT- SO
FIRST OF ALL I'M A START OFF.
WE KNOW THAT BEAU'S FORMAL
POPULATIONS ARE SENIORS- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. IS IT IS LIKE
NURSING HOMES ARE PARTICULARLY.
ACCOUNTABLE TO COVET DEBTS THAT
PARTICULAR FOCUS WE SHOULD HAVE
AS WELL IN TERMS OF TESTING AND
PREVENTION. AS WELL BUT YET
SAME TIME AS I LOOK AT THIS
BUDGET YOU KNOW WE'RE MAKING
CUTS TO SENIORS SWITCH INCLUDE
ACTUALLY ELIMINATION OF PROGRAM
LIKE. MS YOU KNOW THE MULTI
PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM
AND SEE BASS WHICH ACTUALLY
HELPS KEEP PEOPLE FROM COMING
INTO NURSING HOMES SO I THOUGHT
WE'RE TRYING TO KEEP PEOPLE
OUT. OF IT ALSO HAS A COST BY
THE WAY THEY END UP IN A
NURSING HOME- WE'VE ALSO.
INTERESTING ENOUGH WE'VE
CONCERNED ABOUT FOOD FOR
SENIORS AND YET WE'RE CUTTING
NUTRITION. PROGRAMS FOR SENIORS
AS WELL. THE SEEM TO BE
SOMEWHAT COUNTERPRODUCTIVE. TO
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO ACHIEVE-
WHAT'S THE SOME OF THE EFFORTS
THAT WE'RE DOING TO. TRY TO
PROTECT SENIORS AND ALSO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THEM- YOU
KNOW WE'RE ELIMINATING THE
SENIOR COUNTY. WELL ACTUALLY
RESTORING SENIOR PENALTY FOR
MEDI CAL. TO WHICH WE DID LAST
YEAR- OF COURSE SAID THIS WAS A
NEW PROPOSALS EXPANSION MEDI
CAL UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS ALSO.
THOUGH RIGHT SO I GUESS MY
FIRST QUESTION IS THAT GIVEN
THE FACT THAT WHAT WE DO KNOW
ABOUT ARE COVERED RESPONSES
THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE MORE
ACCESS AND SUPPORT FOR SENIORS
ALSO. TRY TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR- SENIORS OR INSTITUTIONS
AND PREVENT MORE FROM GOING
INTO THESE INSTITUTIONS HOW
DOES HOW THESE PROPOSALS THIRD
OF JIVE WITH THOSE GOALS THAT
WE SEE AND PRESENT I HAVE TO DO
SEE ENTRY FUNDING FOR NOW MAYBE
IT'S GONNA COME ON THE
MERCHANT'S DECIDE ON THE
FEDERAL SIDE BUT YET I ISN'T IT
IN PART A BUCKET. V. E. R. COVE
A- POLLS BROWN'S SINGERS. YES
SENATOR PAN A YES SENATOR AND-
I THINK- YOU RIGHT THAT THERE
IS A CONNECTION WITH WHILE
WE'RE FOCUS WITH THE IMMEDIATE
ON THE MEDIA OKAY NINETEEN
RESPONSE ALSO CONNECTED THE
BROADER WE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS. FOR
CORPORATE. USUALLY AN ALTERNATE
OVER TO MY CALL RIDING A IN OUR
HHS UNIX IS THAT. YOU ARE THAT
SEEM TO BE PROGRAM ARE YOU TAKE
SOME COTS IN THE NAY REVISION.
THERE DEFINITELY CANCELLED AND
FOR THE MOST PART I THINK MOST
OF. THE PROGRAM NATION ARE
FEDERAL TRUCKERS SO I DON'T
THINK YOU NEED TO SPEAK WITH A
SECRET YOU MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
FOR THEIR ACTION. THIS COURSE
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH ALL THE
BUDGET PRESSURES AND HOW WE CAN
BALANCE THE BUDGET. THE
GOVERNOR'S FOCUS LIES ON MAKING
SURE THAT. CORD TENNIS FOR
SENIORS IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE MAINTAIN THE CURRENT
ELIGIBILITY LEVELS FOR MEDICARE
HOUSE MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
WERE RECEIVING SSI STATE.
PROGRAM CAME AND CONTINUE TO
GET THOSE AT THE LEVELS AFTER
GETTING RIGHT NOW ON. THOSE
ALSO DISCUSSES. MAKING SOME
REDUCTIONS IN OTHER PARTS OF
THE PROJECT. REMEMBER TO RUN
OVER TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DETAILS. I PAN RUNNING. SO IF
YOU'LL ALLOW I. CURRENT CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK IS I'M I'M ME TO
SORRY THAT RYAN MILLER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO I
HAVE A FEW COMMENTS TO OFFER IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTIONS BUT
THEN I'D LIKE TO ALSO TURNED
OVER TO MIKE TIGER WOODS WHO
WILL BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE SERVICES ARE. I'M YOU
KNOW CONCERN. THE SITUATION
WITH NORTH HOME AND THEIR
IMPORT ROLE RESPONSE TO THE
KOBE SEARCH. I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT WE ARE CONTINUING TO
PROPOSE- REFORMS IN THE WAY
THAT WE FINANCE NURSING HOMES
THAT WILL INCREASE FUNDING TO
THAT- BUT ALSO TRY TO. WE ALSO
HAVE- JUST JUST ACTUALLY
RECENTLY WERE APPROVED FROM CMS
TO- BE ABLE TO HAVE A RATE
ADDED ON FOR NURSING HOMES IN
IN FOR ALSO- I SEE AFTER I'D
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES
FOR THE DISABLED AND SOME OTHER
FACILITIES. PERCENT IRATE ADD
ON. WILL BE IN PLACE FOR FOUR
MONTHS DURING THE MAY REVISION-
FOR. HOSTAGE SEVENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR AND ABOUT FORTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. ARE GUARDING THE- AGE OF
ALL DISABLED ENSURING. OUR THAT
WAS A PART OF LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET- AS I'M SURE YOU'RE
AWARE THERE WERE. DELAYS IN
IMPLEMENTING THAT GO. BUT YOU
KNOW WHEN WE WERE LOOKING AT
THE STRUCTURE FOR THE MAYOR
VISION. ONE RILEY LOOKED AT AS
AS MISTER MISS ONE OFTEN
POINTED OUT WAS- TRYING TO
MAINTAIN ELIGIBILITY FOR
EVERYBODY WHO WAS ALREADY
ENROLLED IN MEDICARE NOW WITH
THE TIME OF THE MAYOR VISION WE
HAVE NOT AND PROPOSAL SO WE ARE
PROPOSING TO ACT- ONE OTHER
AREA BEFORE AGAIN. THE MR TIRE.
THE P. E. N. N. YOU KNOW
TRACING IN OTHER GOOD RESPONSE
EFFORTS- WHILE WE DO NOT HAVE
THAT BUILT INTO THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC BUDGET THIS TIME- WE
ANTICIPATE BE A PART OF THE
PROPOSED CONTROL SECTION- ONE
THING YOU KNOW ONE PERSPECTIVE
I THINK TO OFFER ON THAT- WE'RE
JUST NOW LEARNING FOR EXAMPLE
ABOUT. IT WAS INCLUDE IN THE-
THREE ONE FIVE READ FEDERAL AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
COMMUNICATED APPLICATION. THING
THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE THROUGH
THAT- DOES THAT INFORMATION WAS
NOT AVAILABLE AS WE'RE PLAYING
TOGETHER THE MAYOR VISION AND
SO YEAH THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF.
HOW IT IS CHALLENGING IN SOME
WAYS TO BE ABLE TO THE BUDGET
PROVIDED THE DEPARTMENTAL
LEVEL- BUT WITHOUT TURNING TO
THE ISLAND YOU CAN SEE THE
OTHER. PROPOSAL SENIORS FOLLOW
UP. STE AFTERNOON BRENT HOW'S
YOUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
ONLY THING I WOULD ADD RELATED
TO THE IT'S RELATED TO THE
NUTRITION PROGRAM THAT THE
CARES ACTED OFFER ADDITIONAL.
AND THAT BUILT ON A FIVE
MILLION THAT WAS ALLOCATED FROM
THE FAMILIES FIRST ACTS SO-
WELL THAT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
HAS BEEN DISTRIBUTED TO THE
TRIPLE. OF AGING. GEN SEES
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS SHOULD BE
OUR OUR RELATIVELY QUICKLY.
THAT'S ALL AT ONCE. YOU WELL I
GUESS WHAT I WOULD JUST SAY IS
THAT- I THINK WE SHOULD TAKE A-
MY- GOD YEAH I AT THAT COULD
TAKE A- SERVE MORE HOLISTIC
VIEW OUR INTEGRATED VIEW OF THE
BUDGET SO IT'S NOT LIKE OKAY
HAVE STUFF OVER HERE BUT WHEN I
GOT TALK ABOUT IT SO WE- CAN
SEE THEIR TOTAL. A RECENT ACT
IT'S OUR HE'S VERY SERIOUS
BECAUSE- YEAH DOES IT SAID SOME
OF IT DIDN'T SOUND VERY
CONSISTENT- THE OTHER EXAMPLE
MEDI CAL WE'RE EXPECTING AN
EXPANSION A KEEPSAKE BOTH I
THINK IT WAS WHAT TWO MILLION
THANK. REMEMBER CORRECT. IN THE-
SO I THINK TIME WERE ACT HE
THERE'S A PROGRAM TO ACTUALLY
GET MORE- HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
PHYSICIANS DENTISTS OTHERS TO
TAKE MEDI CAL PATIENTS YEAH
SEEM TO EAT FIVE AND WROTE IT
INTO GENERAL MEDI CAL YET WE'RE
GONNA EXPAND CASELOAD MANY MORE
DOC IS A NURSE AND DENTS AND
OTHER TYPES OF FOLKS AND- AND
THEN AS WE ARE GOING INTO A
FIFTY SIX. WE ARE IT'S- IT ALSO
MEANS THAT THAT'S FOR EXAMPLE
FUND FOR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES AND SOME OTHER TYPES
OF THINGS ESSENTIALLY BECOME
ELIMINATED. AND THAT SO AGAIN
CAN YOU SPEAK TO. THE FACT THAT
WE ON ONE HAND WE'RE EXPECTING
A CASE INCREASE AND MEDI CAL
AND GET IT. WAS AROUND TEN
YEARS AGO THE CUT BUDGET SO WE
HAVE TO MAKE CUTS. SAME TIME
THIS LOOKS ME LIKE WE'RE DOING
IS OUR DESTRUCTIVELY ROLLING IN
MONEY THAT THEN TAKES SENT
ELIMINATE THE WHOLE HEAD OF
PROGRAMS. CAPTAIN IT WOULD
ABOUT WOMEN TIONAL BENEFITS AS
WELL SO CAN YOU SPEAK. MAYBE
THE STRUCTURAL PIECE OF IT WILL
DIVE INTO THE SPECIFICS AND BY.
BUT THE STRONG. AND THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY. PAY FOR THINGS LIKE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH PROGRAMS
FUNDING TO BRING IN MORE THAT
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WILL TAKE
CARE TO MEDI CAL PATIENTS WE'RE
GOING TO. EXPECT THIS
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE TO. SPEAK
TO THAT AND WE'LL DIVE INTO
DOLLARS SPECIFIC DOLLARS LATER
IN SUBCOMMITTEE. YES ALL TURNED
BACK OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE RIGHT
NOW OR TO SPEAK ABOUT THIS.
YEAH. YEAH HI AND THANK YOU FOR
THOSE COMMENTS SENATOR AND- YOU
KNOW WE ARE VERY AWARE OF THOSE
CHALLENGES AND YOU KNOW I DON'T
THINK THAT- YOU KNOW CLEARLY
FOR EXAMPLE LAST YEAR WAS A
PRIORITY IN THE GOVERNOR IN
THIS ADMINISTRATION TO SURE
THAT ALL FIFTY STATES RATHER
NEWS WILL GOING PROVIDER
PAYMENTS AND- IT. WILL GENTLY
BUT- SYSTEM. I THINK THAT I
WOULD JUST GO BACK TO YOU KNOW
I'M MISTER. WHEN OPTIONS. ABOUT
THE I GUESS THE KIND OF
FRAMEWORK A STRATEGY THAT WE
WERE TRYING TO APPROACH THE
REVISION LEFT. ON IN A VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATION WITH A
LARGE BUDGET DEFICIT THAT WE'RE
FACING- AND IN A- PANIC- TRYING
TO MAINTAIN ELIGIBILITY FOR.
THEY HAD A AS A- POLICE YOUR
VISION. AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE
YOUR SECOND LARGEST GENERAL
FUND PROGRAM. MATT CAL. AND
YOUR CALLING FOR A BUDGET
DEFICIT THEY TO BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN OUR COMMITMENTS AND
THE RATES AND BENEFITS AREA-
WOULD MEAN. HARDER CUTS IN IN
EDUCATION AND OTHER PARTS OF
THE BUDGET NAY REALLY
PRACTICALLY IS VERY DIFFICULT
TO SOLVE THE BUDGET DEFICIT
EXACT SIZE WITHOUT HAVING TO
MAKE SOME CUTS IN THE
HEALTHCARE AREA YEAH IN A BUT
ALL THAT. YOU KNOW AGAIN WOULD
WOULD WOULD- YOU KNOW LOOK
FORWARD TO DISCUSSING
MUSICIANSHIP FURTHERANCE OF ME
TO SAY BECAUSE- YEAH THAT'S IT
YEAH I CAN RECOGNIZE THAT THOSE
ARE GONNA BE JACKETS THE CARD
SO I GUESS I JUST SAY IS THAT.
WE GET THE DEFICIT WE GET THE
AMOUNTS BUT EVEN WITHIN A
CERTAIN AMOUNT EVEN IF YOU'RE
MAKING A SIGNIFICANT. HOW YOU
STRUCTURE TO SPEND ALSO MATTER
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS A DID YOU
MAKE THE CUT GOT THAT SO PAINS
WAY WE STRUCTURED THE WAY THE
MONEY FOR IT AND I THINK THAT
THE PRINT THAT'S ALSO
CONVERSATION AS WELL SO. I GOT
THE I THAT WE DEFICIT CUT IN.
SOME OF YOU AS- TALK ABOUT
DISTRICT THE MINUTE WE SPEND
THE MONEY WITHIN THOSE
PARAMETERS OKAY SO WE HAVE THEM
THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE THE
ADDRESS THE DEFICIT THAT THE
JUST ONE FINAL PIECE AGAIN-
ANSWER SIMILARLY WERE EXPECTING
A LARGE EXPANSION IN THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO WILL ENTER THÅU
WORK. WITH GETTING. SOMETHING I
DON'T HAVE A COME. WHAT'S
IMPLEMENTS IN CHILD CARE
RESPECTFULLY TO GO UP- BUT YET
AGAIN SIMILARLY. BASICALLY
WE'RE MAKING REDUCTIONS THERE
AT THAT SEEMS TO BE COUNTER
PRODUCTIVE ACTUALLY IT PROBABLY
JUST FOR A SECOND TIME WON'T
ASK YOU TO RESPOND TO THIS
TODAY HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE
BUT LOOK FOR TO TALKING TO YOU.
AND BUT SUBCOMMITTEE ABOUT IT
IT JUST DOESN'T AGAIN SEEMS TO
BE INCONSISTENT WITH A CASELOAD
GOING YET WE'RE I GOT THE FACT
THE DEATH BUT YOU KNOW WOULD
HAVE STOOD IT. I THINK WE NEED
TO BE. MORE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
THE WAY WE'RE DOING THE CUTS IN
A WAY THAT REFLECT WHAT THE
GOALS THAT WE SEE IT HAPPENING
BECAUSE OF ENDEMIC AND
RESPONDING APPROPRIATELY TO
THAT. AND LOOK AT THE TOP OF MY
RESOURCE THAT'S GOING TO GO
INTO THAT SO FOR EXAMPLE MAYBE
JUST MAYBE SOME FEDERAL
FUNDING. SHOW UP. BUT WE ALSO
TO RECOGNIZE WHAT THE KEY IS
LOADING CREATE. IT IT'S
CHALLENGING TO SIMPLY SAY WE'RE
GOING TO CUT THIS PROGRAM WILL
GET THAT OUT WE'RE SPENDING
TASTE. THE MANAGER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I'D LIKE TO PAN
SIMMER MONEY. Q. CHAIR AND I
WANT THANK. THE STAFF OF BOTH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SOME. IN
THE LA- FOR. THEIR WORK ANNA.
IN THEIR ENGAGEMENT WITH US
TODAY. THERE'S BEEN REFERENCE
TO. OUR LAST GREAT RECESSION
200-082-0009 INTO. TWENTY TEN
ELEVEN. I CAME INTO THE
ASSEMBLY THAT TIME IN ONE OF
THE BIG DIFFERENCES WE RAN INTO
A FORTY TWO BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT. BUT WE COULD TRACE THE
CAUSES OF THAT TOO MALFEASANCE
IN THE FINANCIAL INDUSTRY
MALFEASANCE THAT LED TO MANY
PEOPLE LOSING THEIR HOMES
LOSING JOBS THROUGH
UNEMPLOYMENT BECAUSE BY THAT
CASCADING. GLOBAL ECONOMIC
CRISIS THIS CRISIS IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT. IT'S A PANDEMIC AND
WHILE WE DON'T KNOW THE COURSE
THAT THE PANDEMIC WILL TAKE. WE
DO HAVE THE CONFIDENCE OF
KNOWING. WE WERE IN A STRONG
ECONOMIC POSITION AT THE TIME
OF THE PANDEMIC IN THAT WERE
ABLE TO USE SOME OF THAT
STRENGTH AS WE NOW TRY TO
MANAGE THE CURRENT PROJECTED
SHORTFALLS. THERE'S BEEN
DIFFERENT ECONOMIC MODELS OF
HOW WE MIGHT RECOVER THE SPEED
OF THAT RECOVERY- BUT WE WILL
RECOVER. STRONG TV IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN NATIONALLY
THAT SAID I THINK OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THE UNKNOWN OF THE
COURSE OF COVERT NINETEEN. IN
THE DESIRE OF MANY TO RETURN TO
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND TRYING TO
BALANCE THAT. TO WHAT'S IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND REDUCING THE
CURVE OF DEATH- FROM. END
ILLNESS FROM COVERT NINETEEN.
ONE OF THE CONCERNS AND I'D
LIKE TO HEAR FROM BOTH FINANCE
AND LA- WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
CITIES THAT WE REPRESENT.
THEY'VE BEEN ON THE- BUT ONE
SERVE PUBLIC SAFETY RESPONSE
FIRE POLICE OTHER SERVICES
THEY'VE LOST REVENUE STREAMS TO
THE CITIES AS I UNDERSTAND THE
CURRENT. PROPOSED A RE. THE
GOVERNOR SEEKS CORRECT SOME OF
THE CARE IS MONEY THAT WE'VE
ALREADY BEEN ALLOCATED FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION TO THE
CITIES AND I THINK ONE POINT
TWO OR ONE POINT THREE BILLION
TO THE COUNTIES. I'M THERE'S
CERTAIN FROM CITIES THAT I
REPRESENT I KNOW THAT OTHERS
REPRESENT SMALLER SO THE CENTER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION CITY CENTER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND POPULATION.
AND ACTED SHORTFALLS FOR CITIES
OF UP TO SEVEN BILLION IT SEEMS
LIKE ONE OF THE UNKNOWN. AS WE
TRY TO NAY OUT OF THIS CRISIS
IS QUITE FEDERAL MONEY MAY BE
AVAILABLE IN THE MAY REVISE HAS
CRAFTED. A STRUCTURE WITH
TRIGGERS BASED ON FUTURE
FEDERAL MONEY. SO I HAVE ONE
OTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTION TO
THIS BUT I'D LIKE TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON WHAT APPEARS TO BE
THE AND ADEQUACY. OF THIS
DIRECTION OF THERE'S SUPPORT
FOR OUR CITIES. THERE'S ALSO
CONCERN OF SOME OF IT BEING
DIRECTED THROUGH COUNTIES TO
THE CITY'S. WHICH IS GOING TO
DEPUTISE ARE COUNTIES TO BE
AUDITOR'S IN PASS THROUGH. WHY
CAN'T SOME OF THIS GO DIRECTLY
TO CITIES SO THEY CAN PUT IT TO
USE OR BEST NEEDED SO I'D LIKE
TO HEAR THE ANSWERS TO THAT I
DO HAVE JUST ONE FOLLOW UP
QUESTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR MINING AND THAT'S AN
ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MIND IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS AS WELL ALL JUST
NEED. TO BRIEF COMMENTS AND
THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
ALL 8% SHELTER. I THINK THE
FIRST COMMENT IS
I BELIEVE THAT WAY START
FIFTEEN COUNTY OR AT FIFTY
JOHNNY'S YES I WAS SIX CITIES
AROUND THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO. IN A STATE WITH
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND NEARLY
FIVE HUNDRED CITIES SO MOST OF
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN THE
STATE DID NOT RECEIVE A DIRECT
ALLOCATION UNDER THAT FUNDING
SO I THINK THE FIRST THING THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS TIMES AND
HOPEFULLY AND I CAN READ
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
WHILE WORKING. WITH MEMBERS OF
THE CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION IS
SAYING THAT IN ANY FURTHER.
COMMENT DISCUSSED WITH THE
TRADERS WE'RE HOPING THAT AT
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
ACTION COMES NOT ONLY. INCLUDES
STATE HELLO MANAGE OUR OWN
BUDGET PICTURE BUT ALSO INCLUDE.
FURTHER DELAY KNOWLEDGE. TO
LOCAL CHURCH. INCLUDING THOSE
FEWER THAN FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE
WERE LEFT OUT OF THAT ACTION. I
THINK THE SECOND POINT IN THIS
WORLD FROM IT OVER TO KRISTIN
IS THAT- WE CAN'T SIMPLY WAIT I
SAY WELL WE HOPE THE CONGRESS
DOES MORE OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE TO
SCHOOL CONSTRAINTS THAT. ALL OF
US TOGETHER ARE DEALING WITH AS
WE ALL WORK OUT. IN THE NEXT
MONTHS AS YOU NINETEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RATINGS RIGHT NOW
AND NOT. I EVEN THOUGH NINE AND
HOW BILLION DOLLAR I WAS FOR
SOMEONE. IT WAS A PRIORITY AT
FOR THE GOVERNOR IN THE NAY
REVISION OPPOSING THE USE OF
THE TIMES SEND PORTIONS OF IT
TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ACTUALLY
DISCUSSED WE KNOW THAT TIME. WE
THAT THEY'RE FACING FALLING
REVENUE JUST AS WE ARE AND WE
HAVE STRONG PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COUNTIES WHEN IT COMES THAT
PUBLIC SAFETY HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES HOMELESSNESS THAT
CITIES AS WELL. KRISTIN THINGS
TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE NOW
DESTRUCTION. AND I THINK THAT
THERE IS A LOT MORE TO DO HERE.
AND SO CHRIS JOHNSON DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AS MY COLLEAGUE
NOTED WE DID ALLOCATE A PERSON
AT THE STATE'S NINE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THAT MONEY IS IN
ADDITION A FIVE POINT EIGHT
BILLION THAT WENT DIRECTLY TO
ABOUT 84% OF OUR- AND- COUNTIES
AND CITIES BASED ON POPULATION
DIRECTLY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. SO WHAT. THE POINT
THREE BILLION THAT IS ALEX TO.
IT IS ALLOCATED BASED ON KIND
OF TWO MAIN COMPONENTS RELATIVE
TO. THEIR SIZE SO THE FIRST IS
FOR THOSE CITIES IN COUNTY
COUNTIES WITH POPULATIONS
BELOW. FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WE ARE OUT EATING
APPROXIMATELY 50% OF THE ONE
POINT THREE BILLION. RANGE FROM
MY FIFTY THOUSAND FOR BETTER
SMALLER ANY UP TO ABOUT FIFTY
MILLION FOR LARGER COUNTIES IN
THAT AREA- WITH AN AVERAGE OF
ABOUT FIFTEEN AM MILLIONS. AT
IN ADDITION WE ARE ALLOCATING
THE REMAINING 50% ALSO TO THOSE
COUNTIES THAT RECEIVE SOME OF
THE DIRECT STIMULUS FUNDING AND
WE DIVIDED THAT INTO TWO
PRIMARY GROUPS LINE WHERE 45%
IS. DIVIDED AMONG THE COUNTY
HAS THAT RECEIVES DRIVE
ALLOCATIONS AND THEN THE
REMAINING 55% IS A DIVIDED
AMONG THE COUNTY IS THAT- ALSO
RECEIVE DIRECT ALLOCATIONS BUT
DID NOT HAVE ANY CITY LOCATION
SUBTRACTED FROM THEIR WORDS.
I'M IN TERMS OF THIS IS WE ARE
ALLOCATE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND PRIMARILY
DIRECTED AT PUBLIC SAFETY AND
HOMELESSNESS. AND IT IS THE WAY
IT BETWEEN KIND OF- THE SEVEN
CITIES HAVE POPULATIONS BETWEEN
THREE HUNDRED AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WITH YOU HEARD TWENTY
FIVE MILLION GOING TO THOSE
CITIES. AND THEN- TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION GOING
TO THE BALANCE I DON'T WANT
IMPORTANT NOTES AND I CERTAINLY
GIVE HER THE BEST AND WE
EXPERIENCED. CRIME WELL THERE
RIDLEY PROHIBITED FROM BEING
ABLE TO BE ALLOCATED TO DEAL
WITH THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
REVENUE LOSSES FIRST EXPERIENCE
OF THE STATE LOCAL LEVEL AND I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW IS CITIES
AND COUNTIES ARE FACED WITH
THE- DROP AND USE YOUR ARE YOUR
HERE FIGURES AND- RANGERS.
FORTUNATELY DO YOU HAVE ABILITY
TO USE THOSE FUNDS TO ADDRESS
THOSE TREMENDOUS DROPS IN
REVENUE. SEC LA- HAVE ANY
COMMENT ON THIS. HI IT'S
SENATOR MINING I NORMALLY WE
WOULD HAVE AT THIS POINT HAVE
ANY COMMENT ON THE PARTICULAR-
ALLOCATIONS THAT THE NEIGHBOR
VISION IS PROPOSING AS IT JUST
NINE POINT FIVE BILLION TO THE-
THIS IS INCLUDING TO THE CAT.
TO THE CITIES YEAH I WOULD
AGREE WITH. THIS RECESSION
DIFFERS FROM OUR MOST RECENT
RECESSION IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
AND NINE. WHICH WAS DRIVEN BY.
AN ACTUAL CRISIS AND SO THE
GOOD NEWS IS THAT IN THIS
CURRENT. SITUATION IT DOES SEEM
THAT THE BANKING SYSTEM AND
HOUSEHOLD ON SHEETS IN GENERAL
ARE SOMEWHAT HEALTHIER. AND
THEY WERE AT THAT TIME WHICH
COULD PROMOTE PUBLIC SOMEWHAT
FASTER ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
REALLY WHY CREATED A U. SHAPED.
IN OUR SPRING OUTLOOK SO THAT
YOU COULD SEE IN THE EVENT THAT
IT DID START TO LOOK LIKE THAT
TYPE OF A- PERSON WAS OCCURRING
YOU CAN SEE WHAT THE FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT MIGHT BE.
BUT OF COURSE AS YOU ALLUDED TO
I THINK THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY VERY HIGH LEVEL OF
UNCERTAINTY. NOT JUST THE REST
WE HAD. ALSO HAVE PEOPLE'S
RESPONSE TO THE VIRUS WHEN WILL
THEY BE COMFORTABLE RESUMING
THEIR ACTIVITIES AS THEY WERE
BEFORE AND THEN THIRD JUST KIND
OF. A THIRD DIMENSION TO THE
UNCERTAINTY IS JUST THE REGULAR
FORECAST YOU KNOW THAT ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN IN THE COURSE OUT OF
IT SO. I THINK THEN YOU KNOW
THE POTENTIAL FOR US RECOVERY
IS VERY PLAUSIBLE AND- I WOULD
NOT ARGUE WITH ANY OF THE
POINTS HAVE BEEN MADE ABOUT THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FEDERAL AID
THAT WOULD OBVIOUSLY BE QUITE
HELPFUL FOR. FOR THE STATE'S
BUDGET SITUATION IN THAT THE-
CURRENT YEAR AND NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
THE MAN IN CHAIR. ONE OTHER
AREA AND I REALIZE WILL FILL IN
SOME OF THE CENTER SUB
COMMITTEES. BUT I JUST KNOW.
OUR HOSPITALS IN OUR CARE
WORKERS. THEY'VE BEEN ON THE
FRONT LINES OF NOT ONLY.
MANAGING AND TREATING VICTIMS
OF COVERT NINETEEN BUT ALSO
PREPARING TO EXPAND CAPACITY
FOR ANTICIPATED INCREASES IN
NUMBERS SO CALLED SURGE- IN AS
A RESULT OUR HOSPITALS HAD TO
REALLY REORIENT THEIR ECONOMIES
BOTH PUBLIC CONSTABLES AND
PRIVATE HOSPITALS. REORIENT
THEIR THEIR BUSINESS MODELS TO
BE FIRST AND FOREMOST
RESPONSIVE TO COVERT NINETEEN
DEMANDS BUT ÍEN
THEIR NORMAL BUSINESS MODELS
AND JUST ANY THOUGHTS ON HOW HE
MAINTAIN. THE A CUTE CAPACITY
OF OUR HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
WORKERS TO CONTINUE TO RESPOND
A COVERT NINETEEN TO CONTINUE
TO FOLLOW OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS ON TIMING IN TIME TABLE
FOR. EASING BACK INTO BUSINESS
AS USUAL BUT HOW DO WE HELP OUR
HOSPITALS IS THERE ANYTHING IN
THE BUDGET DESIGNED TO FILL THE
GAP OF THOSE LOSSES OF OUR
PUBLIC HOSPITALS PRIVATE
HOSPITALS. AND THEN I'LL JUST
CLOSE WITH THIS IF. ANY ANY
INSIGHT ANY COM STATIONS
INVOLVING U. S. SENATE OR THE
ADMINISTRATION ON ENGAGING IN
NEGOTIATION ON FOR FURTHER
FURTHER RELIEF I'D APPRECIATE
ANY COMMENT ON THAT AS WELL
THANK YOU. SENATOR MONEY ON
THAT ISSUE AT HOSPITAL HEALTH
I'LL JUST MAKE TWO BRIEF
COMMENTS AND THEN I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO RIGHT NOW NO OR IN OUR
<c.red>HS SCHEMES I THINK NUMBER ONE</c>
THAT YOU MENTIONED AT THE END
THE- FEDERAL FUNDING AND- IN
THE MOST RECENT LEGISLATION
THAT WAS ACTUALLY ENACTED. DID
INCLUDE SOME FUNDING FOR
HOSPITALS BUT WE DO RECOGNIZE
THAT THEY NEED IS GREATER AND
WHILE THE NAY REVISION. GIVING
PRESSURE. ALL THIS TORRENT THAT
OLD MY ONE. WE ARE MAKING SURE
BOTH IN OUR DIRECT RESPONSE
YEAH KOBE NINETEEN AND- IN
TERMS OF MAKING SURE WE ARE
SEARCHING PASSED THE AND ALSO
THINKING THROUGH THE DIFFERENT
FACES ARE GETTING BACK TO SOME
SEMBLANCE OF THE NEW NORMAL.
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE KEEPING
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE HEALTH
OF OUR HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
INCLUDING A PUBLIC HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS IN MIND. AND I
CERTAINLY TOP OF MIND AND THEN
I THINK. THE SECOND THING IS-
WE WERE HAVING A CONVERSATION
BEFORE ABOUT OUR DIFFERENT
HEALTH AND INVESTMENT IN
HEALTHCARE INVESTMENTS WE DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE EVEN AS THE
BUS DOES. A SIM CARD. IN THIS.
WE ARE THINKING OF. HEALTH
HOSPITALS. AMERICAN. SIX THREE.
SPEAK ABOUT. THANK YOU SO HOW
YEAH CONCERN THE FEATHER
FUNDING THAT THE BACK MENTION
HOSP IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
RECEIVED NEARLY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE FEDERAL
PROVIDER RELIEF FUND I THAT WAS
PASSED AS A PART OF THE- CARES
ACT I IN ADDITION- SOME OF THE
FEDERAL HEALTH CENTERS HAVE
GOTTEN THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS I BELIEVE ROUGHLY
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ARE THAT THERE ARE OPTIONAL. BE
MADE AND RECENT FEDERAL
LEGISLATION I THINK THE KERRS
THREE POINT FIVE ACT INCLUDED
ANOTHER SIXTY FIVE OR SEVENT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
NATIONWIDE- SO WE CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW THE DEVELOPMENTS ABOUT
HOW THOSE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH HOSPITALS AND PUBLIC
HOSPITALS TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY AND-
COMPARE. THE HOSPITAL'S WORSE
THAN IT. YOU KNOW I COULD IT'S
DEFINITELY TO SAY THAT THERE
FOR SOME SIGNIFICANT AS HAS
BEEN MY REPORTED IN WE'VE HEARD
DIRECT FROM FROM THE WE DO NOT
PROPOSE ANY NEW STATE FOR A- IN
A REVISION COURSE DOING SO AS
SOON IN THE BUDGET STRUCTURE IS
FIXED WOULD REQUIRE EVEN MORE
REDUCTIONS IN OTHER AREAS AND I
THINK THAT IN THAT CONTEXT. AND
WE UNABLE TO PROPOSE THAT THE
MAYOR VISION- I THINK I JUST
ALSO ECHO THE OTHER COMMENTS
THINK IT'S BEEN PRETTY WIDELY
MADE. ABOUT THE- FUNDING IN
ADDITION FEDERAL IS FOR THE
OPRY'S. I THINK YOU LA HAVE ANY
COMMENT ON HOSPITAL PUBLIC
HEALTH FRIEND I WOULD THAT
OFFER AN OPPORTUNITY FOR MY
COLLEAGUE MARK NEWTON- NEWS ON
ON THE MEETING HERE P. HAS ANY
POINTS TO WEIGH IN ON. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING HE DOESN'T HAVE A
CAMERA BUT MEMBER. THERE'D
SEARCHING THE PARTICIPANT LIST
NOW BUT- OKAY COULD YOU REPEAT
THE NAME. HIS MARK NEWTON HE
WAS A DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST AND YEAH I WAS GONNA
ASK HIM TO HELP RESPOND THE
COURT. WE ON DISSIDENTS LIVE.
THAT HE'S ON THE PHONE MADAM
CHAIR COURTYARD SHIFTS OKAY SO
HE'S ON THE PHONE NOT ON OUR
TELECONFERENCES STEM CELL
MISTER NEW CAN HEARINGS. YES
YES WE KAMLAGER CLEAR IF YOU GO
AHEAD RESPOND THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD SORRY FOR THE TECHNICAL
ISSUE THERE YEAH MARK YOU CAN
BUT THE BUT THE LA L. AND A
PLEASURE TO TALK TODAY SENATOR
MITCHELL AND MEMBERS- YOUR-
QUESTION ABOUT THAT I'M PUBLIC
HOSPITALS. AND PUBLIC HOSPITAL
AND THAT- WHETHER THERE WAS ANY
SORT OF ANYTHING THAT SORT OF
ADDITIONAL IN THE- IN THE IN
THE BUDGET TO. COULD USE YOUR
HELP THE TERM. AND AFTER TO
MENTION THIS SURVEY HAS BEEN
SOME SO DIRECTS FEDERAL AGENT
YEAH AND ACTUALLY TWO OF THE
FEDERAL TAXES- A GOOD CRAPPIE
TO HOSPITAL. PROVIDERS AND THAT
IS TO THE BEING BEING
DISTRIBUTED STRIPPED DOWN AND
THAT THAT- IT IS VERY RELEVANT-
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE AT THE
TOTAL NUMBERS OF THE THAT'S FOR
THE TOTAL HALL BUDGET. HE
ACTUALLY. ALTHOUGH YOU CAN ALL
BY THANK CANCER OVER EMPHASIZE
THAT THE WILL THAT FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE ARE PLAYING BUT INTRO
OF SORT OF WHAT THE STATE CAN
DO I THINK SOME THE QUESTION OF
A VERY SENATORS TODAY ON ON THE
ISSUE OF THE JOURNAL YEAH
BUDGET THE BUDGET PROPOSED
BUDGET SOLUTION THROUGH THE
LAND- HOW DO THEY- DO THEY
POTENTIALLY WORK AT AT CROSS
PURPOSES- THE- THE PANDEMIC
RESPONSE WHEN YOU SAY THAT DEMI
FIND WE WERE TALKING.
OFFICEDEPOT BUT A RISK.
ECONOMIC RESPONSE. AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY HAS BEEN A CURRENTLY
SERVES VALUE WAITING AREA
PROPOSAL BUT THERE IS PROPOSED
FOR INSTANCE TO ANSWER THE THIS
BROWN TALK WORK. WILL GRAHAM
ANY AND PERHAPS IN LOOKING AT
THE LANDS ENDEMIC RESPOND THAT
WHEN THE QUESTION WHETHER THAT
IS- YOU'RE LOOKING AT CROSS
PURPOSES AND WITH THEIR OTHER-
I THINK BUDGET SOLUTIONS THAT
DON'T. SO DIRECTLY SERVICE PACK
FOR THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE
SO- MISTRESSES CORRECTLY REALLY
ISN'T THAT- ANYTHING CORRECT.
PULLS BUT WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE ISSUE AND LOOKING AT
POTENTIAL POP. ALTERNATE BACK
THAT MADE NAY ADDRESS THE
ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I GUESS BUT HE WON'T. PINE
AND QUIT. FEDERAL SUPPORT
FORWARD. SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER BUT- HI I WOULD JUST
CLOSE BY URGING THE IMPORTANCE
OF THAT CONVERSATION FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH NOT JUST OF
CALIFORNIA BUT FOR THE UNITED
STATES. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
SKI WHO WILL BE FOLLOWED BY
THREE TO DO RUSSELL CENTER
WHITE HOUSE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I WILL- I'LL TRY TO
KEEP THIS AS- A WHOLE BECAUSE-
SUB. YOU WILL BE MEET ON SUNDAY.
TWENTY FOURTH AT TEN O'CLOCK.
WE'LL HOPEFULLY DRILL DOWN AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE AT THAT TIME
AND I WILL BE SUBMITTING SOME
WRITTEN QUESTIONS MAP OF. HERE
ABOUT YOU KNOW. THANK PEOPLE
LAST FOUR HUNDRED SIXTEEN. THEY
GOT THIRTY SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE HUNGRY YOU KNOW. WHY
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS CHOSEN
NOT TO WHAT SUSPEND SCHOOL
TESTING FOR A YEAR OR THESE ADA
REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE THAT SAVES
THE STATE'S THE MONEY. AND YOU
KNOW THE HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION WHERE IS THAT RIGHT
OKAY. LET ME WE IT SEEMS IN
RESOURCE WHAT A LITIGATION
ATTORNEY COSTS- YOU KNOW THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY CONSERVATION
NATURAL RESOURCES IS THAT AN
ANOMALY OR WE'VE BEEN SUED OR
SUING. FOLK SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE TO. CONTINUE TO A PAY IF
SOMEBODY HAS AN IDEA ON THAT.
THE SERVICE WILL OFTEN. YES SO
I THINK I'LL HAVE TO CHECK BACK
ON THAT WHEN YOU. TURN IT OVER.
THIRTY I WHO ARE ON OUR TEAM.
WE MIGHT HAVE TO CHECK BACK ON
THOSE DETAILS SEARCH YOUR
DOESN'T HAPPEN RIGHT IN FRONT
OF THIS MOST OF ST. SERVICE
NUMBER COULD YOU REPEAT THE
NAME OF YOUR TEAM MEMBER
PLEASE. YES SERGIO AVELAR AG
YOU HI HOW ARE YOU. THE THIRD
DRIVER FINANCE. YES OKAY IT IS
NOT NECESSARILY ON COMMON THAT
THESE COSTS ARE INCURRED BY-
DEPARTMENTS I THINK JUST
BECAUSE YOU'RE TO DEEP CLEAN
BILL AND WHAT ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT ARE ABLE THEY. ARE
NOT ABLE TO WORK. THE
EUROVISION BUT THEY'RE NOT A-
OKAY I'LL SKIP IN INCOME THE
CHIEF WAS TALK ABOUT THIS FUNDS
IN THE CORE MISSIONS THAT THAT
THESE AGENCIES HAVE TO DO AND
ALL B ASKING THE AIRPORT ABOUT
THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL BOARD
BUT IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTION YOU HAVE. OUR AIRPORT
ACCOUNT AND THE UNIVERSAL
LIFETIME LIFELINE SERVICE AND
THEN THERE'S TRANSFERS FROM THE
CONGESTION MANAGEMENT RELIEF-
AND THE STATE HIGHWAY FUND CAN
YOU EXPLAIN THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THESE TRANSACTIONS. WHY
ARE SOME FUNDS BEING TERMED IS
LOANS AND OTHERS ARE BEING
CERTAIN IS TRANSFERS BECAUSE I
HEARD AT THERESPONSE TO THE
CHEERS QUESTION THAT THESE WILL
BE PAID BACK. SO THE SPECIAL
FUND LOANS WILL ALL BE PAID
BACK WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SPECIFIC ITEMS LET ME TURN IT
OVER TO MARK WHO CONVERSES
TRANSPORTATION. FOR FINANCE.
YES WORK WHEN ROAD APARTMENT
FINANCE AND- THAT'S CORRECT WE
HAVE- THERE'S- SOME SOME FUNDS
WHICH YOU KNOW YOU MENTIONED
THE LOCAL AIRPORT LOAN ACCOUNT
AND WE ARE BORROWING THOSE
FUNDS- THIS COULD BE- COULD BE-
TAKEN IT KIND OF DEPENDS ON THE
NATURE OF THE FINE YOU LOOK AT
THE LIFE LINE FIND- THE END.
THAT SHE DOES FUNDS ARE
SUPPOSED BE. THERE FROM RATE.
IS THE FORCE FUNDING THAT
PROGRAM. AND SO WE HAVE. THREE
TO BUY THEM WE HAVE OUR THE
PAST EIGHT THEM SO REALLY TERMS
OF ONES ARE WHICH ONES ARE IT
CAN BE. ON THE NATURE OF THE
PROGRAM IT ALSO. ANY OTHER
SOURCE GESTURE TO OR IN THE
CASE OF TRANSPORTATION-
CONSTITUTIONAL LIMITATIONS SO
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE STATE HOW
WE CAN THE TRAFFIC CONGESTION
RELIEF FUND- THE FUNDS THAT
WERE TAKING AND THOSE ARE NOT
PROTECTED BY ARTICLE NINETEEN
CONSTITUTION. PROTECTS MORE
OTHER. IN FUNDS. AND SO THIS
CASE IS WERE ABLE TO JUST
TRANSFER THEM. ALTHOUGH I'M
SURE MY CALL ON THE OTHER SIDE
THE I WE'VE SOME. PROBLEMS WITH
THE MORE MOTOR VEHICLE. AND
CHALLENGES THAT BEFORE THE
CRISIS SO WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT- MISTER VISALIA ALL OF
THEM IT WAS- YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS COLLBORATION AND
CONSULTATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THAT TO. THIS
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO KEEP
UP- BUT YOU WANTED SOME FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE FLEXIBILITY MORE
TALKING ABOUT THOSE CONTROL
ACCOUNTS AND I HEARD YOU SAY
THAT THIS FLEXIBILITY WAS
NECESSARY PARTICULAR WITH THE
FEDERAL FUNDS BECAUSE YOU
DIDN'T KNOW. YOU KNOW WHAT HOW
THIS FEDERAL FUNDS WERE
SHIFTING YOU TO ME. HOLES IN
THE BUDGET ONE WITH CAN TRADE A
FLOOD. FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT WILL BASICALLY DETERMINE
WHERE THE PRIORITIES WILL GO ON
THE 40% DISCRETIONARY FUNDS AND
I SEE THAT DEPARTMENTS WOULD BE
DIRECTED TO PARK YOUR TOWARDS.
YOUR TORY PRIORITIZE THEIR NON
DISCRETIONARY- BUCK COSTS NOT
THE LEGISLATURE NOT THE THAT
THE SENATE OR THE ASSEMBLY AND
THEN THE CONSUMER FOR. YOU'VE
GOT LOT OF MONEY ASKING THE
FUND THAT YOU KNOW- BUT WE'RE
WE'RE TOLD I THINK THE
LANGUAGES IS THAT THERE WILL BE
TRAILER LANGUAGE BILL THAT WILL
GIVE BILL BUT JUST SWITCH. MORE
TIME TO VALUE WAITED IN THE IN
SUMMER. BOB YOU KNOW I'M- BILLS
AND WAGE GO. BANK LEVEES I GOT
A HEARING TOMORROW ON ON-
LICENSING DEBT COLLECTORS I'VE
HEARD IS NOTHING AS FAR AS
DETAILS FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THE CONSUMER PROTECT. AND I
FAST I BASS THEM BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND I'M ONE BEING.
IT'S GOING TO BE DUMPED ON US
AT THE END THE SESSION AND- WE
NOT WANT TO. I WOULD WE WANTED
TO CONSUMER PROTECTION WOULDN'T
WANT TO HAVE THE NORMAL
LEGISLATIVE HEARING PROCESS- TO
CHIEF THAT. YES CENTER WHITE
HOUSE YOU LET ME TOUCH ON
BRIEFLY AT EACH OF THOSE THREE
AREAS THAT YOU MENTIONED AND
THEN ANY FOLLOW UP I KNOW SOME
OF MY COLLEAGUES NAY ELABORATE
IS. FIRST WHAT YOU MENTIONED
THAT LAST WHICH IS THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION LAWS
PROPOSED IN. I DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE LEGISLATURE. WE RECEIVE A
LOT AS QUICK FACTS GIVING THEY-
OF THE GRAVITY OF. THE
LEGISLATIVE TIMELINE BETWEEN
NOW AND BY STATE NOT. ON JUNE
SIXTEENTH ABOUT SOME OF OUR
PROPOSALS FROM EIGHT TO THE
ORGANIZATION. CREATION NEW
HOURS WHEN YOU WERE. THE SECTOR
BRANCH SOME OF THOSE WE BELIEVE
ARE IMPORTANT OTHER. SCIENCE
NEWS INCLUDING THAN IN THE NAY
RATIONS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
LOS THIS IS A GREAT IN THIS
CASE WE DO UNDERSTAND. AYE
SLOUGH THIS WE WANT TO GET IT
DONE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE WE
HAVE HEARD FEEDBACK FROM
LEGISLATORS LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
IT'S NOT YOU RUSSIAN THROUGH
THE PROCESS SO THERE IS
DEFINITELY NO INTENTION TO JOHN
ANY. YEAH ACTUALLY GROUP THANKS
IS THAT WHILE BUDGET SHOULD
AUTHORIZE THE NECESSARY FUNDING
IS I WAS AWARE MOVED FORWARD ON
THOSE THREE. THE USED THOSE
THREES WILL BE CONTINGENT ON
APPROVAL I A TRAILER BILL DON'T
LIKE WE WERE NOT PLAY UNTIL THE
SUMMER ON YOUR STATE. AND WITH
YOUR IN CLASS SO WE ARE
DEFINITELY OPEN TO WITH YOU ON
THAT WE WERE SIMPLY ECONOMIST
I'M NOT TO RAISE TAX THROUGH
THE NAY. YES NEEDED WE DO
UNDERSTAND WE- DO OFFER.
ADDITIONAL DETAIL ON THAT IF
THERE ARE. SPECIFIC ON CLOSE. I
KNOW WE ALSO CLEAN. ON THIS.
WHEN IT COMES TO BE A SECOND
ITEM THEY MENTIONED WHICH IS
CAP AND TRADE AS KNOW AS WELL
AS ANYBODY. ON THE AUCTION
RATHER YOU FOR THIS YEAR IS
LIKELY BE SIGNATURE LOWER. AND
WE SEEN A GREAT YOUR- SO THE
PROPOSED THAT THE NEW VERSION
OR WERE. I THINK THAT. SPENDING
FOR UNITY PROTECT FOR FOREST
AND FIRES. AND FOR STATE WATER
AND FOR DRINKING WATER. DOES
WERE THE IS THAT THE- BELIEVES
MOST. ARE GETTING THE GOVERNOR
SAYS THE CRYO. AND SOME OF THE
FACT THAT HE'S- FROM THE LAST
BUT WE- BUT WE ARE WILL WORK
WITH YOU ALREADY KNOW COUPLE.
THE LEGISLATURE FORTY START
PARKS PRIORITY. THAT'S GOING TO
BE A DISCUSSION BETWEEN MINUTES.
AND THE LEGISLATURE WILL WE
DON'T WANT TO DO. USE OVER.
FIND THAT BEYOND RESOURCE THAT
ARE OF THE AND THAT'S WHAT IT'S
THE ADMINISTRATION. TAKE THE
STAIRS YOU GO. AND COMMITTEE
PROTECTION AND THE SIZE. WATER
WHICH WAS SUCH A PRIORITY
MINUTES LAW YEAR AND OF COURSE
GIVEN FINEST WHICH IS CAME OUT
OF AND ANOTHER ONE LIKELY WILL
BE TELLING YOU. PRIORITIZE THAT
AREAS. AND THEN. ON THE FIRST I
AM NOW NINETY WHICH RELATES TO
THE USE OF THE FEDERAL FUNDING.
THE CONTROLS WE HAVE. ANY UP ON
CHRIS I NOTICED ALLIANCE
BASICALLY SO THAT WE ONE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS MONEY IS
YOU KNOW. WHEN IT GOES THE
LOCALS. THE LOCAL I. IN. WITH
FEDERAL KIND MY AND IS NOW
BECAUSE LOTS THE FEDERAL KIND
OF MINE. WE WISH THAT MANY OF
THEM WOULD BE TO. BUT BECAUSE
WE DON'T WANT MIGHT BE FOR CALL
BACKS. ARE GOVERNMENT ARE GOING
TO BE. SO UNDER THE CONTROL
THAT WE HAVE ALWAYS WE WANT TO
HAVE TO SAY BY SEPTEMBER. TO
MAKE SURE THAT LOCALS ARE TRACK
SPEND MONEY IN WAY THAT ARE
COMPORT WITH US I DON'T. AND IT
IS ONLY THAT THOSE CAN BE ARE
MAX THAT SOMEBODY'S. SERVICES I
SO HAPPY TO QUESTIONS ON OF
THOSE AREAS BUT HE STARTED OF
THINGS THAT WE WANT MAKE SURE
THAT WE INTO BUDGET AS WE
TOWARDS SIXTEENTH WHAT CONCERNS
ME IS THAT THE LA ENDED HIS.
PRESS THAT IT THAT SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS. LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY IT WOULD SEEM TO ME
THAT AT LEAST ON THE 40% OF THE
CAP AND TRADE. YOU KNOW YOU'VE
PICKED PROGRAMS THAT DON'T
REDUCE EMISSIONS I MEAN WHILE
FAITH IN AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER IS LAUDABLE AND FOREST
THEM FIRE PROTECTION THE BALL
YOU'VE GOT MONEY. AT NEW. USE
FOR YOU EVER GET. IS WE SEE. TO
DO IT YOU KNOW AND I KNOW THAT
I'M WE THERE'S GOING TO BE AN
OPTION ON THE CAP AND TRADE AND
I AND I TO HAVE MAJOR CONCERNS
OVER THE SIGNALS THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS GIVEN TO THE
MARKET ON WHETHER THEY ARE
SERIOUS ABOUT PRICING IN
MISSIONS IN ORDER IN THE FUTURE
FOR THAT IT IT IT IT REFLECTS
THE COST ON SOCIETY IT'S- EIGHT
EIGHT TO WIN AND TEST GOING ON
AB SEVENTEEN AND TEST THANK YOU
THESE WITH THE- POLLUTION IS
REDUCE 40% LOSS AT. RESET BUT
YOU'RE DOING THE WORK RIGHT AND
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL THAT COULD
MINISTRATION CHARTS OUT FOR THE
NEXT EIGHT NINE YEARS HOW
YOU'RE READING THOSE THOSE
PRICES YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE AIRPORT TO
START REGULATIONS TO DO THAT
AND THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE
THAT READ THAT AT. TO THE CORE
PROBLEM IN THIS WHEN YOU'RE- A-
YOU YOU CARE ABOUT THE SAID THE
A COMMUNITY SO I HOPE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SERIOUS ABOUT
THIS. I EXPECT YOU CAN RELATE
TO THE PEOPLE AND SUB TO THAT
WE WILL BE ASKING SOME
DIFFICULT QUESTION. AND I. THE
ACT ALSO MY TIME THAT SENATOR
DORADO. FEDERAL REMEMBER TO
SPEAK DIRECTLY INTO THE MIKE
THANK YOU OKAY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. I JUST ARE I WAS TRYING
TO. COME UP WITH QUESTIONS AND
NOT GET TOO SPECIFIC- ON THE
OTHER HAND TRYING TO SEE WHAT
IS IT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH THIS UP WITH
HIS BUDGET. THERE'S SO MANY
THINGS THAT WE COULD PUT IN SO
MANY DETAILS BUT WHAT WE REALLY
WANT TO. END UP WITH AT THE END
OF THE AT THE END OF THE DAY
AND IT'S REALLY HARD BECAUSE-
OF. FOR ME. ONE MAJOR GOAL IF
NOT THE TOP GOAL TO SHOULD BE
TO TAKE CARE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE. OUR PEOPLE IN THE
STATE. ARE THE ONES THAT WERE
ALREADY FULL NOBLE AND BECAME
EVEN MORE VULNERABLE I TRIED TO
USE THAT AS A- WAY TO GUIDE MY
QUESTIONS- SO THE FIRST
QUESTION I HAVE IS. WHAT WAS
THE CRITERIA WHAT WAS THE
THOUGHT BEHIND DECIDING WHICH
ROLL BACKS UP FROM JANUARY'S
PROPOSED BUDGET- YOU KNOW WOULD
YOU WOULD YOU TAKE UP. YES
SENATOR DRAWS SO WHEN IT CAME
TO THAT ROLL BACKS- FROM
JANUARY AND THE ADMINISTRATION
PUT OUT OF BUDGET LETTER IN
MARCH APRIL AYE IF THIS SPRING
EITHER MORE STRAIGHT ACROSS MY
DIRECTING AND DEPARTMENTS
AGENCIES OR SUBMITTING BUDGETS
SOULS YOU THINK ABOUT. IN THE
CONTEXT OF A BUDGET RANGE
DURING OUR. GAINES BUT WE HAVE
A TWENTY NINETY BUDGET ACT AND
AS WE CAN ALL SEE WITH NEIGHBOR.
I EVEN HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
GIVEN THAT. TENDERLY DOLLARS IN
DAIS THAT ARE WITHIN THAT. SO
WHEN IT CAME TO THE PROPOSAL'S
INDIANA. I SAY NEAR EVERYTHING
WAS ON THE WAS THE LIST FOR
ROLLED BACK IN ITEMS THAT WERE
NOT ROLE BACK YOUR MADE
SIGNATURE. REALLY RELATED
SIMPLY. WILDFIRES YOU. THE
PRIMARY CATEGORY AND I CAN GO
BACK AND JUST ALL UP INTO OF
SPECIFIC ITEMS I DON'T KNOW
THOSE ARE WAS IN THE NAME. OUR
BACKS MOST OF THE MAJOR I DON'T.
NEW X. THAT WORK OF JANUARY
WERE PULLED BACK THE GOVERNOR
WILL IT IS VERY DISAPPOINTED
ABOUT THAT THIS CITED THAT. YOU
KNOW THE PRICE CONFERENCE THAT
I JUST LAST FOR NEARLY HOURS.
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT CAUSAL
THANK YOU THE WORLD THAT WE ARE
A NOT ALL EVERY COASTAL FROM
JANUARY HAS TO WHAT'S WRONG.
AND ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
COLD WITH NINETEEN WHERE WE
KNOW THAT. ONE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE- OF GROUPS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE OVER SIXTY
FIVE AND SO IT SEEMED TO ME TO
FIT IN AND IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
FACTORED IN WAS THOSE THAT ARE
MOST VULNERABLE UNDER NOT ONLY
GENERALLY BUT- ESPECIALLY IN
THIS ENVIRONMENT OF COLE BUT
COLE BUT NINETEEN. AND THE ARE
EXTENDING THAT TO SUCH A SMALL.
ADDITIONAL NUMBER OF ON COVERED
UNINSURED. IT SEEMED TO ME TO
MAKE THE MOST SENSE THEY'RE THE
ONES WHO CAN BECOME THE MOST
VULNERABLE THEY ARE THE MOST
AND- IN ADDITION TO THAT WE'RE
FINDING NOW. THAT OF CERTAIN
GROUPS ETHNICALLY ARE BEING
IMPACTED FAR MORE. I THINK SOME
OF THIS COULD PREDICTED THAT.
OF FAR MORE LATINOS THE STATE.
OF AFRICAN. AND A AGENT
ISLANDERS OF THOSE ARE GROUPS
THAT ARE GETTING IMPACTED EVEN
MORE SO COULDN'T YOU MAKE THE
CONNECTION THERE THAT OF. THIS
MEDI CAL EXPANSION AS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED IN THE END DECIDED
THE ROLL BACKS SHOULD HAVE
INCLUDED- GROUPS LIKE THIS
VULNERABLE GROUPS THAT ARE YOU
COULD SEE THE NUMBER OF CASES
AND THE NUMBER OF DEATHS ARE SO
HIGH- DISPROPORTIONATELY TO THE
REST OF THE POPULATION. SO I
WOULD URGE RECONSIDER OBVIOUSLY
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE WE HAVE FOR
MORE INFORMATION TODAY. THAN WE
DID BACK IN JANUARY. AND IF
THERE'S ANY COMMENTS ABOUT THEM.
YES WILL SIMPLY SAY I'LL MAKE
SURE TO TAKE THAT BACK ON THE
CALL IN THE IN. AND YOU ARE
THIS IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
AND SO VERY COGNIZANT THAT AND
DECISIONS THAT WE MAY I CAN
ALWAYS CAN SAY WILL CHANGE IS
NOT. A OUR GOAL WHEN I ALLERGY
I KNOW YOU'RE ASKING. ASKED
ABOUT ELIGIBILITY SHE FOR THE
MEDICAL. WAS TO PRESERVE. WHAT
WE- COLLUDED THE EXTENT. COME
FROM DOCUMENTS TELLS TO AGE
TWENTY SIX THAT WAS PASSED IN
LAST MUCH ACTING SO WE KNOW
THAT'S NOT UNITS KIND OF. WE
HAVE AN. ON THE LINE- THE
SECOND QUESTION IS- WHAT WAS
THE CRITERIA USED TO DECIDE THE
LIST OF CUTS. OR THE AREAS OF
CUTTING UP AND I KNOW THERE
WERE SEVERAL COMMENTS MADE
PRIOR ESPECIALLY BY- DOCTOR PAN
OF BUT WHAT DID YOU USE TO
DECIDE. ITS POTENTIAL CUTS. YES
SO WHEN IT CAME TO THOSE BASE
CARDS ARE AND ALL ALMOST ALL OF
WHICH ARE IN AT FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS TRIGGER THEY
WERE DEAR REACHED YOU- PROGRAMS
THAT STATE SO YOU KNOW K.
TWELVE EDUCATION HIGHER
EDUCATION YOU KNOW WHILE MEDI
CAL ELIGIBILITY SCHOOLS ARE.
MEDI CAL OPTIONAL. WERE REDUCE
OR ELIMINATED DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICE DAYS YEAH I JUST ASK
PROGRAM SO THESE ARE THE COURTS
IN THE CORE. HUMAN WELFARE
FUNCTIONS OF GOVERNMENT AND
NONE OF THOSE PROGRAMS IT'S
GETTING HOT AND WHEN IT CAME TO
THOSE CUTS. THERE WERE A COUPLE
AREAS AND I KNOW THAT. WHERE
THERE WERE A GEN TALK YOU KNOW
FIRST. YOU CAN CALIFORNIANS.
STATE WE A CLASS AND- BASIS
JURORS HER I. HSN. THEIR RECESS
CHRISTIAN. FOR THE SERVICE OUR
AT WORK FOR. WHEN IT CAME TO
SOME OF THESE ARE PRO AS
MEDICARE FOUR X. WE ARE THE
RATES FOR REDUCE IDEA NOT WORKS
FINE DAY BY. FIFTY SIX AND
THOSE AND SEND A CHECK GENERAL
MEDI CAL GROSS AND THERE WAS
ALSO. A METHODOLOGY THAT WE
WANT TAX IN DECIDING
DEVELOPMENTAL. SERVICES THAT'S
SHOULD BE IN IN THE TRIGGER AND
EITHER CALLING THE LINE. I NEED
MORE DETAIL ON THAT WE TRY TO
STAY AN APPROACH THAT WOULD
MINIMIZE THE HARM KNOWING THAT
THERE'S NO WAY TO ELIMINATE
MINDS WHO ARE STATIONED. THIS
WELL AGAIN I THINK THAT IF AT
THE START. PRIORITY WORK THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS I
THINK THE RESULTS COULD HAVE
BEEN A DIFFERENT AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
GOVERNMENT. TO REALLY STAND UP
AND HOLD UP HIGH THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN OUR STATE-
AND JUST A- COUPLE MORE THINGS-
WE DO HAVE WE STILL IT IN YOUR
PROPOSED BUDGET WE STILL HAVE
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS. IRV IS THAT IS THAT
CORRECT THAT I READ IT RIGHT.
SO DEAR ON DEBTS IT UNDER THE
COURT IN A RAINY DAY FUND WHICH
IS THE BIGGEST LEVEL OF
RESEARCH WE ARE AT COMPOSING
SPENDING SEVEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR SO AFTER THAT THEY WOULD
BE AN ADDITIONAL. IRAQI POINT
FOUR BILLION IN THAT ACCOUNT
APPROXIMATELY AS WELL AS
ANOTHER FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN THE SAFETY NET
RESEARCH. OUR ON MULTI YEAR
FORECAST DOES SHOW. RESEARCH IN
ITS YEARS. SO WITH SO WHAT'S
THE WHAT'S THE POINT OF THE
ELEVEN OR WHATEVER EIGHT ELEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN IN RESERVE
WILL WORK CUTTING BACK UP
POTENTIALLY COMING CUTTING BACK
ESPECIALLY OF CUTTING BACK ON
SUCH ESSENTIAL SERVICES FOR
SUCH ESSENTIAL VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. YES THAT'S A
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION BECAUSE
WE'RE SEEING THESE CUTS IN LIKE
YOU MENTIONED IN ACROSS THE
STATE IN COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW
THE THINKING HERE IS TWO FOLD
NUMBER ONE. THERE IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL PROHIBITION
UNDER PROPOSITION TWO ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF RESEARCH THAT YOU CAN
WITHDRAW FROM THE RAINY DAY
SIGNS IN A GIVEN YEAR. BUT MORE
THAN THAT I THINK THE SECOND
POINT WHICH IS NO WE HOPE IS
NOT THE CASE THAT WE'RE
PROJECTING TO BE THE CASE IS
THAT EVEN THOUGH WE ARE ALL
HOPEFUL THAT THE NINETEEN AND
THEN MAKE OVER THE NEXT YEAR
WILL BE RESOLVED. MAXINE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THE
ECONOMIC EFFECTS BASS ARE GOING
TO REVERBERATE IN TERMS OF THIS
CRISIS PROJECTS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS EVEN THREE OR FOUR YOU
DOWN THE ROAD MAY NOT NECESSARY
I SEE. ALL HERE. YEARS AGO SO
BUDGET OF THE RESEARCH IN THE
IN THE SKY YEAR THAT MAKES
THINGS LITTLE BIT YOU AND THIS
YEAR BUT IT MAKES THINGS LOT
HARDER MAY THE COST WORSE THE
NEXT YEAR IN THE AFTER THAT SO.
WE WHILE WE ARE SIMPLY IT OUT
THE BUDGET FOR THE COMING YEAR.
OKAY AND WE CAN STRUCTURE
DEFICITS ALRIGHT IN THE YEAR
AFTER. WE DID WANT TO HAVE
SOMETHING OF A LONG TERM
OUTLOOK IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE MINIMIZING THE DAMAGE
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE TO. FACE IN
THOSE COMING YEARS. ACTIONS FOR
OUR ECONOMY. YEAH YEAH AND I
UNDERSTAND I MEAN I UNDERSTAND
THAT POINT OF VIEW AGAIN. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO WILL
NOT HAVE FOOD ON THE TABLE.
PEOPLE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SURVIVE. AND THAT'S THE BALLOTS
THAT'S THE PART OF THE BUDGET
THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT WITH
REGARDS TO STILL HAVE ENOUGH OF
A RESERVE OF THAT SIZE TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF THE PEOPLE
WHO WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SURVIVE.
FRAN DEATHS. AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE LAST ONE
IS IT'S A VERY SPECIFIC- BUT-
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WERE
TAKING UP AND TALKING ABOUT
BEFORE. THE BEFORE THE WHOLE
BIT. AND THAT IS ABOUT THE
FUNDING FORMULA FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION- I REPRESENT. UP MY
DISTRICT IN MY DISTRICT. THE
HIGHEST OF ALL. WITH REGARDS TO
SPECIAL ED STUDENTS IN THE LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
IMPACTED OF VERY HARSHLY UP BY
THE WAY THE ALLOCATION IS MADE
SO I JUST WANT TO BRING IT TO
YOUR ATTENTION I THINK THIS
CONTINUES TO BE. UP A
DISPROPORTIONATE OF FINANCIAL
RISK DISABILITY ON THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ESPECIALLY AT A TIME
WHEN THEY'RE NOW GOING TO HAVE
TO. ADDRESS ALL THE ADDITIONAL
EXPENSES- YOU KNOW TO TAKE CARE
OF THE STATE'S CHILDREN AND THE
YOUTH AND THE AND THE STUDENTS
SO I WANT TO BRING THAT. TAKE
IT TO YOUR ATTENTION. THAT'S IT
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER CABALLERO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND ONE I
THINK. THANK THE- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY IT REALLY APPRECIATE
THE THOUGHTFULNESS THAT'S GONE
INTO THIS BUDGET. IT'S NEVER
EASY TO MAKE BUDGET CUTS ON THE
TO SAY THAT AND- OR IN A TOUGH
FISCAL ENVIRONMENT NOW HAVING
SAID THAT I DO WANNA SECOND. A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE BY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IN REGARDS TO THE-
PRESSURE FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND IN PARTICULAR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE THE
SMALLER COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
NOT GETTING A DIRECT GRANT
UNDER THE CARES PROGRAM AS WELL
AS A SMALL RURAL HOSPITALS I
HAVE A- AND NUMBER EIGHT IN MY-
DISTRICT THAT MAY NOT. CONTINUE
TO EXIST THIS. BECAUSE AND IT
WOULD BE A SHAME FOR US TO LOSE
THOSE HOSPITALS- THEY'VE DONE
ALL THE RIGHT THINGS BY
PREPARING FOR THE SEARCH THAT
DIDN'T COME THANK GOODNESS WE
DID THE RIGHT THING. BUT BUT
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN DOING THEIR
LIFE BLOODS WORK WHICH IS THE
ELECTIVE SURGERY SO I JUST WANT
TO PUT THAT IS A PEN BECAUSE I
THINK WE'RE- WE'RE PROBABLY
GONNA HAVE TO COME BACK TO THAT
AT SOME SOME POINT AND HAVE A
DISCUSSION. BUT IN REGARDS TO
I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT- WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AND PART OF THE
REASON MAY BE THAT WE'RE JUST
NOT HEARING BACK FROM OUR
LOCAL- REP. IT IS ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT HAVE BEEN
GRANTED TO THEM AND ON MANY OF
US LOOK AROUND AND AS MUCH AS
WERE NOT OUT WE STILL WHEN WE
WHEN WE DO TRAVEL WE SEE THIS.
NUMBER OF HOMELESS PEOPLE ON
THE STREET AND SO. I'M
WONDERING IF YOU COULD TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. HOW YOU
BELIEVE PROPOSED BUDGET WILL
HELP THE STATE TO CONTINUE OUR
EFFORTS TO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS
AND IN PARTICULAR. HOW THE
BUDGET PLANS TO PRESERVE THE
GAINS MADE OVER THE PAST COUPLE
OF YEARS IN THE KEEP IN THE
HOUSE PROGRAM. HOW DOES IT WORK
TOGETHER. YES ON THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS- WHICH ARE AS THE
GOVERNOR AND I STAYED IN A
STATE OF THE STATE OURS IS THE
TOP PRIORITY FOR THE STATE. IN
WHICH YOU TALKED ABOUT IN THE
CITY'S DRESS THE FACT OF THE
KOBE NINETEEN GEN X. HASN'T
LESSEN THE URGENCY DEALING WITH
THAT AND IN FACT. THERE'S AN
EVEN STRONGER PUBLIC HEALTH
COMPONENT AS WELL AS ALL THE
OTHER MORAL ETHICAL AND
PRACTICAL REASONS I TO GET HE-
AN JURISDICTIONS. I ON
RESOURCES REDUCE. I'M GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO TWO OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE SPECIFIC THINGS THAT
WE'RE DOING FIRST KRISTIN
SHELTER AND WILL COVER THE
SPECIFIC FEDERAL ALLOCATIONS.
BECAUSE A LARGE. PART OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR SEATS WILL
BE DEVOTED SEC REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS AND PROVIDING
SUPPORT. LOW MY CAR CHRIS.
HELLO ALL. MY TO DETAIL ABOUT
HOW THIS IS BEING ADDRESSED IN
THE CONTEXT THE OVERALL. THIS
IS CHRISTIAN FRIEND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SORRY ABOUT THAT AND
HAD A LITTLE AND MUTING
CHALLENGE AND BE CORONAVIRUS
REALLY FUN AS WE NOTED HAS
TREMENDOUS FLEXIBILITY AND WE
HAVE. ALLOCATE CENTERS. ALMOST
POPULATION. WE HAVE AND SIX
HUNDRED MILLION IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TOWARDS HOMELESSNESS
AND IN IN THE BUDGET THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO FOLLOW
ON ACTIVITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
THE HUNDRED MILLION PROVIDED
PREVIOUSLY FOR PRICE FROM G.
AND THEN WE HAVE FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS- TO
CITIES. THAT WOULD BE FOR BOTH
PUBLIC SAFETY AND HOMELESSNESS
AND IN TERMS OF PRIORITIZE
PRAYERS HOUSING BILLS
EXPENDITURES RELATIVE TO THE
SPECIFIC POPULATION AND I
WOULD. TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE CHRIS. I TO TALK MORE
REGARDING TO PROGRAM AREAS
GOOD AFTERNOON CRISCO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT
THANK YOU FOR THE QUICK
QUESTION CENTER- WITH REGARDS
TO HOMELESSNESS- AS YOU MAY
KNOW AND AS NOTED EARLIER-
PROJECT ROOM KEY WORDS- WAS
BORN WITH- THE INITIAL HUNDRED
AND FIFTY- PROVIDED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR WHICH PROVIDED-
SHORT TERM HOUSING FOR A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO EITHER ACT
REYES OR- OR- EXITING I'M
SYMPTOMS ARE A- CO IN NINETEEN-
FOR THOSE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND SO. IN ORDER TO
AVOID THE CLIFF A FACT NO
LONGER BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT HOUSING FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS- THE BUDGET AS
SOON. PROPOSES TO USE. A
HUNDRED OR SO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
OF WHICH A HUNDRED FIFTY WOULD
BACK FILL. THE GENERAL FUND
PROVIDED IN THE CURRENT YEAR
WHAT THE REMAINING SIX HUNDRED
MILLION- TO BLEND IN RATE WITH
THE LOCALS DOLLARS THAT THEY'RE
RECEIVING. EITHER BY WAY OF.
THERE ALLOCATION OF THE SIERRA
FINDS. SOME OF THEIR OTHER
DIRECT ALLOCATIONS OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT THEY'VE
RECEIVED AND IN ADDITION TO THE
KEEP IT HAPPENS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE INDICATED. IN YOUR EARLIER
COMMENT BUT PULLING TOGETHER
AND BRINGING A LOT OF THOSE-
THOSE FUNDING FROM THE LOCALS
IN ADDITION TO THE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION TO- SHE'S ME TO PROVIDE
THE ACQUISITION FOR THESE
PROJECT ROOM G. SITES. AND SO
THE LONG TERM GOAL IS TO
ACQUIRE THESE FACILITY AT.
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
DEPARTMENT OF- GENERAL SERVICES
IN ADDITION TO THE LOCALS. AND
HAVE THOSE- LOCALS OPERATE
THOSE PROJECT ROOM KEY SITES-
INTO THE FUTURE MOVING FORWARD.
SO HAVING SAID THAT I
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE BUT
HAVING SAID THAT- THOSE FUNDS
NEED TO BE USED BY THE END OF
THE CALENDAR YEAR AND MY
CONCERN IS THE ABILITY TO
PURCHASE. ANYTHING WITHIN A SIX
MONTH PERIOD AND HAVE IT BE
DONE BECAUSE FEDERAL FUNDS NEED
TO BE USED WITHIN THAT PERIOD
OF TIME- SO IT IT PRESUMES THAT
WE'VE GOT SOME SITES IDENTIFIED
AT LEAST IDENTIFIED WHERE WE
CAN. START THE NEGOTIATIONS
OTHERWISE WE HAVE A WHOLE HECK
OF A LOT OF HOUSING MONEY THAT
HAS TO BE RETURNED TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AM I
CORRECT. THAT'S THAT'S CORRECT
FOR THE SIERRA FUNDS THEY DO
HAVE TO BE FULLY SPENT ARE
THOSE FUNDS HAVE TO BE SPENT BY
DECEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY BUT THERE IS SOME MONEY
THAT HAS A LITTLE BIT LONGER
FLEXIBILITY AND THAT'S THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING PROVIDED
DOES TO GRANT SOURCES- THROUGH
THE CARE EXACTLY THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING A LONGER DURATION OF
TIME AND THOSE ARE AVAILABLE
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY TWO. I'M
AT SO THERE WAS THOSE PARTS OF
PLANS OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND THEN IN
ADDITION AS YOU NOTED THAT HE'D
BEEN HAPPENS DO YOU HAVE. AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME- TO BE
USED BY LOCALS BUT THAT IS
GOING TO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE LOCALS IS
THERE THEIR ABILITY. TO PROVIDE
THE LONG TERM FUNDING TO
SUSTAIN THE SITES A LONG TERM.
I WILL ALSO NOTE HERE. HERE
COME IN ABOUT THE TIME
SENSITIVITY AS WELL- WHEN WE
WERE- ACQUIRING OR IDENTIFYING
THE SITES FOR PROJECT ROOM G.
OUR INTENTION THE STATE'S
INTENTION TO PURCHASE THESE
FACILITIES LONG TERM WAS ALWAYS
MADE. KNOWN MANY OF THEM HAVE
BUILT IN PROVISIONS IN THEIR
LEASE AGREEMENTS THAT THE STATE
WILL BE LOOKING TO. THE SIDE.
AND THE- PEACE AND SO DOES COME
STATIONS HAVE ALREADY BEGUN
THAT'S THE IN. OF THE ADMIN. IS
TO BUILD UPON. THE A LOT OF
THAT WORK ON THIS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ALREADY
BEGUN WITH THOSE- PROPERTY
OWNERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. TO
CONTINUE TO PROCEED WITH THE
ACQUISITION. OF THOSE SITES IF
THEY ARE- DECIDED TO BE THE
ONES THAT- THE STATE WOULD LIKE
TO- PURCHASE. GREAT OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT
THAT'S THAT'S REALLY HELPFUL.
SO MOVING ON TO A DIFFERENT
TOPIC AND THIS ONE IS THE- THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT- LET ME JUST SAY ON
ON THE HOUSING I'M VERY PLEASED
TO SEE THAT WE HAVE A NEW
DIRECTOR MAKES CD AS WELL AS
THE POSITION FOR BCS EIGHT FELT
BECAUSE- SEEMS TO ME YOU CAN
SAY IT'S A PRIORITY BUT YOU. IF
YOU DON'T HAVE ANYBODY. THERE
PERMANENTLY IT'S HARD TO SEE
HOW THEY'LL BE INNOVATIVE AND-
BE ABLE TO MOVE THE AGENDA
FORWARD. BUT MOVING TO THE DBA
THE- OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT- I
WAS A LITTLE SURPRISED TO SEE
THEIR RECOMMENDATION IN THE MAY
REVISE THAT- THE NEW EXPANDED
AUTHORITY. OVER CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTIONS WAS WAS
STILL IN THE BUDGET THIS IS
THIS GUY I THINK GOES BACK. TO
SOMETHING THAT SENATOR DRAWS A
WAS. WAS COMMENTING ON THIS IS-
FORTY FOUR POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLAR. EXPENDITURE TO EXPAND
THE- THE WORKLOAD AND THAT AND
THEM. THE HORIZON OF THINGS
THAT COULD BE. THE BATTLE FOR
WHICH OVER SAY COULD BE
GRANTED. AND WE STILL DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE EXPANSION
WILL LOOK LIKE AND I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD TELL ME
THE RATIONALE BEHIND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAINTENANCE OF
THIS REORGANIZATION PROPOSAL-
WHEN WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF
FIGHTING AN ACTIVE PANDEMIC AND
WE'VE GOT SOME REALLY
SIGNIFICANT- SOCIAL SERVICE
NEEDS AT THE SAME TIME. YES I
WILL MAKE TWO BRIEF POINTS ON
THAT AND THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUES HELLO WHEN WE
TO SOME OF THE SONGS. I THINK
THE FIRST POINT IS. THIS
PROPOSAL WAS INCLUDED IN THE
NAY OR NATION RECOGNIZING THAT
ESPECIALLY GIVEN APPLICATION AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL ON CONSUMER
PROTECTION IS AN URGENT NEED
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
ESPECIALLY IN THE MIDST OF
THAT. PUBLIC NINETEEN CAN DOWN
NAY- WHEN THERE IS EXPLOITATION
OF CONSUMERS CALLING ON THAT
THE STATE HAS THE APPROPRIATE
POWERS CRITICS CONSUMERS DOT ON
ITS OWN IS AN INADEQUATE
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION BECAUSE
WE'RE PROTECTION IS IMPORTANT
BUT AS YOU MENTIONED
HOMELESSNESS IS IMPORTANT.
HEALTH CARE AND- SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT SENATOR ALSO
MENTIONS ARE ALSO IMPORTANT TO
MORE CONCRETELY ON THIS ISSUE
THE SECOND POINT I WOULD MAKE
IS. THAT FUNDING THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO IT ACTUALLY COMING
OUT ITS SELF. IT'S NOT. TIME
MINOR SYSTEM WHEN IT'S- ON IT
CAN YEARS THIS IS WHY. BUT I
WILL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE CLAIMS TALK ABOUT A
LITTLE MORE. REPEAT THE NAME
AGAIN OR THE PERSON ON THE
PHONE. YES SO IT'S CLICK CALLUM
C. L. I. N. C. A. HE'S ON THE
PHONE I'M SORRY. CLINT THANK
YOU YES. HELLO. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD OKAY
COMPOUND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO- THINK BUT ABOVE EIGHT LAID
OUT- THE REASONS FOR WHY NOW ON
THIS PROPOSAL- BEING THAT THE
NEEDS ARE HIGHER IN THE-
ATTORNEY AND FINANCIAL
RECESSION AND THAT IT IS
SPECIAL FUNDS- THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WE HAVE IT HAD BEEN
AVAILABLE SINCE JANUARY AND I
KNOW THAT NAM XO DOWN OUR
ABILITY TO HAVE. SOME CA. LAST
AMONG OR SO BUT ANY REVISION OF
INCLUDED LANGUAGE THAT ALLOW
MAKES A BUDGET- TIED ON- TO
LEGISLATION TO BE PASSED LATER
IN THE SPRING IF YOU ALLOW FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND WE JUST
OTHERS DID UPDATED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ON FRIDAY TAKING IT
BACK FROM EVERYONE- THAT WE
THINK REALLY DOESN'T. MOVE AWAY
FROM THE CORE PRINCIPLE OF OUR
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL BUT REALLY
CLARIFY. WITH THE LANGUAGE.
SOME OF THE CONFUSION ALL WHERE.
IF THE OTHER TO LIGHT EITHER
ACT WITHIN THE SCOPE OF THEIR
LICENSE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
IMPACTED BY THIS PROPOSAL-
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT WAS
CLEAR THAT WE'RE NOT
ESTABLISHING YOU LICENSES-
FINANCIAL SERVICE OF LICENSES
WITH THE PROGRAM. IF YOU'RE ON
LIFE AND TING YOUR FINANCIAL
RISK PRODUCT PROVIDERS NEW.
REGISTRANTS BUT THAT IT MIGHT
CATEGORY I'M AND JUST WORKING
SOME OF THOSE WELL TO MAKE SURE
EVERYTHING'S CLEAR AND THAT
UNFAIR AND ABUSE OF THE
DECEPTIVE PRACTICES- AUTHORITY
WOULD APPLY TO YOU REGISTERED.
AND THE WIFE AND SO I THERE'S
SOME OF AND USE CASH AND WE- OF
COURSE OUR CALLS ON. AND WE CAN.
HOPEFULLY WORK THROUGH THE WITH
THE LEAD. OVER THE COMING. ONE
FOLLOW UP ON THAT- DIRECTOR OF
THIS ONE OFTEN IS. BOB THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE SPECIAL FUNDS FOR
WHICH THE MONEY CAN ONLY BE
USED FOR THAT PURPOSE UNLESS IT
CAN BE BORROWED- AND PAID BACK
I'M ASSUMING. YES AND SO I DID
WANT TO CHECK- WITH SOME OF OUR
STAFF ON THIS SPECIFIC
RESTRICTIONS ON THE SPECIAL
FUNDS BUT IT IS DIRECTED FOR A
PARTICULAR PURPOSE THAT'S
CORRECT. OKAY AND THEN MOVE ON
TO- UP THAT MY LAST QUESTION IT
IN HAS TO DO WITH THE E.
CIGARETTE TAX. AND I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD. YOU
COULD TELL US WHAT THE
ESTIMATED REVENUE FROM THAT
PROPOSED E. E. CIGARETTE TAX.
IS AND IF. THE ESTIMATE CHANGES
GIVEN THE NEW FEDERAL FDA BAN
ON CERTAIN FLAVORS- AND WHETHER
THAT WAS PARTY YOUR
CALCULATION- AND THEN AND THEN
AS PART OF THAT DISCUSSION TALK
ABOUT WHY YOU BELIEVE IT SHOULD
BE. IT SHOULD GO INTO A NEW
SPECIAL FIND IS SUPPOSED TO BE
BEING DEPOSITED IN THE GENERAL
FUND. YES ON THE E. CIGARETTE
TAX- I HAVE TO COLLEAGUES ON
THE LINE WHO CAN SPEAK TO BOTH
OF THOSE QUESTIONS- FIRST DAYS
RYAN MILLER- FROM HHS. UNIT AND
FINANCES AND SECOND ON THEIR
READING YOU ACT QUESTION THAT
YOU DISCUSSED WE ALSO HAVE JAKE
CHAMBER WHEN ON THE SIGN WHICH
READ IT OVER TO BOTH. WE'RE
GOING TO A OF BRIAN MILLER
FIRST I BELIEVE IS ON A VIDEO
CONFERENCE. HI THIS IS RYAN
MILLER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I HEARD YOUR SECOND
QUESTION SENATOR- CONCERNING
THE GENERAL FUND COULD YOU
PLEASE REPEAT YOUR FIRST
QUESTION. YES THE FIRST
QUESTION HAD TO DO WITH THE-
THE REVENUE PROJECTIONS FOR THE
PROPOSED CIGARETTE TAX AND
WHETHER THE ESTIMATE THAT YOU
YOU HAVE CHANGES GIVEN THE NEW
FEDERAL FTA BAN ON ON FLAVORS.
ON CERTAIN FLAVORS AND WE ALSO
HAVE A SENATE BILL THAT AT THAT
HAS A SIMILAR. KIND OF
LIMITATION AND I WONDER IF THE
ESTIMATE CHANGES GIVEN THAT.
THAT INFORMATION. OKAY SO YEAH
I WOULD PROBABLY- GOOD FOR OF
THOSE QUESTIONS TO J.
CHAMBERLAIN I THINK I WOULD
SAY- CONCERNING THE USE OF THE
PHONES- THE GOVERNOR AND I HAD
TO KEEP PRIORITIES AND THEY
CONTINUE RE BUDGET- TO- USE THE
FUNDING TO BOTH OF MINISTER
THAT TAX AND GET SOME OF THE
FUNDING THE CHP- AND THEN IN
THE MAYOR VISION OF COURSE ARE
PROPOSING TO USE ME ON
ALLOCATED AMOUNTS TO OFFSET
GENERAL COSTS IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM. AND SO DEPENDING ON
YOUR CHAMBER WAS RESPONSE I TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE REVENUES
WOULD BE LOWER I THINK THAT
THAT WOULD PROBABLY READ THE
AMOUNT OF SET. CAL I WOULD KICK
IT TO JAY. FOR TEETH ABOUT HER
MISTER. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
JERRY CHAMBERLAIN- DEPARTMENT
FIND SO THE MATTER REVENUE
WE'VE ESTIMATED. DR FROM THIS
THE NEW TAX WOULD BE A THIRTY
THREE MILLION IN. TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR-
AND WHETHER THAT WOULD BE- FOR
THAT WOULD BE RE SHOULD BE
REDUCED BY THE FEDERAL ACTIONS
ON- FLAVORED CIGARETTES ALL I
HAVE TO BACK TO ON THE- RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE
THAT SHE THAT. COLLEAGUES THAT
NEXT UP WE HAVE CENTER MORE
LOCKS INTO MORE LOCK WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY SENATORS STERN
SKINNER AND THEN LABOR ARE
THERE OTHER MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK. THEN IT SENATOR DOLLY I
SEE YOU WHICH- SO THERE'S OKAY
SENATOR MORE LAW. QUESTION THEN
YOU GO IN QUESTIONS FOR MS
VESSEL OF THE THAT THE COULD
ANSWER TWO A FEW THE FIRST ONE
IS- MISTER RESPONDED BEEN I ASK
THIS QUESTION LAST YEAR IT'S
MAY EIGHTEENTH WHERE IS THE
STATE'S COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL
FINANCIAL REPORT FOR JUNE
THIRTIETH. THIS IS. TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND SO ON THAT
ACCOUNT FOR I WOULD HAVE TO
CHECK WITH OUR OFFICE AND ALSO
WHAT THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE WILL MAKE A NOTE TO
CHECK IN ON THAT WOULD BE GREAT
WERE ONE OF THREE STATES THAT
STILL HAVEN'T FINISHED THEIR
KAFIRS NUMBER TWO YOU SAID AT
THE BEGINNING ONCE IN A
CENTURY- WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IS
THAT JUST A DESCRIPTOR OR ARE
YOU ANTICIPATING A SHORT. CLIP
IN THE ECONOMY OR- JUST CURIOUS
IN A COUPLE WORDS WHAT THAT
MEANT SURE JUST TO KEEP IT
BRIEF FIVE DEFINITELY NOT
TREATING THIS AS A BLACK AND I
THINK WHAT'S AROUND YOU
PROJECTIONS NOT ONLY THE FIFTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR GAP FOR
THIS EVENING BUDGET BANKS THE
STRUCTURAL ABSENT WE NEED. IN
THE COMING YEARS THIS IS AN
ECONOMIC CRISIS I THINK WHEN I
REFER TO ONCE IN A CENTURY TO
IN TWO WAYS ANY NUMBER ONE. THE
FACT THAT THIS IS. BY I KNOW
WHAT IT'S PEOPLE MAY THE
ANALOGY. NINETEEN EIGHTEEN IN
THE EARLY PART OF THE TWENTY
CENTURY THAT WAS EXACTLY THE
SAME AGO AND THE SECOND THING I
THINK IS DOUBLE SEE HOW THE
ROAD TO RECOVERY IS BUT THESE
LEVELS OF UNEMPLOYMENT HAVE NOT
BEEN SEEN WELL OVER HALF A
CENTURY YOU HAVE TO GO BACK TO
THE TIME OF THE GREAT QUESTION
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE GREAT
RECESSION TEN YEARS AGO WITH
JUST. AS MANY OF YOU MENTIONED
YOU WERE. YOUR RESEARCH OTHER
ELECTED OFFICIAL. THAT WAS A-
ECONOMIC. AND EVEN. WE SAW.
LEVELS HE HAD A LITTLE BIT OVER.
PERCENT IN THIS FIRST.
WORSENING UNEMPLOYMENT LEVELS
THAT WILL EXCEED AYE AYE
SEVERAL. SO WE HAVE BEEN
WATCHING THE ECONOMY OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS IMPROVE AND SO
WE'VE BEEN ABLE THROUGH OUR
PROP NINETY EIGHT TO GIVE MORE
MONEY TO OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THERE CAL
STIRS CONTRIBUTIONS HAVE BEEN
RISING SO THEY REALLY. AT THE
END OF THE DAY THEIR DELTA
RATHER. THIS ONE OF THE BIGGEST.
ECONOMIC RECESSIONS DEPRESSIONS
IN IN A CENTURY IS IN THIS TIME
TO DO SOME. IMPROVEMENTS TO
SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS AT THE STATE
LIKE THE PENSION PLANS. COULD
WE DO A BIKE A DIFF ASSURED
RISK PLAN AT THE STATE OF
WISCONSIN. HAS IMPLEMENTED AND
THEY ALWAYS SHOW UP AS BEING A
100% FUNDED AT LEAST
HISTORICALLY FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS WHEN THE PEW REPORT COMES
OUT EVERY YEAR IS THIS AN
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO SAY HEY.
LET'S AVOID FURTHER PROBLEMS
BECAUSE A YEAR OR TWO OR THREE
OR FOUR FROM NOW WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A MUCH LARGER PENSION PLAN
CONTRIBUTIONS HOW DO WE- WHEN
WE ARE DOING. NOW WHAT KIND OF
COVERAGE IN IN. TWENTY TWELVE.
SAID THE BUDGET AND THE NEW
REVISION AT AND DID NOT INCLUDE
ANY OF THIS SPECIFIC TYPES OF
CHANGES. THAT YOU MENTION. THAT
BEING SAID WE ARE AWARE OF THE-
PRESSURES THAT. UNDER AND NOT
JUST THE STATE BUT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE WHEN IT COMES TO
SOME OF THESE RISING COSTS AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY.
FOR SCHOOLS WE NOT ONLY
ALLOCATED FOR BILLION DOLLARS
IN FEDERAL FUNDING FOR K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS FOR THE UPCOMING
YEAR. ALSO INCLUDED AND
REALLOCATING SUPPLEMENTARY
MONEY THAT THE GOVERNOR.
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
HAS TAKEN OUT OF THE SURPLUS
LAST YEAR. HE'S THAT BY. SOME
OF THE SCHOOLS IN CONTRIBUTION.
IN THE NEXT YEAR AND THE YEAR
AFTER THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THESE COSTS
THAT HIGH SCHOOLS WILL BE
DEALING WITH FOR SOME TIME TO
COME AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES.
CAN WE- NEGOTIATE AND MODIFY
RETIREE MEDICAL PLANS. SO I
THINK ALL I CAN SAY RIGHT NOW
IS THAT THOSE CONSIDERATIONS
ARE NOT DIRECTLY PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S. RACE HIGH SPEED
RAIL. SO WHEN IT COMES TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL AT THE GOVERNOR I
HAD SENT OUT HIS PLANS
RECOGNIZING SOME THE ISSUES
WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL AT THE
BEGINNING OF HIS ADMINISTRATION
LAST YEAR. THAT FUNDING FOR
HIGH SPEED RAIL COMES FROM A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT SORTS CITY
COUNCIL FEDERAL FUNDS IT COMES
FROM BONDS THAT WERE APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS YEARS AGO AND IT
COMES FROM CONTINUOUS
PREPARATION FROM THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM AND WHEN IT COMES
TO THAT LAST EL NAY. AS THE
DISCUSSION WITH GENERAL POLICY.
THE CAP. AND TRADE PROGRAM I
READ THE NEWS. ACTED OR LOOKS
LIKE THEY WILL. FALL IN THE
COMING YEAR SO ALL OF THE- THAT
ARE. BY A FOR. WE'LL SEE REDUCE
RECORD. AND THEN THE CAP AND
TRADE MONEY COULD AND SO OF
GOING TO HIGH SPEED RAIL TO GO
HARDING ASSETS. A SO THAT WE
CAN REDUCE WILDFIRES A PATCH OF
TO A COMMENT- WHAT ABOUT- IMHO
USE WORK WE'RE SHOWING SIX
HUNDRED FOUR MILLION- IN MORE
STATE EMPLOYEE PAY AND BENEFIT
RAISES. WILL THOSE BE
RENEGOTIATED OR OR MAYBE PUT ON
HOLD. SO ONLY ONE COMMENTS HERE
AND MY COLLEAGUE MARY HALTER
MANIA IS ON THE LINE AS WELL.
THE BUDGET REFLECTS OUR-
EMPLOYEES SAVINGS SIDES I
BELIEVE TEN PERCENT. OF
EMPLOYEES SAVINGS ACROSS OUR
STATE EMPLOYEES ON AND
RESPECTING THE LOS GATOS AFTER
BARGAINING TABLE TO ACHIEVE
THOSE SAVINGS WELL TURN IT OVER
TO AND IT ALSO MEANS AND THAT'S
THAT'S OKAY THAT. THAT'S FINE I
WANT TO KEEP THIS REAL BRIEF
ABOUT THE- MINIMUM WAGE WE'RE
DOING THAT EVERY YEAR. AS AN
INCREASE IN THAT AFFECTS AYE
HSS WHO WE WILL BE PUT THAT.
MAYBE A TEMPORARY HOLDER. OUGHT
TO BE DOING WITH THE MINIMUM
WAGE. RIGHT NOW THE BUDGET
WRESTLING A SCHEDULE INCREASE
IN THE MINIMUM WAGE. YEAR SO OF
THE PRO. MY COMMISSION I HSS
ARE CONSTANT AREAS THAT ARE
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT. BUT THAT
DALY REVISION WHAT'S CLASSES
SCHEDULED INCREASE. RATES OF
MATT THE FISCAL CRISIS
MANAGEMENT AND ASSISTANCE TEAM-
YOU HISTORICALLY FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE HAVING TROUBLE
WOULD TO LOAN MONEY. BUT WE'VE
ALREADY MENTIONED LAUSD- THEY
HAVE AN UNRESTRICTED NET
DEFICIT OF ALMOST TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS IF THE BARD
HALF OF THAT WE'RE WITH. THE
STATE BE ABLE TO LOAN BILLION
DOLLARS. TO LA UNIFIED. I TO
CHECK BACK ON SPECIFIC ISSUE TO
FOLLOW WITH YOU. WORK WORK. AT
BUDGETING TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A BI FIVE
ENFORCEMENT I'M WONDERING
WHAT'S THE GOAL THERE ARE WE
TRYING TO PENALIZE TAX
PREPARERS OR- OR OR REPAIR IS
THAT A REVENUE SOURCE AND THAT
SEEMS ANTI BUSINESS HOW DOES.
HOW DOES GO BIZ FEEL ABOUT THIS
BUDGET ALLOCATION. SO I HAVEN'T
CHECKED WITH DOLBY SPECIFICALLY
I THINK ACTION ARE ONLY- THAT
GOVERNOR YOUR CHECKED IN WITH
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION. I SEE PUT
TOGETHER THE BUDGET AND WE HERE
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
COURTING HIM SPECIFICALLY FOR
THAT ALLOCATION FOR EIGHTY FIVE
ENFORCEMENT. THAT WAS A BILL
THAT WAS ENACTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR AND
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR I CITIES
ARE RESOURCES TO ENFORCE MISS
VAUGHN IS ALREADY. AND THEN
LAST QUESTION ONE IN PEOPLE AND
CAL SHOULD PLAY OUT OR ON A
COLLECTING. BENEFITS THAT'S IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR DO WE KNOW
HOW MANY ARE UNEMPLOYED IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR AND WHAT IT WHAT
TO ME DISSIPATE. I HAVE NOT
SEEN DIRECT WAY OFF DATA. OR
UNEMPLOYMENT DATA WHEN IT COMES
TO THAT PUBLIC SECTOR CERTAINLY
THE REPORTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
SEEING ACROSS THE NATION. I
CHAU ALREADY THAT DIFFERENT.
THINGS IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY ARE BEGINNING TO
KAT I THINK AS WE SINCE HEARING
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE LOOKING. TO
CONGRESS TO SEE WHAT KIND OF A-
GROUP BECAUSE- IT CALMLY.
CONFER WITH ADDITIONAL AID I
THINK YOU'LL LIKELY SEE
DIFFERENT MY OFFICE- ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE. BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
SPECIFIC DATA AND WHAT THAT
LEVEL WAYS I DON'T. MR BUT EVAN
I OF YOUR TO RESPONSES YOUR
PROFESSIONALISM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND THANK YOU SIR SENATOR STERN
EURO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IS
WORKING. IT CERTAINLY IS OKAY-
WELL THANK YOU- MR THIS ONE
DOWN AND TWO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR WRESTLING WITH-
PRETTY IMPOSSIBLE CIRCUMSTANCE
HERE I APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY
THUS FAR. MY QUESTION HAD TO DO
WITH. OPERATIONS FOR CENTRAL
DISASTERS WE'RE GONNA BE
FACING- THIS FALL INTO THE
WINTER I KNOW WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THE WILD FIRES YOU BUT-
OUR CLIMATE COSTS WE KNOW WERE
ARE BIGGER THAN JUST WILD FIRE
WERE WE'RE FACING A MEGA
DROUGHT THIS YEAR- AND A NUMBER
OF OTHER- CONCERNING IT SHOES
THAT. I'M WORRIED ABOUT OUR
ABILITY TO SORT OF FIGHT CO TO
COVER OUR ECONOMY- AND- BE ABLE
TO RESPOND TO THESE DISASTERS
AT THE SAME TIME SO I'M JUST
CURIOUS TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS
FIRST ON SORT OF RESPONSE
CAPABILITIES AND THEN.
COROLLARY QUESTION ON OUR
ABILITY TO PREVENT KIND OF
DISASTERS- BUT ON THE RESPONSE
I. AT I THINK. SO ESTIMATE OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS WE'VE HAD I
DON'T KNOW WHERE FIVE JUST SIX
BILLION DOLLAR COSTS EMERGE
WHEN WE HAVE MASSIVE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES SO HOW DO WE
GET THROUGH- THAT KIND OF
SCENARIO THIS YEAR UNDER THE
CURRENT BUDGET. YES SO WHEN IT
COMES TO THAT ISSUE AND I THINK
IT'S EXACTLY YOU MENTIONED I
THINK WHAT WOULD REALLY BE A
DIFFICULT SCENARIO AS DIFFICULT
AS A STEREO IS NOT WORKING
RIGHT NOW. IS IF THIS CRISIS WE
WERE WE ARE IN WERE COMPOUNDED
BY SOME OTHER TYPE OF DISASTER
WHETHER IT'S ANOTHER WILDFIRE
WHETHER IT'S AN EARTHQUAKE OR
ANY OTHER. SO I KNOW WE WERE
TALKING BEFORE ABOUT HOW MOST
OF THE- CREATE A NEW
INVESTMENTS OF THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED IN JANUARY. I HAVEN'T
REALLY WHAT'S WRONG I THINK
THIS IS ONE OF THESE AREAS
WHERE WHEN IT COMES TO. FIRE
FIRE FIREFIGHTERS STAFFING WHEN
IT COMES TO RESOURCES FOR CAL-
YES RESPOND TO THE RANGE OF
DISASTERS AND WHEN IT COMES TO.
THE ACT UNITY TOWER. THIS IS
THE DEAL WITH SOME OF THE SHOTS
THAT WERE SO DESTRUCTIVE. LAST
YEAR IN MAKING SURE THAT THE
STATE AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
I'M RESOURCES THERE WE ARE
CONTINUING TO MAKE INVESTMENTS
IN THESE AREAS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE WELL EQUIPPED FOR
WHATEVER. I DO APPRECIATE THAT
I KNOW. I MEAN I MISSED IT
YOU'RE ALSO RELYING ON SOME
KIND OF. CONTINGENCY GIVEN THAT
EVEN FROM WHAT YOU'VE BUDGET
AND BEEN VERY PROACTIVE ABOUT-
AUGMENTING DESPITE ALL THE
OTHER CUTS. THE COST WOULD
STILL- ARE. FAR EXCEEDED. SO
WHAT YOU NEED AND BUDGET FOR
RIGHT IN TERMS OF YES AND CAL
FIRE FUNDS IS THAT YOU'RE
ANTICIPATING SOME SORT OF
FEDERAL. AID TO COMMENT AS WELL
IF WE HAD A STATE MASSIVE
EARTHQUAKE OR WILD FIRE OR-
FLOOD. YES GENERALLY WHEN IT
COMES THESE COSTS AND NOW- TURN
OVER BRIEFLY TO MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE RESOURCES AND CAPITAL
OUTLAY ROOM WHICH RECENT
CALVERT ANOTHER COLLEAGUES.
CALIFORNIA THE STATE NEEDS TO
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO MOUNT THE
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE AND THEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HELPS WHAT
HAPPENED NEXT YEAR MINUS SO
SEATED AGENCIES AT. ALL LEVELS.
IT WILL ROLL AND- TO SEE FOR A
LOT OF THESE EXPLAINS EVEN WHEN
WE ALSO REALLY RECEIVE
REIMBURSEMENT OF THE STATE
AUSTIN HOUSE FRONT MOST OR EVEN
ALL OF THEM AND REIMBURSEMENT
CAN TAKE MONTHS IF NOT YEARS SO
THAT BECOMES MORE CASH FLOW
MANAGEMENT PROBLEM AND WE
CERTAINLY HAVE THE CAPABILITY
TO DO THAT RIGHT NOW. BUT IT'S
HARD TO ESTIMATE IN ADVANCE
JUST HOW MUCH THE COST WILL BE
BECAUSE THAT DEPENDS BOTH ON
THE SCALE OF THE DISASTER WHAT
TIME TODAY'S AS WELL AS HOW
COOPERATE AT OUR PARTNERS. WILL
BE LET ME TURN IT OVER VERY
BRIEFLY ASK MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE RESOURCE ROOM MY CHAD. ANY
ADDITIONAL DETAIL. THANKS AS
CURRENCY BUT WORTH FINDING YET
SO THANK NORMAL QUITE OTHER
YEAR. BUDGET WE AN EMERGENCY
FUND APPROPRIATION THAT HELPS
US TO ADDRESS WHILE FIRED-
COSTS THAT GO BEYOND THE KIND
REGULAR BASED BUDGET AMOUNTS IN
ADDITION AS A MY COLLEAGUE
REFERENCED WHATEVER WE HAVE
MAJOR DISASTERS IF THE
PRESIDENT DECLARES A
PRESIDENTIAL DISASTER. AND HE
WAS PUBLIC ASSISTANCE FUNDING
BECOMES AVAILABLE- FIRST TAPPED
INTO THEIR SO WHAT IT REALLY
DOES GET DOWN TO THE MAGNITUDE
OF THE DISASTER. HAVE THEY
WORKS FINE CORPORATE AS WELL-
AS ARE JUST RESPONSE ROUTES JOB
RATIONS ACCOUNT. MECHANISM THAT
WE USED TO ADDRESS THOSE
DISASTERS. AND IF I COULD
MANAGER JUST MIGHT. MY FOLLOW
TO ON THE PREVENTION SIDE- I
I'VE SEEN REFERENCE IN SOME OF
THE DOCUMENTS THAT- LIKE
JUSTIFYING FOR INSTANCE THAT
CORRECTED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR CUT- TO THE HOME
HARDENING FUNDS- DAD'S-
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS. TO
IMPROVE THE RESILIENCE OF
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WILL BE
CONSIDERED AS PART OF AN
OVERALL INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN I
THINK IT WAS ALSO MENTIONED IN
THE IN THE CUTS TO. OF FUNDING
FOR THIS IS DANIEL GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT AS DEALING WITH.
ALL THE FARMERS WERE PROBABLY.
GOING TO BE ON THE BRINK- WITH
THIS DROUGHT- SO CAN CAN YOU
JUST LAY OUT WHERE WHERE DOES
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN LIVE
IN AND WHAT WEIGHT WHAT MIGHT
WE SEE IS THAT POTENTIAL
MECHANISMS FOR. IF ACTUATING
SAID THE PLAN AND THEN THE
COMING WEEKS. YES I THINK WHEN
IT COMES TO THOSE ISSUES AND
THE MOST DIRECT ANSWER IS THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT THE GOVERNOR
AND THE ADMINISTRATION YOU WANT
TO DO AND ARE THINKING ABOUT
FINDING WAYS TO DO. THAT HAVE
ENGINE WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU
SETTLED ON THE PAST MECHANISM
TO DO THAT YEAH WE KNOW. AS
ALWAYS KNOW WHAT THE BUDGET IS
UNDER A LOT OF PRESSURE ON ME
TO PROPOSE A BALANCED BUDGET.
AS YOU MENTIONED SENATOR
STIRRING THAT THESE LONGER TERM
PRIORITIES. REBUILDING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AN ADAPTATION ARE
ALSO VERY SIGNIFICANT FOR THE
STATE'S FUTURE AND SO. THE
REASON THAT SOME OF THOSE WERE
NOT INCLUDED IN THE NEIGHBOR
ASIAN IS BECAUSE WE DIDN'T SEE
A WAY SELECT TOP AND GIVEN
CURRENT BUDGET REALITIES. BUT
THE GOVERNOR HAS ALSO MENTIONS
THAT CONNECTS YOU TO LOOK AT
WAYS- WHETHER LOOKING AT.
ADDITIONAL USES THE FEDERAL
FUNDING IF MORE IS AVAILABLE
AND EDUCATIONAL REVENUE DOWN
THE LINE I DON'T KNOW. ON
SUNDAY FOR SOME OF THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS ALL OF
THESE ARE HARD AS- TOPICS
GOVERNOR AT THEIR MANY MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE. ARE
THINKING ABOUT. RIGHT NOW WE
DON'T HAVE. PROPOSAL IN THESE
AREAS BUT WE WANT TO FIND A WAY
TO MAKE. ON BECAUSE- HERE EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE NOT RIGHT AND OF
US IN TERMS OF THE MEDIA
ALLEN'S. TRYING TO GET TO
RECALL. THEY'RE ON VERY
SINISTER. SELECT AND LONG TERM
FUTURE. THANKS FOR THAT WE LOOK
FOR WORKING THAT RIGHT IN THANK
YOU MADAM BUT YEAR FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR WILL TO SEND A SKIN.
THANK YOU MADAM BUT CHAIR AND A
TIME ELADIO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED SO FAR IN
PRESENTING US THE INFORMATION-
I WILL TRY TO GO TO THESE VERY
QUICKLY SO THE MY FIRST SET OF
QUESTIONS ARE REGARDING-
FURIOUS AT THE- WHAT I'LL CALL
INTENT ON THE PROGRAM SO THE
GOVERNOR'S ISSUED MANY GOOD
EXECUTIVE ORDERS TO HELP THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF THIS
PANDEMIC. FOR EXAMPLE LIFTING
THE TWO WEEK WAIT ON
UNEMPLOYMENT- AND BY WONDERED
WHAT THINGS WITH IN THIS BUDGET.
OUR OUR COMPARABLE TO ASSIST
FOLKS IN HAT REGARD IN ALL
EXPLAIN IN A SECOND SO FOR
EXAMPLE. THE BUDGET SHOWS AS
DOCTOR PAN POINTED OUT A
INCREASE IN MEDI CAL CASELOAD
AND THAT'S OBVIOUSLY DUE TO A
DROP IN PEOPLES- INCOMES. BUT
DOES THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDE
ANY- REMOVAL OF OBSTACLES FOR
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO ENROLL IN
MEDICARE QUICKLY SEVEN OTHER
WORDS AS SOON MEAN FOR EXAMPLE
IF THEY ARE ON AN UNEMPLOYMENT
THAT THEY ARE THEN ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDI CAL. THAT IS ONE MAYBE I
SHOULD LIST A COUPLE OF THESE
AND THEY CAN ANSWER IT ONCE THE
SECOND ONE IS ON SIMILARLY WE'D-
SOME OF THE I THINK THE DELAYS
ON FOR EXAMPLE- IN RULING IN
CALIFORNIA'S. DOES THE- BUDGET.
LOOK AT LIFTING EVEN IF
TEMPORARILY OBSTACLES THAT
LIMIT CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENTS
ABILITY TO ENROLL IN PROGRAMS
LIKE WAKE AND CALIBRATION
SIMILAR WAY THAT I DESCRIBED AS
MEDI CAL. CALLED OLD HEAR AN
ANSWER ON THAT BEFORE AS THE
NEXT QUESTION. SENATOR SCARE
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT
EVEN WHEN WE PRESERVE
ELIGIBILITY I DON'T REALLY
SOUNDS PEOPLE IF WE'RE NOT
CREATING NEW HOOPS FOR PEOPLE
TO SHOP FOR MAKING SURE. SIR IS.
NOT TO BRING TO NEW HOOPS ARE
REFERRED EXISTING HOOPS BUT GO
AHEAD YES YES AND SO WHEN IT
COMES TO THAT I'M GONNA TURN
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE BRIAN
MILLER. THIS WAS JUST A AND DAY
TO TALK ABOUT. HOW WE ARE
WORKING TO REMOVE. WHEN YOU
SENATOR SO- THAT CONCERNING AN
ALIEN THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM I
CAN'T SAY THAT THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS IN THE
REVISION BUT THE BUDGET DOES
SUPPORT AND FIND- MANY OF THE
WAIVER ACTIVITIES THAT WERE
SOUGHT IN THE SPRING TO TRY TO-
YOU KNOW- ENHANCE PEOPLE'S
ABILITY TO GET ON THE PROGRAM
AND SO MY COLLEAGUE JACOB CAN
GET INTO MORE DETAIL ABOUT.
CLOSE JUGGLING GOVERNMENT
FINANCES I MEAN SPECIFIC YOUR
QUESTION WE ARE SENDING OUR AND
OVER YOU TERMINATION SO MEDICAL
PROGRAM SO THAT. ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS OF REGULAR MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES HAS TO BE
RECESSED FOR ENROLLMENT INTO
THE PROGRAM. DURING THE STATE
OF EMERGENCY WE ARE CURRENTLY
SPENDING THAT OPERATION
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING- UNINSURED
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS FOR. POTENTIALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDI CAL SO UNDER
OUR- THE BILL IS THAT WE
REQUEST. INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
UNINSURED WOULD BE ABLE TO
ENROLL IN MEDICARE LITERACY
COATED TESTING INCOME WOULD
REALLY TREAT. FROM THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS- HAD
SOME ADDITIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS
I HOPE THAT THEY CAN BE
DISCUSSED IN SUBCOMMITTEE. THE
S. SIMILARLY I THINK THERE ARE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING
CAL FRESH WHERE CAN PROGRAMS
LIKE THAT ADDITIONALLY ON THE
ECONOMIC FRONT. THE BUDGET
INCLUDES- I BELIEVE SO AN
INCREASE IN THE LOAN GUARANTEE
FORCE OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
WHICH OBVIOUSLY WILL GET
DEBATED AND SAD BUT I WONDERED
IF- IN A SIMILAR VEIN WHETHER
THE BUDGET FOR- WAS CONSIDERING
SUCH THINGS AS- A- ACROSS THE
BOARD EXTENSION. ON AN EXISTING
BUILDING PERMITS AND ZONING
ENTITLEMENTS GIVEN THAT MUCH
ACTIVITY HAD TO SEIZE THAT-
RATHER THAN IN THE SAME WAY
THAT RATHER YOU SHOULD YOU
RATHER THAN YOU HAVING TO
REAPPLY FOR MEDI CAL WHY WOULD
WE HAVE EXISTING PER. HAVE TO
BE. CERTAINLY WHICH WERE ISSUED
ON A LOCAL GOVERNMENT BASIS BUT
STILL THE- TIME STATE. HAS
EXTENDED OTHER DEADLINES AND
SUCH AND- I THINK IT IS WORTH
CONSIDERING THOSE ADDITIONALLY
THE STATE MIGHT CONSIDER A
EXTENSION ON ALL STATE ISSUED
CANNABIS LICENSES GIVEN THAT. A
SUCH BUSINESSES AREN'T ELIGIBLE
OTHER THAN FOR POTENTIALLY SOME
STATE RELIEF THEY'RE NOT
ELIGIBLE TO FOR ANY OF THE
FEDERAL RELIEF THAT WAS- A
PROVIDED IN ANY OF THE FEDERAL
ACTS SO FAR. AND IF THERE'S IF
THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN
CONTEMPLATED I HOPE THAT THAT
CAN BE DISCUSSED IN THE
APPROPRIATE BUDGET SAT AND
CONTEMPLATED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. THEN THE LA-
THIS QUESTION IS DAILY- UNLESS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WANTS TO
COMMENT ON EITHER OF THOSE. THE
TICKET SO ON ELIO YOU MENTIONED
IN YOUR PRESENTATION THAT-
THERE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
RECOMMENDS FOR EXAMPLE A LIMIT
ON THE TAKING THE TAX CREDIT
EXPENDITURES TWO FIVE MILLION
IT. FOR ANY ENTITY YOU
MENTIONED THAT THERE MAY BE
ADDITIONAL. ACTIONS LIKE THAT
THAT MAY PROVIDE SOME. GENERAL
FUND OR OTHER AGAIN- IT'S MORE
A DELAY IN- IN AN EXPENDITURE
VERSUS THE NEW REVENUE BUT- YOU
YOU REFERENCED IT BUT SHE
DIDN'T STATE ANY SPECIFICS. YES
SENATOR SKINNER I
APOLOGETICALLY BROKE UP JUST A
LITTLE BIT COULD IS IT POSSIBLE
FOR YOU TO RESTATE THAT THE
AVERAGE THE IN YOUR
PRESENTATION YOU REFERENCED.
SUPPORT SORRY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TIED. IN WHICH
YOUR CALL WAIVER FOR LIMITATION
ON ENTITIES TAKING CERTAIN TAX
CREDIT EXPENDITURES WITHIN
THIS- THIS UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR
AND YOU MENTIONED THAT THERE
MAY BE ADDITIONAL ONES THAT WE
SHOULD CONSIDER. BUT IN
SPECIFIED. YES SO THE TAX-
PROPOSALS FOR AUGMENTING THE
REVENUE PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND THE NAME REVISION
INCLUDE SUSPENDING NET
OPERATING LOSSES THE ABILITY OF
MEDIUM AND LARGE SIZED
BUSINESSES TO UTILIZE THIS THIS
IS A CASE WHERE THEIR
DEDUCTIONS OR NET INCOME IS IN
A NEGATIVE POSITION RESULTING
IN A NET OPERATING LOSS AND
THEY CAN USE THAT TO OFFSET
THEIR TAX LIABILITIES AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
LIMIT THE USE OF THOSE FOR
BUSINESSES. WITH BELIEVE IT'S A
SAX MOMENT FIVE MILLION FIVE
MILLION- OF. A MILLION ACTUALLY
AND THEN THEY ARE. FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS THAT WOULD LIMIT
THAT AND SO WHAT WE WERE SAYING
IS THAT THAT IS IN EFFECT A WAY
TO ACCELERATE THE TAX PAYMENTS
THAT THEY MIGHT BE SUBJECT TO
MAKING IN FUTURE YEARS THERE'S
NO THIS IS A TAX CATEGORY
THAT'S KNOWN FOR BEING HARD TO
FORECAST AND SOME UNPREDICTABLE.
AND YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T FULLY
WORK THROUGH THE DETAILS OF IT
BUT WE SUSPECTED MIGHT BE A
LITTLE BIT HIGH IN THE-
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATES- SO
YOU'RE SO WHAT YOU ARE
REFERENCING WAS NOT POTENTIALLY
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS LIKE THAT
THAT YOU MIGHT RECOMMEND BU
RATHER THAT THIS MAY HAVE TO BE
CALCULATED DIFFERENTLY SECTOR
ACT. THAT'S CORRECT OR THEY
COULD BE STRUCTURED SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENTLY THERE'S ANOTHER
THERE'S ANOTHER. COMPANION
PROPOSAL WHERE THEY WOULD LIMIT
TAX CREDITS- BY BUSINESSES- AND
THAT'S WHERE THE FIVE MILLION
COMES IN. THE BUSINESSES WOULD
NOT BE. ABLE TO UTILIZE TAX
CREDITS IN EXCESS OF FIVE
MILLION IN ANY GIVEN YEAR. AND
THEN- THERE'S SORT OF A
BEHAVIORAL EFFECTS ON THESE
BUSINESSES AND SO THE
ADMINISTRATION WE THINK
GENERALLY CORRECTLY ACCOUNTS
FOR HOW IF YOU. MAKE A CHANGE
IN ONE OF THESE YOU YOU REALLY
KIND OF NEED TO MAKE A CHANGE
IN TE OTHER IN ORDER TO
CAPTURE THE- FACT. LONG STORY
SHORT I BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD-
YOU KNOW OUR ANALYSIS OF THIS
IS THAT IT DOES REPRESENTED
ACCELERATION OF TAX COLLECTIONS
INTO THE- NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS-
BUT NOT NECESSARILY INCREASING
IT ON ANY ONGOING BASIS. AND
SOME OF THE KIND OF CHANGES
THAT WE WOULD WE WOULD-
ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
IS. RATHER THAN AND- CAN'T
CALIBRATING IT FOR LIKE THE NET
OPERATING LOSSES RATHER HAVING
THAT APPLY TO BUSINESSES WITH
NET INCOME OF MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S A CASE FOR YOU COULD
HAVE A ONE BUSINESS COULD. NET
INCOME OF NINE HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH IS VERY
SIMILAR BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
WITH A HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION
OF NET INCOME SO INSTEAD OF-
STRUCTURED THAT WAY ONE ONE
ALTERNATIVE IDEA THAT WE HAVE
IS. REALLY SET THE- SET A
THRESHOLD FOR HOW MUCH IN NET
OPERATING LOSSES ANY BUSINESS
CAN TAKE AT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR EXAMPLE
AND SO. IT WOULD REALLY-
GENERATE THE ADDITIONAL
REVENUES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TARGETING.
BUT NOT- TREAT VIRTUALLY
SIMILAR BUSINESSES IN A
DIFFERENT WAY UNDER THE TAX
CODE. THERE ARE OTHER OTHERS
KIND OF GOING OUTSIDE OF WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
OTHER KIND OF TAX. CHANGES THAT
THERE'D STILL AVOID- SORT OF A
BROAD BASED TAX INCREASE
CHANGING TAX RATES. THIS WOULD
INVOLVE DOING THINGS LIKE
INCREASE SCENE- THE STATE'S
CONFORMITY WITH THE FEDERAL TAX
LAW. SUCH AS- REDUCING OR
CAPPING THE MORTGAGE INTEREST
DEDUCTION SO THAT IT CONFORMS
WITH THE ACTUAL FEDERAL TAX
LAW. OR ELIMINATING THE
MORTGAGE INTEREST DEDUCTION ON
SECOND HOMES THOSE ARE TAX
BENEFITS THAN GENERALLY
APPROVED TO PEOPLE WITH HIGHER
INCOMES AND HIGHER MEANS. AND
SO- IF YOU MOVED IN THAT
DIRECTION YOU COULD GENERATE
SOME ADDITIONAL REVENUE WITHOUT
OF FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGING THE
TAX CODE. THERE THERE IS WE
HAVE A WE HAVE SORT OF A LIST
OF IDEAS KIND OF ALONG THESE
LINES THAT WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO.
WORK WITH YOU ON- AND I'LL STOP
THERE UNLESS YOU WANT ME TO GO
FURTHER ON THIS NO I APPRECIATE
THAT. I REMEMBER THE DISCUSSION
THERE WAS DISCUSSION LAST YEAR
IN OUR TAX CONFORMITY ACTION
WHY THE MORTGAGE ON SECOND
HOMES WAS NOT INCLUDED. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR RAISING IT NOW
AND- I WERE IN A OBVIOUSLY IT
MORE TRUNCATED THE BUDGET
DISCUSSION THAN USUAL BUT
PERHAPS WE CAN STILL- ENTERTAIN
SUCH CONCEPTS. ON NORMAN A
DISCARDED DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- MY QUESTION HERE IS-
ON PAGE THIRTY OF THE MAY
REVISION- SORRY ON PAGE THIRTY
HER. THESE MIKES ARE HARD
ESPECIALLY WITH THESE MASKS IN
FRONT OF US ANYWAY ON PAGE
THIRTY OF THE MARY VISION.
THERE IS A REFERENCE THIS IS IN
THE HOUSING AREA. THERE IS A
REFERENCE WHICH I SUPPORT WHICH
IS. ACTION THAT COULD GUARD
AGAINST PRIVATE SECTOR ACTORS
BUYING UP DISTRESSED ASSETS- AS
WE KNOW THAT OCCURRED DURING
THE LAST RECESSION NANDED TO
HAS NOT BEEN A BENEFIT TO MOST
OF OUR NEIGHBORHOODS. ON I
WON'T I DON'T NEED TO GO INTO
DISCUSS INTO ELABORATION ON
THAT BUT I WONDERED. WHY HE DID
NOT SIEU SPECIFICS SOLVE
REFERENCE PRICE ON NO SPECIFICS
ARE THOSE. THE EITHER YOU CAN
GIVE ME AN ANSWER NOW OR A HOPE
THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE A GETS
INTO THIS AND- MAKE SURE THERE
ARE SOME SPECIFICS. WE WILL GET
BACK TO YOU IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE
PROCESS ON SPECIFICS OKAY GREAT
AND NOW I HAVE JUST A COUPLE
OF. OF QUESTIONS ON THE
CORRECTION SIDE MY SUBCOMMITTEE
PUT A SUB FIVE I WILL OF COURSE
MAKE THOSE PRIMARILY DURING MY
OWN HEARING BUT THE FIRST THING
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO- KIND OF
MADE A NOTE OR MAKE A COMMENT
ON. IS THAT IF YOU LOOK AT PAGE
ELEVEN OF THE REVISED WHICH HAS
A CHART THAT LISTS THE ARE
AGENCIES IN THEIR GENERAL FUND.
EXPENDITURES FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND IN THAT CHART IN IN EFFECT
SHOWS WHAT THE GF REDUCTIONS
ARE GOING TO BE PER AGENCY IF
THE BUDGET IS ADOPTED AS THE
MAY REVISE IN OF. OF PROPOSES
AND IN THAT CHART. THE CDC ARE
HAS THE LOWEST PERCENT
REDUCTION OF ALL AGENCIES IT IS
UNDER 1% ALL OTHER AGENCIES THE
NEXT LOWEST AGENCY IS AROUND 6%
ALL OTHER AGENCIES ARE IN THE
ORDER OF 17% FORTY PERCENT. AND
IF YOU LOOK AT ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION IT'S A 94% GENERAL
FUND REDUCTION NOW OBVIOUSLY.
PERCENTS ARE SOMEWHAT ARE YOU
CAN GET IN THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS
CAN VERY BECAUSE IF A BUDGET IS
VERY LARGE. A 1% REDUCTION CAN
BE BIG BUT ACTUALLY. DE UM. THE
IF YOU LOOK AT IT RELATIVE TO
THE EXPENDITURE LEVELS I GUESS
THE REAL QUESTION I HAVE IS
WHAT. WELL I APPRECIATE SOME OF
THE PROPOSALS WITHIN BE A SUB
FIVE CATEGORY IN THEIR SOME
GOOD ONES THAT REDUCE SPENDING
THERE'S ALSO A VERY SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF INCREASES GF
INCREASES WHICH I THINK
CONTRIBUTE TO THE FACT THAT
THERE'S ONLY 1% REDUCTION IN
GIVEN THAT. THE WE ARE FACING A
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT I'M KIND OF SURPRISED
THAT- WHEN DEPARTMENT IS
GETTING SUCH A MINIMALIST HAIR
CUT. SENATOR SKINNER ON THAT
ISSUE ALL ANSWER VERY BRIEFLY
AND MAKES YOU POINTS I THINK
NUMBER. ONE AND THEN YOU KNOW
THERE'S PROBABLY BETTER THAN
ANY THAT THAT DEPART IS A-
COURT MANDATES AND OTHER
REQUIREMENTS THAT MAKE IT HARD
TO WHICH WE REDUCE COSTS BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY NUMBER EXCUSE.
CURRENT POPULATION TRENDS HOLD
ON THE NAY REVISION JUST FOR
PROS CLOSING TWO PRESENTS OVER
THE MULTI YEAR WINDOW OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS SO THAT
SHOULD HOPEFULLY CREATES. AND
THAT'S OF COURSE WE WILL WE
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS BUT IT
DOESN'T GIVE ANY RELIEF TO
THOSE PEOPLE WHETHER THEY ARE
OUR STUDENTS. FOR OUR- LOOK
VERY LOW INCOME PEOPLE AREN'T
THE MANY OTHERS WHO WERE VERY
ECONOMICALLY. IMPACTED BY OUR
BY THE BY THE. THE CUTS WE
WOULD HAVE TO MAKE TO MEET OUR
DEFICIT SO I IN WHEN YOU
BROUGHT UP POPULATION IN THIS
WILL BE DISCUSSED OBVIOUSLY
MORE IN MY A SUBCOMMITTEE THE
MAY REVISE SHOWS THE AVERAGE
DAILY POPULATION AT ABOUT A
1-002-300-0700 WERE ADDS THE
SPRING PROJECTIONS PRIOR TO ANY
IMPACT ASSOCIATED WITH COVETED.
HELLO ONLY HAD AN AVERAGE OF
ABOUT A THOUSAND INMATE LOWER
SO ONE HUNDRED AND 220-005-0030
SIX YOU DON'T NEED TO COMMENT A
PURELY- RAISE IT AS IT'S A MUCH
HIGHER POPULATION NUMBER THEN-
OTHER DOCUMENTS SHOW AND THAT
MAY I IF WE WERE SEEING THE
ORIGINAL POPULATION NUMBERS IT
MIGHT ASSIST DUSTIN TERMS OF
THESE CAUGHT. BUT I'LL LEAVE IT
AT THAT AND WE'LL DISCUSS THEM
IN MY SUBCOMMITTEE. ON THE- ON
THE ISSUE OF THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE REALIGNMENT I
JUST REYES THIS I THINK THERE
WAS A LOT OF DEBATE LAST YEAR
THE- ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED
ELIMINATING THE JJ AND IN OUR
INCORPORATING IT INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN SERVICES
THIS BUDGET RECISIONS THAT. AND
WOULD MOVE I THINK SENATOR OF A
NELSON REFERENCED WOULD MOVE
FOLKS TO THE- COUNTY FACILITIES
WHICH OF HAS BEEN BASICALLY
BEEN SOMETHING THAT MANY
ADVOCATES HAVE ADVOCATED FOR A
LONG TIME AND ARE COUNTY
FACILITIES ARE- UNDER UTILIZED
PRESENTLY BUT I JUST RAISE IT
BECAUSE- I THINK WE THERE NEEDS
TO BE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS IN ON
HOW THE COSTS WILL BE
CALCULATED TO ENSURE THAT THE
COSTS WE BEAR THE STATE BEARS.
DUE TO THIS CHANGE DOESN'T
RESULT IN A HIGHER COST THAN
THE STATE THE COST THE STATE IS
CURRENTLY I'M EXPERIENCING SO
JUST RAISE THAT IS A LITTLE
MARKER AND THEN FINALLY. THERE
IS BY. OF MY FINAL ISSUE IS
WITHIN THE JUDICIAL. BRANCH DE
COUNTY LAWLER. ARE NOW
EXPERIENCING REVENUE SHORTFALLS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE IN HIGHER
DEMAND AS WE COULD IMAGINE
PEOPLE ARE BEING ARE ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE IMPACTED
ECONOMICALLY AND FACING WHETHER
IT'S THINGS LIKE FAMILY COURT
ISSUES CREDIT REPORTING ISSUES
FORECLOSURES EVEN WITH OUR-
EXTENSIONS. AND DRAWING UPON
THEIR COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES SO
WANTED THIS PLACE THAT MARKER
ALSO AS TO WHETHER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TRACKING THIS
ISSUE AND IF THERE'S A PLAN TO
KEEP THAT VITAL SERVICE OPEN.
AND THOSE ARE MY LAST ONES ON
CD ON THE PUBLIC SIDE. SOME
FIVE WILL GET INTO MORE DETAIL
ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SENATOR SKINNER
BEFORE I GO TO OUR LAST TWO
MEMBERS SENATOR LEYVA WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DOLLY LET
ME- MAKE SURE THAT THE- AT LET
ME INVITE THE PUBLIC WNTING TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT SECTION LET ME GIVE YOU
THE DIAL IN AND TOLL FREE
NUMBER NOW BECAUSE WILL BE
GOING TO PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER
OUR LAST TWO MEMBERS SPEAK. THE
DEATH TOLL FREE NUMBER IS. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE
SIX FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE. THE
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO NINE SEVEN
THREE FOUR SEVEN FOUR AND IT'S
ON THE BOTTOM OF THE SCREEN- OF
THE HEARING AS WE SPEAK. WE'LL
GO TO THOSE ON THE PHONE AFTER
WE- MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE NO
PEOPLE HERE IN THE GALLERY OR
THE ADJACENT HEARING ROOM TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. WITH
THAT SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU
MADAM BUDGET CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE- BUDGET STAFF FOR ALL
OF YOUR HELP IN PREPARING ALL
OF THIS. I HAVE- MANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT- OUR SCHOOLS K. TWELVE
AND HIGHER ED BUT I'M GOING TO
SAVE THOSE FOR YOU RICHARD FOR
WHEN WE MEET- NEXT MONDAY AND
BUDGET SUB ONE. FIVE TO OUR
QUESTIONS ABOUT TWO ISSUES THAT
MIGHT SEEM RATHER SMALL BUT I
THINK ARE IMPORTANT. AB SIX
SEVENTEEN AND THE FUNDING IN
THE BUDGET MOST OF YOU WILL
RECALL THAT THIS IS THE
COMMUNITY BASED CARE MONITORING
PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN FUNDED.
THROUGH THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM I APPRECIATE THAT THERE
IS TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN THE
BUDGET AS LONG AS AUCTION
PROCEEDS ARE SUFFICIENT. I HAVE
CONCERNS AS THE DID MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE WILL MR LIKE
HEALTHY. REGARDING WHAT WE WILL
ACTUALLY GET IN- CAP AND TRADE
MONIES SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE'VE COME SO FAR ON.
THE AIR AND WE'VE COME SO FAR
IN OUR DISTRICTS THAT REALLY
NEED THIS WORK I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T FORGET.
THEM AND WE DON'T LET THIS GO
TO WASTE SITE. WITHOUT OF THE
WORKING DONE BY DISTRICTS
COMMUNITIES MEMBER CLEAN UP LOW.
WILL SIGNIFY PLACE ARE STOP
GATHER. THIS IS FOR PROP. FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR GIVEN
RECENT FINDINGS THAT EXPOSURE
TO AIR POLLUTION WHEN COMBINED
WITH COVERED NINETEEN A
RESPIRATORY VIRUS BY NATURE.
MAY RESULT IN DECREASED
INCREASED DEATH EXAGGERATE
EXACERBATE NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS SO I JUST A WATERY IN
RATE THAT I HOPE WE CAN DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO. FIND THAT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS PROGRAM MOVES
FORWARD. SECONDLY I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T TALK ABOUT
MY MOBILE HOME PEOPLE AS A
CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON MOBILE HOMES. THE REDUCTION
OF FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TWO AB ONE SEVENTY
THREE THE IMPLEMENT THE
IMPLEMENTATION WILL MEAN THERE
IS LESS STAFF. TO ASSIST MOBILE
HOME OWNERS AND APPLYING FOR
THE MOBILE HOME REGISTRATION.
FEE AND TAX WAIVER. AS I'VE
SAID MANY TIMES MOBILE HOMES
ARE THE LAST BASTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IF THESE
FOLKS ARE EITHER CAN'T MAKE
THEIR PAYMENTS AT THEIR KICKED
OUT. IF THEY ARE OF THE LETTER
THE MOBILE HOME GO BACK TO THE
BANK THERE MOST LIKELY GOING TO
BE IN A ON THE STREETS. SO WHAT
I WOULD ASK IS FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
REDUCTION. IF WE CANNOT FIND
THAT MONEY TO HELP AND HELP
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS TAX
WITH MP WAIVER IS OUT THERE FOR
THEM. IT EXPIRES THIS DECEMBER
IF WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THIS
REDUCTION CAN WE MAKE SURE THAT
IN THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
WEEKS THEN THE WAIVER TO
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. TO ME THAT SEEMS
LIKE A REASONABLE COMPROMISE
THAT IS ALL I HAVE RIGHT NOW
MADAM BUDGET CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL GO TO CENTER DOLLY
AND SENATOR BAIL WILL BE OUR
LAST PERSON SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS I KNOW I WANT THIS TO
BE. COURTEOUS AND BUT I WANT I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SOME
STATEMENTS FIRST AND I DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. YOU KNOW
I HEARD FROM THE CHAIR WHEN WE
STARTED ABOUT BEING TRANSPARENT
AND- YOU KNOW THROUGH THIS
PROCESS THERE'S A VOTE I COULD
TAKE BACK IT WOULD BE SB EIGHTY
NINE BECAUSE I FELT. I FEEL
LIKE THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH OF
THIS HAS BEEN LEFT OUT OF. THE
PROCESS WE WERE ENGAGED I DON'T
BELIEVE IT ALL AND SO FOR THE
FUTURE VOTES I WILL NOT BE.
ADVOCATING FOR. US CONTROL
ACCOUNTS- FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION I DON'T THINK
IT'S THE WILL OF THE
DEMONSTRATION OF THE PAST HAS
NOT BEEN GOOD SO- AND I WANTED
TO ASK. INSPIRATION TO ON YOU
SAID SOMETHING ABOUT VACCINES
SO I WANT TO KIND OF GET THE
VISION. THIS BUDGET IS PRETTY.
LAID OUT IN A WAY WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO BE PUSHING DOWN ON
COUNTIES AND CITIES WE'RE GOING
TO BE SHIFTING FIRES AND
BARRING MONIES- AND I KNOW THAT
CITIES RELY ON PROPERTY OR OR
SALES TAX MAINLY TO IN THEIR
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN DESTROYED.
AND HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
GENERATE THAT REVENUE NOW WE
HAVE HAD THE MONEY'S COMING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THANK GOD- AND COUNTY SURVIVE
MAINLY ON PROPERTY TAX SO THOSE
ARE THE- THE TWO AREAS IT THERE
WE GET THE HAVE BASICALLY NO
ROOM. FOR US TO PUT OUR
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THEM SO I
WANT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THEM
AND CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT. MANY
OTHER MEMBERS BROUGHT UP ABOUT
THE POPULATION DIVIDE IN WHO'S
GOING TO END UP WITH WHAT. POTS
OF MONEY. SO THAT I'D LIKE TO
BE ANSWERED AND I LIKE TO THEN
THE OVERALL. VISION OF WHAT.
THE TIME FRAME IS. FOR COMING
OUT OF THIS WE WERE TOLD- BY
THE GOVERNOR'S CHIEF OF STAFF
AND DOCTOR GALLEY IN MARCH
THAT. THE PANDEMIC WOULD BE
INTEL MAY THAT HE SUPPOSEDLY
SUPPRESSES IT- SO IT'S GONNA BE
SHORT TERM AND THE GOAL POST
KEEPS MOVING SO I'M KIND OF
TRYING TO FIND OUT I HEARD THE
BOARD ARE WE GONNA WAIT TILL-THERE'S A VACCINATION. BECAUSE
IF THAT'S THE CASE.
CALIFORNIA'S IN OF IN A REALLY
BAD WAY WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO- SHIFT AROUND SO THOSE
THOSE ARE WHAT'S THE LONG TERM
VISION WHAT WHAT DO YOU SEE-
WHEN WE GET BACK SHE THERE'S
AND THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS
BUDGETS OF ABOUT. GETTING
BUSINESSES BACK GOING IN SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS
SHIFTING. SENATOR DOLLINGER ON
THOSE QUESTIONS AT FIRST I
DEFINITELY WANT TO CLARIFY.
WHEN REFERRING TO A POSSIBLE
AND I DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW THE
VACCINES FOR THE COMPANY
NINETEEN. VIRUS IN THE FUTURE-
I WAS REFERRING TO THAT AS- ANY
PLAN A SERIES OF STAGES IN
WHICH- WE GET CONTROL OUT OF.
THE EFFECTS OF THE SECOND AND I
JUST HAD ON ALL OF OUR LIVES
BUT YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THAT THERE ARE INTERMEDIATE
STAGES BETWEEN. NOW AND THEN
STARTING WITH THE STATE'S
CAREFUL RE OPENING STARTING
WITH INVESTMENTS IN A CONTACT
FACING OUTWARDS AND I THINK
YOU'RE SEEING SOME OF THAT.
FROM BEING MINISTRATION OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO.
MORE QUICKLY. THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE WHO MAY AFRAID OF
QUICKLY IT IS MOVING. CERTAINLY
THE CALL A SECOND. AS SAFELY AS
POSSIBLE CONTINUE TO REOPEN THE
ECONOMY. PLACE WHERE WE WERE
BEFORE THE STAINED AND WITHOUT
JEOPARDIZING HEALTH AND SAFETY.
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT YOU
SPECIFIC ITEMS THAT YOU
MENTIONED. FIRST ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RECOGNIZING THE
STRESS WE WERE UNDER IS WHY AT
THE STATE EVEN THOUGH WE FACE
SO MANY OF OUR OWN BY
SUPPRESSORS. MINISTRATION ALL
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
RESOLVE THE NEXT FOUR WEEKS WE
DIDN'T THINK THAT IT WAS RIGHT.
ALL OF THE STATE ALLOCATION AND
I'M NOT GOING HOURS USING ALL
FOR THE STATE GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT PRESSURES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE UNDER AND THE
FACT THAT WE ARE PARTNERS. THEY
ARE IN THE- REYES. THE SERVER.
THAT WE ARE SOMETIMES AND THEN
THIS PLANE ON GONNA TRY TO OVER
TO CHAMBER GOING TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT REFUGE
FORECAST. WHAT WILL STATE
ACROSS A- IN DEVELOPING THAT
FOR. WE ANTICIPATED AND THAT
ACTUALLY OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
WEEKS AND MONTHS. THE ECONOMY
WOULD BEGIN TO RIO. OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LATE SPRING AND
SUMMER I EVEN WITH THAT AS SOME
OF THESE SCARS ON THE ECONOMY.
I WOULD REVERBERATE FOR A
COUPLE OF YEARS AND OBVIOUSLY
OUR GOAL AS THE STATE IS TO
MAKE THAT RECOVERY PROCESS AS
SHORT AS POSSIBLE. BUT THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE ANTICIPATING RIGHT
NOW AND WILL BE TREATED ALREADY
J. JUST. BRIEFLY TALKED ABOUT-
THE INPUTS INTO. OUR REVENUE
FORECASTS. GOOD AFTERNOON ARMS
SO WE WE'RE EXPECT A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN ALL THE
REVENUE SOURCES OF THE MAJOR
REVENUE SOURCES FROM THE STATE
I THINK- ARE YOU OVER 20% LINE
IN PERSONAL INCOME TAX SALES
TAX INCORPORATION TAX FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR. I THINK ONE ONE
BRIGHT SPOT FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- TO DRESS YOUR
CONCERN IS THAT OF THE PROPERTY
TAXES IS SO WE EXPECT TO FARE.
BETTER THAN THAN THE OTHER
MAJOR REVENUE SOURCES- I'M MORE
EXPECTING ANY- SOMEWHAT OF A OF
A DECLINE. FROM WHAT WE HAD TO
GET WE ARE PROJECTED TO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT NOT
NEARLY AS SIGNIFICANT AS
OVERSEEING AND YET THE REVENUE
SOURCE. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT
STONE SO THANK YOU I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND WAS A CASE
SUPERVISOR FOR SIXTEEN YEARS
AND WE WON'T SEE THE REVENUE
DROP. IN COUNTIES UNTIL
EIGHTEEN MONTHS BECAUSE THERE
OF THE CYCLE IS TAKE THAT LONG
BUT CITIES ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED IMMEDIATELY BY SALES
TAX SO- ANYWAY APPRECIATE THOSE
COVERS IT THE- THOUGHT THERE
BUT I'VE MY GOOD IN MY BOOK. MY
POINT IS THAT WE CANNOT PUSH
DOWN ANYMORE LIABILITY OR-
OBLIGATIONS TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES- THEY'RE ALREADY
TAPPED OUT AND I I'VE HEARD A
LOT FROM MY FROM LOS I
REPRESENT ELEVEN COUNTIES. THE
OTHER THING I WANTED TO ASK
ABOUT WAS UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
I CANNOT TELL YOU HOW MANY
CALLS ON GETTING OUR SYSTEM IS
BROKEN. IT DOESN'T ALLOW FOR-
THE MASS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
TRYING TO GET APPOINTMENTS AND
THE- ORIGINAL PEOPLE THAT
SIGNED UP. DIDN'T CLICK THE BOX
RIGHT WE DIDN'T HAVE A BOX FOR
COVE IT AND SO IT REJECTED ALL
THOSE PEOPLE AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF MORNING AWARE THAT
THEY'RE- THEY'RE NOT GETTING
FILE BECAUSE IT REJECTED HIM
AND WHAT ARE WE DOING IN THAT
AREA. I KNOW THERE WAS A
CONFERENCE CALL WITH ATTENDED
ON IT THERE'S LIKE TWENTY FIVE
PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THAT OFFICE
BUT WE NEED. IMMEDIATE SUPPORT
TO THE U. I. OFFICE SO WE CAN
GET THESE BENEFITS OUT OF THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING THERE. I
CAN I CAN SHARE STORY WITH YOU
REAL QUICK. A PERSON WHO DRIVES
AN S. U. V. WHO HAD A GREAT JOB
BURN THROUGH THEIR SAVINGS AND
IS TRYING TO GET FOOD FROM- THE
NONPROFIT. BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
GET THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
SENATOR WHAT I'LL SAY HERE IS I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZES THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING IN
ESPECIALLY IN A PUBLIC FACING.
AGENCY OR DEPARTMENT MIKEY D.
WHEN THEY PEOPLE ARE DEPENDING
ON THE STATUS STATES AND
THEY'RE CERTAINLY NOT SHOWING
UP AT THE SPEAKS ALL OF US
WOULD WANT I THINK ALL I CAN
SAY IS YOUR NUMBER ONE THAT YOU
FOR WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK TO
SPECIFICALLY ON MACS UDTS OUR
SECOND EXTENDED YOUR CALL HOURS
OR MORE PER DAY. ON THE WEEKEND
IN TERMS OF CALL CENTERS I KNOW
THAT THAT IS NOT. YOU MEAN
PEOPLE AREN'T GETTING. THIS FOR
RIGHT NOW BUT- WE ARE DOING THE
BEST WE CAN NOW WITH AGE OLD
WATCHFUL SYSTEMS ARE NOT
CERTAINLY. NEED UPDATING AND
SOME ASK FEDERAL ASSISTANCE HAS
BEEN FORTHCOMING IN OUR EFFORTS
TO REFORM THOSE AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. I THINK THE OTHER
CHALLENGE AND THIS IS A GOOD
THING THAT. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CRAFTED ON ITS OWN
THEN ESTATES ON OUR STUDENTS
SIMPLY EXTEND. THAT WENT ON A-
THEY ALSO ADDED AS YOU KNOW THE
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS PER WEEK
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS. THERE WAS
ALSO THE CAN DOWN THE KIND OF
ON AN INSURANCE PROGRAM FOR
PEOPLE. WHO MAY NOT QUALIFY FOR
TRADITIONAL UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AT THE STATE LEVEL
BUT ALSO LOST HER JOB I THINK
THE CHALLENGES WHEN YOU HAVE
ALL THESE DIFFERENT PIECES ON
TOP OF EACH OTHER. YOU PUT IT
ON TOP OF ANY AGE OLD
TECHNOLOGICAL SYSTEMS AND THEN
YOU SEE. THE I WE NEVER SEEN
SOMETHING LIKE THIS. IF YOU GO
BACK TO THE ONCE IN A CENTURY
AND THIS IS TRULY UNBELIEVABLE
YOU KNOW I THINK IN THE GREAT
RECESSION. MONTHS IF NOT YEARS.
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT TO READ JUST.
A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN 12% FOR
YES AND HE'S HERE WE'VE SEEN IN
A MATTER OF WEEKS- SITTING WAY
PAST THAT MARKS SO I THINK OUR
SYSTEMS. DO YOU NEED A LOT OF
IMPROVEMENTS BUT EVEN A WELL
PUT TOGETHER SYSTEM- WOULD HAVE
STRUGGLED UNDER THE STRAIN OF
THE PANIC THAT WE'RE SEEING.
BUT THAT'S A LONG ANSWER THE
SHORT VERSION HERE SHORT ANSWER
TO YOUR QUESTION IS ON THE
PERFORMANCE THAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW EVERYBODY IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. KNOWS IT NEEDS
TO BE IMPROVED WE'RE WORKING AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE RESOURCES AND.
EXPERTISE IS THERE. PEOPLE
EXACTLY THE PERSON YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU. THAT THE FIRM. THE
DOW YOU'RE DONE. THANK YOU WILL
GONNA GO TO SENATOR BAIL. AND
THEN WE WILL CLOSE WITH A TWO
BILLS AND SENATOR BAIL. THANK
YOU WELL I APPRECIATE BEING
LAST. I A- I HAD A QUESTION
ABOUT THE TRIGGERS- THE
FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IS I
UNDERSTAND IT IS THE TRIGGER A
MILE AND- WERE LOOKING TO
DEPEND ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THOSE DOLLARS.
AND THEY WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
US FOUR OR ONE MAYBE TWO YEARS
OR ARE I'D LIKE TO KNOW ABOUT
GOD WHAT'S THE INTENTION. AND
THEN THE HOW DID-
ADMINISTRATION SELECT. THE
PROJECT WERE THINGS THAT WERE
COVERED BY THE TRIGGER AND THE
BUDGET AND THE REASON I'M
ASKING ABOUT IS IT APPEARS THAT
YOU'RE SELECTING A LOT OF ON
GOING EXPENSES ARE ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT EDUCATION
AND THAT'S A BIG A BIG I'M
DOLLAR AMOUNT THERE BUT ALSO.
PROGRAMS FOR DEVELOPING
DISABLED AND I CAN ECHO ECHO
SENATE CENTER SCANNERS REMARKS
ABOUT THERE'S CERTAIN PROGRAMS
THE SEEM TO BE. TARGETED A
LITTLE BIT MORE AND I KNOW SAID
THE RATES HAVE BEEN ROLLED BACK
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT DISABLED.
IT APPEARS THEY'VE BEEN ROLLED
BACK FOR FIVE YEARS BACK TO
WHERE WE HAD A FIVE YEARS AGO.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW. WHY.
POPULATIONS THAT ARE CLEARLY IN
DANGER DUE TO THE VIRUS. ARE
HAVING SUCH LARGE CUTBACKS FOR
THESE PROGRAMS THIS DOES NOT
MAKE SENSE TO ME. OF IT IS NOT
CLEAR TO ME WHY OUT. ROUTE WAS
CHILDREN CHOSEN BY YOU- AND I
REALLY THINK THAT OUGHT TO BE
WE LOOKED AT SO MAYBE WE CAN
GET A RESPONSE OR BUDGET
DIRECTOR OF THAT. AND
APPRECIATE SENATOR ROBB
SCANNERS REMARKS ON AND WE'LL
SEE HER AT UP. WEDNESDAY
HEARING WE WERE GOING TO HAVE
AN ARC SUBCOMMITTEE SO THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER THIS ONE OFTEN.
YES HI SENATOR BALLOT I WILL
MAKE AYE CHIU BRIEF POINTS ON
THAT TRIGGERS THE ISSUES THAT
YOU RAISE AND THEN I'M GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
FRANK HOLLISTER WHO'S ON OUR
HHS FINANCE YOU TALK ABOUT THE
SPECIFICS OF THE GDS PROVISIONS
THAT YOU MENTION. THE FIRST
POINT SPEAKING VERY BROADLY IS
THAT THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
THE ITEMS THAT WERE IN THE
TRIGGER VERSES WERE NOT THESE
WERE A LOT OF AYE SINCE THEIR
GENERALLY HERE'S ANY ITEMS THAT
WERE COMPOSED AS NEW EXTENSIONS
IN JANUARY- WERE MOSTLY WHAT'S
WRONG AND NOT INCLUDED- BECAUSE
THOSE WERE NOT A SIGN BUDGET ON
THE TWENTY NINETEEN. BUT WHEN
IT COMES TO THAT BASED. IN ON.
ITEMS TWENTY NINETY BUDGET I.
MIGHT THE LCS FOR WHITE BASED
ON FUNDING THAT WE- TO YOU SEE.
YES YEAR DOES CUTS. ACTUALLY TO
MAKE BECAUSE THERE WERE A BACK
EVEN WASN'T NINE. NOT TO WHAT
WE ARE TO X. TWENTY. DOES WERE
GENERALLY THE ITEMS THAT
WORKPLACE IN THE TRACKER AND
THE SECOND POINT IS YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT. IF NOT
MOST OF THE ITEMS IN THE
TRAILERS ARE ONGOING
EXPENDITURES SO IT IS THE CASE
AND WE'RE VERY COGNIZANT UP
THIS THAT EVEN IF FEDERAL
FUNDING ARRIVES IN THE AMOUNT
OF FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
WOULD TRIGGER OFFICE. FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR TWENTY TWENTY DASH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BUT WE WOULD
STILL NEED TO FIND WAYS TO ON
THOSE EXPENDITURES IN THE YEARS
AFTER THAT WHEN WE ARE FACING
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS AND THAT'S
ONE REASON WHY. WHEN WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT ARE ASK FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S WE'RE NOT ASKING
FOR FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
FOR ASKING FOR SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE. BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO EVER. ONE
OF ON GOING BASS. BECAUSE IS MY
CALLING TO CHAMBER ONE. THE IS
GOING TO STAY SEVERAL YEARS TO
RECOVER. WHEN IT COMES IS
TYPICALLY TO. THAT SERVICE.
RATE REDUCTIONS YOU TURN IT
OVER TO GRANT AT STOCK OF HOW.
THE THOUGHT ABOUT THOSE THAT
CUT IN ANY AREA WICKS IS
PAINFUL AS WE WERE. THIS YEAH
EARLY. EMPTY THIS IS THE
RESOURCES ROOM HOPING WE CAN
USE TO WRAP AROUND HOUSE ARE
TYLER WHAT I. OKAY MAYBE- LATER
TO GET BACK TO ME BUT- BUT- MY
POINT MY POINT I WANNA SHOES ON
THE ON THE STRUCTURE OF THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL. WHY WHY ARE.
WHY RISK AS OF YOU KNOW FOR THE
TRIGGER STILL GOING TO FACT-
THOSE PROGRAMS GET C<c.cyan></c>
AUTOMATICALLY RIGHT WHAT I
REALIZE THE KINDS OF PROBLEMS.
THAT WERE HAPPENING WHEN WE PUT
THAT MONEY FIVE YEARS AGO IN
THE BUDGET IN THE FIRST PLACE I
KNOW THAT I WORK WITH IT WAS A
BIPARTISAN EFFORT THEN WE WORK
WITH GOVERNOR BROWN TO PUT THE
MONEY FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
DISABLED BACK INTO THE BUDGET.
BECAUSE WE WERE STARTING TO SEE
PLACES CLOSE PROGRAM SHUTTING
DOWN- YOU KNOW HOUSING UNITS SO
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT DISABLED-
DECIDED THEY WORK CONTINUE ON-
ALL THESE PROBLEMS WAY WAY
CREEK THEIR PRODUCTS AND A
PROBLEM NOW. WITH THESE. WHO
ARE VERY HIGH REAL US TO THE
VIRUS. AND WE SHOULD NOT BE
DOING THIS FOR THOSE KINDS OF
PEOPLE. I DON'T TRUST THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S GONNA COME
UP WITH ANYTHING BUDGET JULY.
OF MADE DOES ANYBODY WANT TO
PUT MONEY ON THAT I'LL TAKE
THAT. SO I THINK IT COULD BE.
STALEMATE UNTIL AFTER THE
ELECTION I MEAN- SO I WANT TO
KNOW WHY THOSE PROGRAMS WERE
ACTED JUST. IT'S LIKE-
INCONGRUENT SO- SENSE OF
PRIORITIES AND PROTECTING
PEOPLE THAT ARE. DISABLE THAT
HAVE HEALTH PROBLEMS TO BEGIN
WITH AND ARE VERY VULNERABLE TO
THE VIRUS ITSELF WHITE WHERE IT
RISKS THOSE PEOPLE WE DON'T
NEED THAT. SO I LIKE I LIKE
SOME KIND OF ANSWER BUT I LIKE
IT. MAYBE MAYBE IT'S A HIGHER
LEVEL THAT WE SHOULD HAS THAT
SHOULD ANSWER THOSE THE
GOVERNOR THE CHIEF OF STAFF I
LIKE TO KNOW THOUGH I AM I AM.
WE HAD QUITE A LONG BATTLE TO
GET THOSE MONIES IN THE FIRST
PLACE. IF EVERYBODY REMEMBERS
THAT I I'LL BE WILLING TO GO GO
THROUGH IT AGAIN. BUT HI I LIKE
TO KNOW WHAT THE ANSWERS ARE.
SENATOR NOW I JOE DAYCARE
DIESEL GENERATOR ON THING
THERE'S A SATISFYING ANSWER
YOUR AND YOU MENTIONED I'M NOT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL THE GOVERNOR.
SENDING HIS NEIGHBOR VISION
PRESS CONFERENCE SAID THIS AREA
OF CONSTANT PARTICULAR IN THE
COSTS THAT ARE IN THE TRIGGER
BUT HE SAID THEY BREAK HIS
HEART AND SO. ALL OF THESE CUTS
ARE PAINFUL CUTS IN THE AREA
THAT YOU MENTIONED CRITICAL OR
WE SO- BUT EVEN WITH THE
CONCEPT WE HAVE A WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE AN ON GOING. PROBLEM
AND SO THESE ARE WERE SIMPLY TO
CUTS. THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE TO
PUT FORWARD A BALANCED BUDGET
FOR THIS YEAR. WHEN NOBODY IS
TALKING ABOUT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR BILL GOING TO GO TO
SENATOR NIELSEN FOR ONE MORE
COMMENT AND THEN WILL BE
PREPARED TO OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. SENATOR
NIELSEN. I'M SO USED TO
STANDING UP MADAM CHAIR OF THIS
IS A- DIFFICULT THING TO. STAND
AS HE'D LIKE YOUR PRISON THE
BILL YOU CAN WATCH I GET I JUMP
AROUND ALL OVER THE PLACE I'LL
BE VERY BRIEF AND- MY
COLLEAGUES AND- TO THE
GOVERNOR. THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
I REALLY WOULD LIKE TO. CLOSE
TO THE OBSERVATION THAT
WHATEVER WE ARE GOING TO BE
DOING IT. AND WE HAVE BEEN
THROUGH THIS BILL BEFORE SO I
BELIEVE WE'LL GET THERE. BUT IT
IS INDEED. THE KEY. IS ECONOMY.
BUT WHAT WE DO IN THE BUDGET.
HERE BUT WHAT GOES ON WITH THE
ECONOMY OTHER THAN WHAT WE DO
IN THE BUDGET AS IT ENCOURAGES
RATHER THAN DISCOURAGES. THE
ECONOMY BOTH IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND IN THE LEAD THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. AND IN THE BUDGET. AND
I MAY BE WRONG I AM NO IMMINENT.
ECONOMIST BUT I TRULY BELIEVE
IN AMERICA TODAY IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY. THERE'S A PATH UP INTO
GSM ABOUT GETTING BACK TO WORK.
THAT WILL TRANSLATE INTO A
GREAT ECONOMIC JUMPED IN A
RETURN TO OUR PROSPERITY AS
WE'RE DOING THAT. AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT EACH DAY IT
SEEMS ALMOST THE GOVERNOR IS
OPENING UP A BIT MORE. AND I
ENCOURAGE THAT TO CONTINUE
BECAUSE AS FAR AS GETTING OUT
OF THIS DEEP HOLE AND STAYING
OUT OF IT WHICH WILL REQUIRE
SOME STRUCTURAL THINGS THAT
WILL DO HERE BUT THAT IS SO KEY.
AND YOU ALL SEE IT AS I DO IN
AREAS THAT WE REPRESENT. THOSE
HOLLOW LICE WONDERING AROUND OR
SITTING AT HOME FRUSTRATED.
GETTING ANTSY. HAVE AN WHAT
THEY'VE CALLED CABIN FEVER. BUT
THEN THAT QUICKLY TRANSLATES
AND I DO NOT THINK IT HAS QUITE
YET BUT TO FEAR. OUTRAGE FEAR.
AND I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT WE
DARE LET THAT HAPPEN. SO THESE
POSITIVE SIGNALS EMANATING FROM
SACRAMENTO TO THOSE BUSINESSES.
HEY IT'S GOING TO BE OKAY
YOU'LL COME BACK WILL BE HERE
TO HELP YOU. I THINK THAT IS SO
CRITICAL AND I ASK THAT WE
REALLY DO FOCUS ON THE ECONOMY
AS WE PROCEED IN OUR BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS AND PLAYED IN
JAIL AND I LOOK FORWARD THAT
LONG AND ARDUOUS PROCESS. WITH
YOU YET AGAIN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. MISTER VICE CHAIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
WE APPRECIATE IT OUT WITH THAT
COLLEAGUES SEEN NO FURTHER
MEMBERS WHO CHOOSE TO BE
RECOGNIZED- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
INTO OUR PUBLIC COMMENT.
PORTION OF THE AGENDA- GOING TO
INSTITUTE A TIME LIMIT ON
TESTIMONY WE TYPICALLY DOING
BUDGET. COMMITTEE BUT- NOW
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE LENGTH
OF THE HEARINGS TCHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS. AND I KNEW
CLEANING PROTOCOLS ARE GOING TO
LIMIT TESTIMONY TO ONE MINUTE.
SO LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY THIRTY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC
COMMENT. SEEN NONE THAT THE
SERGEANTS CAN TELL ME IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN HEARING ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. THERE ARE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY- WITH THAT THANK
YOU THEN WILL MOVE INTO- ON TO
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY. THE OF THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE THANK
YOU MODERATOR. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT AT THIS TIME
PRESS ONE ZERO. MODERATOR
MARKETPLACE FOR COULD YOU
BEFORE WE BEGIN COULD YOU
PLEASE TELL ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. I'M AND THEIR
QUEUING UP RIGHT NOW IT LOOKS
LIKE WE'VE GOT ABOUT. HANNAH
THAT MAKE YOU. OKAY ALL RIGHT
WILL TAKE THE FIRST MEMBER
PLEASE. ONE MOMENT. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH LYING IN A FORTY TWO
I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LEAD
TO REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YEARS AND I
WANTED TO CHECK OUT THE CAN YOU
PROVIDE SOME COMMENT FROM THE
GENERAL BUDGET STRUCTURE AND
THAT WE HAVE LEARNED THAT. THE
PROJECT GRAHAM HERE REALLY
GONNA CONTINUE TO LEAVE OUR
UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH ON THE
STREET. BUT THE LINE FOR SIXTY
FIVE- PEOPLE OF AGE OR OLDER
THAT AT THE TIME THAT WE REALLY
HAVE TO BE BRINGING YOU INTO
THE PROGRAM AND WE KNOW THAT
YOU MAY NOT HAVE THE BACK NEAR
THE CLINIC AND MEDICAL
CONDITIONS THAT WOULD GET THEM
IN THE PROGRAM. AND I THINK YOU
KNOW IT DIFFICULT FOR OUR YOUTH
ON THE STREET REALLY SHELTER IN
PLACE WHEN THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE
A QUICKLY LIKE WASH THEIR
HANDS. AND STAY HEALTHY AND EAT.
PAPER NO PERMANENT ROOM. YOU
KNOW WORKING WE BEEN INCREASE
BECAUSE TWO PRO. I HAVE. YOU
NEEDING BASIC NEEDS ADDITIONAL.
I HAVING A LOT OF AND MEANT
HEALTH NEEDS HIGHER THE YEARS I
CRIED MY IS EVEN HARDER NEED.
DATA PLAYERS THERE'S THEY FEEL
AREN'T SAFE FOR THEM BUT NEED
HERE BECAUSE OF THE SELF
EMPLOYED ORDER AND WE HAVE I'M
CALLING FROM BACKROOM SHOWERS
RUNNING BECAUSE THEY DON'T TO
BE OVER HEARD BUT PEOPLE AND
THEIR HOME EVEN THE CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELLNESS. AND I THINK WE REALLY
EED TO ENSURE THAT WHATEVER
POLLUTION FORWARD AROUND
HOMELESSNESS DOESN'T LEAVE.ARE
YOU CONTINUOUSLY ON THE STREET.
IT'S ONLY GONNA GET WORSE TO
COME OUT OF THAT HAND THEM. AND
YOU HAVE BEEN REALLY MAKE.
IMPACTED LOW WAGE JOBS BEING.
CUT FROM OUR APPROVING YOUR JOB
ALTOGETHER. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU COULD YOU OPEN THE
CALL TO THE NEXT MEMBER THE
PUBLIC PLEASE. NEXT CALL THAT A
LINE FORTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
TIRING YUBA COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
I'M BECOMING NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HAVE EXACERBATED THE NEED FOR
OUR HEALTH SERVICE ABOUT THE
SAME TIME THAT REVENUES ARE
DECLINING PRECIPITOUSLY I'M
COUNTY OPERATE ENTITLEMENT IN
CRITICAL PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF
THE DEBATE THE REALIGNMENT
INCLUDED MEDI CAL SB MENTAL
HEALTH AND- DISORDERS ARE AT
THAT. WOULD NEVER IMAGINE ONE
REALIGNMENT WOULD AGREE TO THAT
WE WOULD BE IN A TIME WHERE
WE'D BE UNABLE TO MAINTAIN
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL AND
STATE REGULATIONS WITH THAT
YEAH WELL I'M BIG LAW OVER A
THREE POINT THREE BILLION OVER
TWO YEARS. BLOCKING TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE LEGISLATURE
IN ADMINISTRATION TO PRESERVE
PROM REALIGNMENT PROGRAM AND
AVOID MAP WITH CUTS OR SERVICE
WHICH RUSSIAN MILITARY SERVICE
ARE RENDON AND NEED THE MOST
DURING THAT TIME WE DID YOU
KNOW WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
ELIMINATION OF THE AMERICAN
RESPONSE FROM IN THE MOB. IN
THE MAY REVISIT MAY REVISION ON
WHICH IS THE GUY TO PROVIDE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TRAUMA
INFORMED SUPPORT TO CURRENT AND
FORMER BOSS YOU CAN THEIR CARE
GIVERS REGIONALLY ASKING FOR
FLEXIBILITY WITHIN THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES BACK IN ORDER
TO LEVERAGE AND MAJOR PAY FINES
MORE EFFECTIVELY TO MEET THE
CHALLENGES. YET RECOVERED
NINETEEN WE ALSO LIKE TO
REQUEST. CONSIDERATION OF THE
PARTY MATTER HOW. WHAT YOU'RE
SUCCESSFUL IN PROVIDING.
EFFECTIVE AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT SERVE GEN. AND WITH
MARIJUANA THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALL THAT ONLINE. FORTY
EIGHT. HELLO MADAM CHAIR TO
PROVIDE LOW ELECTRIC AND I'M ON
POVERTY. CALLING WITH A COUPLE
OF APPOINTED LIKE MAKE ABOUT
THE BUDGET MY COLLEAGUE MIKE
HERALD ALSO CALLING IN WITH
ADDITIONAL POINTS- I JUST LIKE
TO SAY THAT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FOCUS. ON AND ON
THE MOST DEEPLY IN POVERTY AND
CHILDREN SPECIFICALLY- NOT THAT
BECAUSE THAT WILL PREVENT THEM
FROM HAVING LONG AND EVER
LASTING HARM VERY THAT. AT THIS
CRISIS BUT ALSO BECAUSE AND
INVESTMENT IN THE COURSE
CALIFORNIANS AND ALSO SEE BY
CONSERVATIVE ECONOMISTS AND
BEING ONE OF THE BEST WAY TO
STIMULATE THE ECONOMY IF YOU
WANT TO GET MONEY OUT THE DOOR
AND INTO THE ECONOMY GIVE IT TO
THE LOWEST INCOME PEOPLE FIRST.
AND WOULD LIKE TO REINFORCE.
THE QUESTION BY SENATOR. AND
HER. YOU KNOW INQUISITION HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WHEN WE
HAVE SEVERAL LIKE NOW AND LIKE
THAT THAT TAX STIMULANT COMING
TO LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS CAN
WE MAKE SURE WHAT CAN WE DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE BENEFITS
GET IN THE HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE SO THEY'RE OUT
THERE WORKING TO PREVENT HUNGER.
AND THAT PREVENT HOMELESSNESS
AND OTHER CRIMES POVERTY. WE
WERE IN MOVING ON NUTRITION
HOPEFULLY EVERYBODY HAS SEEN
THAT. ONE IN FIVE AMERICANS IS
ADULT AMERICANS THAT IS
EXPERIENCING HUNGER DURING THE
CALL THE PERIOD 40% OF SINGLE
PARENTS ARE EXPERIENCING HUNGER
CHILDREN HAVE HIGH HIGH RATES
OF HUNGER WE NEED TO BE FOCUSED
ON HUNGER AND A SOLUTION I'M
THE REALLY GREAT THAT THE THAT
THERE WERE NO. PRESIDENT BUT
ALSO UNDERTOOK WHEN YOU SHOULD
SEE. THAT HI IN THE WHAT
EXPANSION OF THE CALPERS REST
FROM YOUR PROGRAM A PROGRAM
THAT MAY ALSO NOT ONLY HELP
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN NEED OF A
PREPARED MEAL BUT MAY ALSO HELP
OUT OF WORK. RESTAURANT
EMPLOYEES TAKE YOUR OR REQUIRE
REGAIN THEIR EMPLOYMENT. I'M A
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE
UNDERSTAND IF THAT DEPARTMENT
SAYING. THAT THEY CAN'T MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT. THE END WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE ON
THEIR WAY THEM IN THEIR- AND
CAN PASS TO DO SO. THEY AND-
END OF THE OVER A BILL DOLLAR
IN RELIEF AND THE PREVIEW
COVERED BACK FOR NUTRITION AND
ARE AND WE TRUST THERE ANYTHING
AND HOW FAR AND HOW FAST THEY
CAN MOVE ON THAT RESTAURANT NO
EXPAND. IN CLOSING WE FIND
THANK YOU FOR THE SENATE AND-
WOMAN FOR ALL YOU'VE DONE THAT
I. THE WE DIDN'T HAVE A STAKE
IN THE DEEPER CUTS AND INVITE
ALL OF THE SENATOR TO JOIN US
IN FIVE FOR THE FED RELIEF THAT
NEED. IN ORDER THE TRIGGER CAT
HAD THAT THAT THE BEST A WE CAN
ADD SHE RIGHT NOW AND WE INVITE
YOU TO PARTY WITH US ADDICT IT.
THANK YOU. NECK CALL THAT'LL.
FORTY FOUR. BETTER HEARING BACK
ROGER AND ME AFTER THE
TEAMSTERS IMPAIRED AS YOUR
GEISHA DISTRICT I JUST HAVE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO RESTORE FUNDING
RIGHT AND I NEED YOU ONE ZERO
FOUR NINE FIVE. ON WHICH
APPROPRIATED SEVEN POINT THREE
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL. YOU SHOULD GET.
RESTORATION FUNDING IS FOR THE
PURPOSE ACTION BY OF PARADISE
YOUR HERE YEAH BY THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY FIRE. THAT YOUR NATION
DISTRICT CLEAN DRINKING WATER
FOR THE TOWN OF PARADISE DURING
THE TWENTY NINE BADGE CYCLE.
YEAH HE WAS ABLE TO SECURE TWO
YEARS BACK HEALTH FIND IN ORDER
TO KEEP THE WATER UTILITY
OPERATIONAL AND RESPOND. BUT IN
ALMOST ENTIRELY TOWARDS PAYING
ITS EMPLOYEES WHO WORK. IF YOU
MEMBERS. HE WAS NOT A THAT THE
SECOND YEAR DYLAN IN JEFF INTO
RELEASED THE TWENTY MAYOR
BUDGET LAST WEEK WE ANDERSON
THAT CALIFORNIA PLEASE. VERY
STRANGE YOU THE KIND OF IN
NINETEEN PAN DOWN. EVEN SO WE
ASK YEARS K<c.cyan></c><c.cyan>WI SECOND</c>
YEAR ABOUT IS PART OF THE BILL.
IF THE LEGISLATURE SERIOUS
ABOUT PARADISE BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IT IS ABOUT BACK FILL
THE P. IDEA TO CENSURE BECAUSE
WE DRINK WATER PARADISE
REMEMBER COPPER THANK YOU. NEXT
PHOTO LINE STUFF. THANK YOU
GREETINGS NOT MANY MISTER
ROGERS I'M ON BEHALF OF GOLDEN
STATE OPERA YOUR IS A NON.
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
ENDING POVERTY- CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF ITUNES
HOLDERS IN THE ACCOUNT YET YOU
SEE IN THE CALL. VERSION A TEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND- THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE- STATE
BUDGET TO SUPPORT. THE ATC
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH EFFORT
EFFORTS AS WELL AS- PRE TAX
PREPARATION SERVICES- FUNDING
IT'S BEEN INCLUDED AND PASS
BUDGETS AND IS CRITICAL TO
HELPING CALIFORNIA DRIVE DOWN
THE ALMOST TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
IN FEDERAL EITC PAYMENTS THAT
ARE LEFT ON THE TABLE EACH YEAR
MORE CRITICAL THAN EVER. THIS
FUNDING WILL ALSO HELP PEOPLE
FATHER TAXES FOR. IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE TAX
PREPARATION SERVICES FOR A LOT
MORE DIFFICULT THAN EVER TO
ATTAIN. THIS FUNDING WILL ALSO
HELP THE STATE- REACH A GREATER
NUMBER OF PEOPLE- AND FAMILIES
THAT ARE BECOMING NEWLY
ELIGIBLE AS RESULT THE
RECEPTION- FOR THE CAL YOU
EIGHTY C. THE FEDERAL YET YOU
SEE IN THE NEWLY CREATED YOUNG
CHILD TAX FOR. JUST WANNA DATE-
THANK YOU CARE MEMBERS STAFF
ALL THE WORK YOU'RE DOING HERE
WERE WERE REALLY GREAT. THANKS
NEXT CALL THAT A LINE FORTY
NINE. SH BUT AFTERNOON- CHAIR
MITCHELL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALAN ABS
I'M WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK SENATOR LEYVA
FOR BRINGING UP THE- THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CODE
NINETEEN AND ARE AT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT. THAT THERE'S A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT TO OUR
OVER BURDEN COMMUNITIES AND
THAT'S WHY FUNDING FOR THE AB
SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM IS SO
IMPORTANT AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR'S- STAFF FOR
MAINTAINING THE AB SIX
SEVENTEEN INCENTIVE FUNDING BY
IN THE CURRENT BUDGET BUT I
ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS SOME
CONCERN. THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION PORTION OF THAT
FUNDING HAS NOT BEEN
PRIORITIZED IN AND LIKELY
WOULDN'T BE REALIZED THAT BY
ANY THE AIR DISTRICTS AND- THE
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING IS
CRITICAL TO THE WORK THAT WE DO
IN THE COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE
MONITORING SERVICES. TO PROVIDE
COMMUNITY OUT REACH TO WORK
WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO GET
REDUCTIONS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND TO MAKE THEIR VOICES HEARD
AND WE HOPE TO WORK WITH- THE
SENATE BUDGET STAFF TO SHOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF BUT THIS-
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING ARE
WORKING DISADVANTAGED.
COMMUNITIES GOING FORWARD THANK
YOU. IN FACT WE WILL THAT'LL
LINE. FIVE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS A
MILLION THE MONEY CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRAVELS. AND A BROAD COALITION
OF ADVOCATES SPENDING TRAVELING
TOWARD THEM LABOR MEDIA AND
LOCAL CHAMBER. EVEN IN SEVERE
DOWNTURN IN LEISURE AND
HOSPITALITY JOB DETAILED IN THE
REVISION WE RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THAT ARE A ONE TIME FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION.
CALIFORNIA TO CREATE AND TOWARD
THE MARKETING CAMPAIGN. WHEN
LEISURE TRAVEL THE COULD B THE
GOVERNOR. SURE CALIFORNIANS TO
TRAVEL AGAIN AND TO ENCOURAGE.
THEM TO CALIFORNIA WHEN THEY DO.
WE DELIVER TO POINT THREE
DOLLARS IN REVENUE TO
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES. AND
EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
MILLION AND ADDITIONAL STATE
AND LOCAL TAX REVENUE. REACTOR
WE ARE ON OUR WITHOUT TRAVEL
CALIFORNIA WILL LOSE SEVENTY
TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
THAT ARE SPENDING. A LOT. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COOLEY SIX POINT ONE
BILLION IN TAX REVENUES THAT
PLAN BY THE LOCAL SERVICES LIKE
POLICE FIRE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION. WE KNOW THAT
THE COACH WORK BECAUSE THE ONE
TIME BUDGET I ALLOCATION OF AT
THE CALIFORNIA PERSONAL OUR
CAMPAIGN HELPED US GET BACK
AREN'T THE AFTER NINE ELEVEN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. NEXT WE WILL
THAT ALIGN FORTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BLEND INTO IT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WE
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITIZATION
OF GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FIND FUNDING FOR THE EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY ARE
PROTECTION PROGRAM. AND FOR
AGRICULTURAL DIESEL ENGINE
UPGRADES AND REPLACEMENT TWO
VERY IMPORTANT PUBLIC. A
QUALITY PROGRAMS HOWEVER WE ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED THERE WILL BE
LITTLE TO NO FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AB SIX
SEVENTEEN PROGRAM AND WE
APPRECIATE. COMMENTS ON THIS WE
KNOW THAT FOR THIS COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAM TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING NEEDS TO
BE ADEQUATE AND ONGOING
INCENTIVES AND IMPLEMENTATION
GO HAND IN HAND I POINT OUT
THAT IMPLEMENTATION WAS FOUNDED
AT FIFTY MILLION LAST YEAR
WHICH IS. SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
THAN THE ACTUAL COST. BE
SPEAKING TO THIS IN THIS AS
WELL AND YOU CAN SEE YOUR YOUR
TIME ON THIS THANK YOU MADAM
AND MEMBERS. MEXICO A LINE. SIX
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT MY
NAME IS PATRICK MCFARLAND WITH
THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER-
I WANNA LINE MY COMMENTS WITH
ALL MY COLLEAGUES IN STATEWIDE.
YOU SEE ACTION AS WE KNOW KOBE
NINETEEN THAT DISRUPTED DAILY
LIFE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS BUT
ACCESS TO CHILDCARE IS CRITICAL
TO COMBATING THIS CARD AND FOR
THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY TO
PROBLEM WE- TO COMMITTEE ADMIN.
PORTS DECISIVE ACTION TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY FUNDING AND
DOCTORS FOR SUPPLIES. EMERGENCY
FUNDING FOR DOCTORS AND THE BY
THE- EASY COALITION IS
CERTAINLY IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
REJECT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO DECREASE THE STATE-REIMBURSEMENT RATE AND THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE. CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS ARE PROVIDING AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE AND ARE
SERVING ESSENTIAL WORKERS
PAYING AS REACH MAKES IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING CARE WE ALSO ASK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MOVED THE
SUNSET ON THE EMERGENCY
VOUCHERS AND SUPPLIES THAT
ESSENTIAL WORKERS CAN CONTINUE
ACCESSING CHILDCARE. THANK YOU.
BLACK LABEL THAT ONLINE. THIRTY
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS PUBLIC IS FOCUSED
ON THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
APPRECIATE THE FOCUS ON OUR
MOST VULNERABLE YOUTH AND
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY ANIME
REVISION HOWEVER. CORD AS WE
NOW FACE OPPOSED 10% REDUCTION
AND THE PHONE. SPORTS ARE STILL
PROVIDING HEALTHY MEALS IN
PLEDGING STUDENTS AND
CONTINUING COULD DELIVER OTHER
MUCH NEEDED SERVICES TO OUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WELL I'M
TO SCHOOL CLOSURES AND FACING
CHALLENGES AT THE HOUSE SCHOOL
OPEN THEY FLEE. HOLDER AND
INTEGRAL PART OF THE STATE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY FROM THE
NOVEL CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC.
GOOD FOR YOUR EFFORTS TO
ADVOCATE FOR ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING TO TURN OFF THE TRIGGER
TO THE PROPOSED CUTS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
YOUR STAFF IN THE WEEKS AHEAD
ON OTHER SOLUTIONS TO REDUCE
THE STATE BUDGET. DEFICIT THANK
YOU. NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE
FIFTY. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS JERRY BROWN AND
SEIU CALIFORNIA. YOU KNEW TO BE
MINDFUL NOT TO REPEAT THE
MISTAKES OF THE PAST HAVE BEEN
LACK. HE IS WE NEED TO CUT TO
THE BONE- WHERE IT IS OKAY KATE
RECOVER SOME OF NEVER FULLY
RECOVER MANY ON A CONDOM IS TO
HAVE ARGUED THAT ACTUALLY SLOW
WHO. YES HE HAD UNANIMOUS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE BE MINDFUL OF
COOL AND PAYING FOR ANY
SHORTFALL IN FEDERAL FUNDS.
WERE ULTIMATELY PAY OFF ANY OF
THE BAR- SENATOR SKINNER'S
CONVERSATION WITH THE LA I HOPE
MAY PROVE INSTRUCTIVE EVEN
AFTER I THINK THERE ARE OTHER
DOES NOT IT'S A INTO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT SHOULD
BE. LORD WE ASK. FRONTLINE WHO
ARE NOW CALLING HEROES TO
WORKERS. HI SING EVERY DAY ARE
NOT SACRIFICE THEIR ON THE ROAD
EVEN MORE DEEPLY WITH CUTS TO
THE BUDGET THANK YOU. NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE FIFTY SEVEN.
LINE FIFTY SEVEN IF YOU'RE A
NEW YOU'LL NEED TO AND MEET
YOURSELF. THEY DON'T CARE-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GIVE
YOU WORK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION I'D
LIKE TO ECHO- THE REQUEST OF
THE- L. TRAVEL- REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THE ONE TIME OF FORTY FIVE.
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION FOR
BASIC CALIFORNIA- IN ADDITION
TO PROVIDING REVENUE FOR- STATE
AND LOCAL COFFERS- IT WILL ALSO
HELP- BELEAGUERED NEWSPAPER
INDUSTRY- WITH- POTENTIAL
ADVERTISING AND THE- AS SHE
POINTED OUT- WITH VISIT
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN AFTER NINE
ELEVEN- THE PROGRAM PROP PAID
OFF EXPONENTIALLY- IN THE
ADDITIONAL REVENUES AND SO WE-
ARE SEEKING YOUR- CONSIDERATION
OF THIS REQUEST THANK YOU. NEXT
WE LOOK AT A LINE FIFTY NINE.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS STILL
A PROBLEM AFTER THE SOUTH COAST
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
WE LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE
PARTICIPATION IN THE NAVY FIVE
TWO HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY
HERE PROTECTION PLAN TO FUNDING
FOR LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS.
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LACK OF
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEENTH
INSTRUMENTATION FUNDING. CHEN
PROCEEDS ARE NOT TO BE ENOUGH
TO FUNDING FOR EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION. WHICH
HAS BEEN GIVEN SECOND PARTY IN
THE BUDGET. AND WITHOUT THIS
CRITICAL FUNDING BURKE BY AIR
DISTRICTS WOULD COMMUNITIES TO
CLEAN UP LOCAL AIR POLLUTION.
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY SLOW OR STOP
ALTOGETHER. THIS IS PROBLEMATIC
SPECIALLY FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. GIVEN FINANCIAL EXPOSURE
TO AIR POLLUTION COMBINED WITH
COLLUDED NINETEEN MAY RESULT IN
INCREASED GAS AND EXACERBATE
NECK AND HEALTH AND TAX. AND
WE'D LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
LABEL FOR HER SUPPORT COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONE MORE
TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE NO ONE
LONG DON I'M ACTUALLY BEGAN THE
LAST PROCESS. SURE IF YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE WILL GO TO LINE
SIXTY. HEY AND VISITED DARBY
KERNAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL THE- I WON IT
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
LONG. COMMON AND THE COUNTY YOU
KNOW THAT THESE ARE
UNPRECEDENTED TIME. AND WE WORK
TO MAKE SURE WORK ALL NEEDS.
AND PROBLEMS TOGETHER WE ARE
ASKING FOR AND REALIGNMENT
FUNDING THE BACK BUILD THE NEED
IS GREATER THAN IT'S EVER BEEN
AND SO WE ARE LOOKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE DATE.
FIND THE NEEDED. THE SERVICE IN
ALONE THE IN IN THAT WORKING
AND THE DEMAND WE WANT TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION MAKE SURE THAT-
DEFINING CAN BE WORKED OUT AND
WE CAN KEEP GETTING PEOPLE THAT
MERGING PETER WITHIN THEY NEED
INCLUDING MEDICAL MENTAL HEALTH
ECONOMIC. EIGHT MEN AND YOU
NEED DURING THE CENTER IN TIME
THANK YOU. AND THERE IS NO ONE
OUT THANK YOU. EXCELLENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR WE
APPRECIATE YOU FOR YOUR HELP
AND EVERYONE WHO'S TESTIFIED
WHAT TO THINK- OF A SENATE
THANKS ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY IN THE
PUBLIC- TESTIMONY. IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO SURVIVE THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIALHEARING RECORD THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
PARTICIPATION. THANKS TO ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE AND TO
FINANCE IN THE LA FOR YOUR
PATIENCE- AND BRINGING FOR YOUR
EXPERTISE TODAY- SUB COMMITTEES
WILL COMMENCE ON WEDNESDAY AND
WE ANTICIPATE. THAT THE NEXT
FULL. SENATE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE HEARING WILL
TAKE PLACE ON THE TWENTY EIGHTH
WE STAND ADJOURNED THANK YOU.